right from the start software
development comprise two different
departments the development team that
develops the plan designs and builds the
system from scratch and the operation
team for testing and implementation of
whatever is developed the operations
team gave the development team feedback
on any bugs that needed fixing and any
rework required invariably the
development team would be idle awaiting
feedback from the operations team
this undoubtedly extended timelines and
delayed the entire software development
cycle
there would be instances where the
development team moves on to the next
project while the operations team
continues to provide feedback for the
previous code
this meant weeks or even months for the
project to be closed and final code to
be developed now what if the two
departments came together and worked in
collaboration with each other what if
the wall of confusion was broken
and this is called the devops approach
the devops symbol resembles an infinity
sign suggesting that it is a continuous
process of improving efficiency and
constant activity the devops approach
makes companies adapt faster to updates
and development changes the teams can
now deliver quickly and the deployments
are more consistent and smooth though
there may be communication challenges
devops manages a streamlined flow
between the teams and makes the software
development process successful the
devops culture is implemented in several
phases with the help of several tools
let's have a look at these phases
the first phase is the planning phase
where the development team puts down a
plan keeping in mind the application
objectives that are to be delivered to
the customer
once the plan is made the coding begins
the development team works on the same
code and different versions of the code
are stored into a repository with the
help of tools like get and merged when
required this process is called version
control the code is then made executable
with tools like maven and gradle in the
build stage
after the code is successfully built it
is then tested for any bugs or errors
the most popular tool for automation
testing is selenium
once the code has passed several manual
and automated tests we can say that it
is ready for deployment and is sent to
the operations team
the operations team now deploys the code
to the working environment the most
prominent tools used to automate these
phases are ansible docker and kubernetes
after the deployment the product is
continuously monitored and nagios is one
of the top tools used to automate this
phase
the feedback received after this phase
is sent back to the planning phase and
this is what forms the core of the
devops life cycle that is the
integration phase
jenkins is the tool that sends the code
for building and testing if the code
passes the test it is sent for
deployment and this is referred to as
continuous integration
there are many tech giants and
organizations that have opted for the
devops approach for example amazon
netflix walmart facebook and adobe
netflix introduced its online streaming
service in 2007.
in 2014 it was estimated that a downtime
for about an hour would cost netflix 200
000
however now netflix can cope with such
issues they opted for devops in the most
fantastic way
netflix developed a tool called the
simeon army that continuously created
bugs in the environment without
affecting the users
this chaos motivated the developers to
build a system that does not fall apart
when any such thing happens
so on this note here is a quiz for you
match the devops tool with the phase it
is used in
a
b
c
[Music]
d
none of the above
today more and more companies lean
towards automation with the aim of
reducing its delivery time and the gap
between its development and operations
teams to attain all of these there's
just one gateway
devops
and if you're also looking forward to
doing the same and excel in devops check
out simply learn's postgraduate program
in devops design and collaboration with
caltech ctme
the program can help you master several
in-demand devops skills and tools like
continuous integration and delivery
devops on cloud kubernetes docker and
much more hey everyone
have you ever thought
what would have helped netflix to evolve
from shipping dvds to streaming videos
over the web or
what would have helped amazon to predict
how much equipment to buy to meet
traffic demands
how do you think nasa was able to
analyze data from mars rover's curiosity
what would have made it possible for
walmart to become the kink of big box
retailers or what would have helped
facebook to refresh its mobile app so
rapidly
the answer to all these questions is
devops
the devops market generated 3.36 billion
dollars in 2017 and it is expected to
generate
9.40 billion dollars by 2023
devops is helping many organizations to
automate their entire process the
process allows any organization to
create and improve their products at a
faster pace than traditional models
so now let's see what is devops
devops as the name suggests is a
combination of two practices dev refers
to development and ops refers to
operations
devops is not a workflow but a culture
that brings these two teams together the
development team writes codes for new
products security updates and bug fixes
while the operation team looks after the
servers and make sure that the
deployments happen more reliably and
frequently
the main focus of devops is towards
integrating these two teams to improve
collaboration and increase productivity
by automating the entire process of
software development
devops has several stages and tools to
ensure that all the process is
implemented in the best possible manner
let us look at all these stages with the
tools that play a very significant role
in that phase
beginning with the development phase the
first step is to put down a plan that
includes modules and the algorithms to
be used in the software
once the plan is finalized it is
developed with tools like git
as git helps to store all the codes and
different versions of those codes
this is called the version control
system
this code is now fetched and made
executable in the next stage and that is
called the build phase
the phase uses tools like gradle and
maven
after the code is made executable it is
supposed to be tested
the next stage tests the code for any
bugs and the most famous tool used in
this phase is selenium
once the testing is done deployment
comes into consideration
this is where the work of the operations
team begins in the deployment phase the
product is deployed and this deployed
product is continuously configured to
the desired state
the tools that could be used to automate
these phases are ansible puppet and
docker
the product from here is continuously
monitored for any failures
and the most common tool that makes it
possible is negios
the feedback of all the monitoring is
sent back to the planning phase this
process is repeated in continuous cycles
and this happens until a satisfactory
result is reached
this completes the entire devops cycle
that is the process of automation from
the planning phase to the monitoring
phase
this is what is referred to as the core
of devops life cycle the integration
phase jenkins another devops tool is
known for sending the code for build and
test and if this code passes the test it
is further deployed and monitored
let's have a look at some features that
are making industries move towards
devops
increasing customer satisfaction
improved response time
fewer chances of implementation failure
reduction in it cost better business
agility
high employee productivity and
satisfaction
faster delivery
better release control
frequent software releases
better collaboration among teams
automated server configuration
now when you know so much about devops
you must be curious about what would the
future of devops hold it is quite
evident that devops is on the rise and
it is going to have a long way ahead
there are several fields that devops is
going to be explored in in the near
future
every organization has started leaning
towards automation so devops will play a
significant role in new upcoming
organizations when everything moves
towards automation there will be a need
for devops in the security field devops
framework in ai and ml will help the
devops team to focus on innovation and
creativity by enabling them to manage
the amount and speed of data more
efficiently
devops focuses on infrastructure as code
which ensures continuity as all the
processes from building to staging are
configured automatically with no place
for human error
the future of devops will make the
culture more accessible there is no
industry that would not want to shift
towards more reliability in deployment
every organization wishes to deliver its
product in shorter durations and reduce
the gap between its development team and
the operations team
all these scenarios are going to take
devops to the new height very soon
some organizations have already shifted
towards devops and many are planning to
do the same hence the jobs for devops
engineers are certainly going to rise in
the market in the near future
so
when are you planning to master devops
you can begin today with simplylearn's
devops certification training course
my name is antoine victor and i'll be
your instructor for this devops training
in this training we'll look at what is
devops the devops lifecycle devops tools
talk a little bit about version control
and then we'll get into ci and cd that's
continuous integration and continuous
delivery and then we'll follow on with
configuration management
containerization and finally finishing
up there with monitoring so let's go
ahead and dive right in with a
definition of devops so what is devops
really well devops largely is a cultural
shift it's an organization-wide cultural
shift towards delivering business value
to the end customer now this means that
development and operations both have to
work together now because devops is a
clipped compound which includes only
development and operations it might seem
like devops is just for developers and
operations staff but the reality is if
we were to include everything that
devops really contained devops
containing development operations
obviously but also quality assessment uh
security configuration management
infrastructure management network
management and so on and so on and so on
the the name wouldn't sound cool it
wouldn't be a good marketing term anyway
anymore so let's assume for now that
devops includes not just development
operations but everything on the
software delivery pipeline from idea to
business value making it into the
customer's hands so developers
continuously want to develop and test
code so they're building new features
they're rewarded for delivering new
features to the end customer on the
other hand the operations team is in
charge of keeping the network and the
production software in a running state
so for them
less changes are better so you can see
we've got kind of opposing missions here
between development and operations
development wants to deliver new
features but the operation of delivering
new features tends to cause downtime
which the operations team are rewarded
for maintaining the opposite of that
which is uptime so in order to
get these guys working together the
development team and the operations team
working together to enable continuous
deployment we have to automate a lot of
these historically manual processes so
what we're really talking about here is
the devops life cycle or the software
delivery life cycle where we plan and
again because we're talking about the
entire team working together here we're
planning but not planning everything we
plan just enough to get get the next
iteration done and then we code but just
enough to complete the features that we
plan to deliver in the coming release
and then we compile or build that
solution and once we get a successful
build of that solution then we go on and
test that solution and only on
successful completion of all of those
tests uh do we move on to the next phase
where we integrate the code that one
team member has just submitted got a
successful build on and then a
successful test run then we take that
code and we integrate it with all the
code that was written by the other
developers on the team and then we test
it again and once we are successful with
that integrated build and that
integrated test run then we can move on
to configuring the environment that
we're going to deploy this successfully
compiled and tested solution too that's
where configuration management comes
into play uh it's best to avoid
configuration drift and incorrect
configurations by automating this
process of configuring those servers
that we're going to deploy our solution
to so with configuration management and
automated configuration our goal is to
automate this process so we can be more
consistent and reliable and once we've
configured the system that we're going
to deploy to then we want to use
automated deployment to deploy to those
systems that have been configured in a
consistent way one now we want to now
deploy to them in a consistent and
reliable way and finally once those
solutions are deployed successfully into
our stable consistently configured
environment we want to monitor the
ongoing use of those solutions to make
sure that users are getting the features
and the performance that they expect
from the solution that we've delivered
so let's start at the beginning let's
say we want to build a website for a
company we might have a customer that
comes to us and says hey i want to build
a new website for my organization and we
might respond you know you can use
devops tools and techniques to build
your website and streamline your
delivery process hey that sounds like a
great idea let's do it so let me hire
some developers testers and operations
guys who can develop and test and
maintain the website and then after
gathering all the requirements the
developers can start building the code
for the website and store each version
of that code in a source code repository
but for now we'll call it github we'll
say we're using github so we've got a
couple of developers and then we've got
our github repository to store all of
our solution artifacts so at this point
we've done a little bit of the planning
we've collected some requirements for
our customer we've started on the coding
we've stored some of the code in our
local git repository or maybe we're
using uh the microsoft stack and we
might be using the tool formerly known
as team foundation services uh it's now
called azure devops but as far as source
control uses the same foundations as get
so we get our code into version control
so we might have multiple files that the
developers have created developers are
working on file one file two file three
and they check those files in the github
repository as version one another team
of developers might be working on
different features that might impact
those same files so they're working on
file three but have made a couple
versions of it a couple of iterations to
it so they're on file 3.3 while team one
is only on file three as we merge those
different branches of changes together
we create version two of the solution
but if anything goes wrong anywhere
along the way we've kept those branches
of changes separate so one will not
affect the other this is the benefit of
version control uh and source control
tools like git and github so the basic
architecture of git here we have a
working directory we've got a local
staging area where we prepare changes
that we've made to be committed to the
local repository and then to share those
changes with other developers on the
team uh we can push the changes out to a
remote repository to receive changes
that other developers have made or other
team members have made we can pull those
changes down from the remote repository
so back to our website project here now
the developers have built the code using
whatever tools they chose to use whether
they be dotnet eclipse or some other
editing tool we can then take that code
and make sure that code is valid by
compiling it packaging it and then
having the code verified by our quality
assurance team now in order for other
team members to access this code it's
best if it's moved to that central
repository the github that we were
talking about earlier so our developers
write their code they compile it make
sure it runs and the tests all pass
locally and they can push that out to
our central repository in github now
we've talked about planning and we've
talked about testing and we've talked
about the uh the compiling and the
source code repository but we didn't
really talk about how that compiling is
being done so one of the ways that we
might build java code is by using a tool
called maven now maven is what we can
use to define how our build is going to
be done and automate our build process
so once we have that planning and
building phase done our solution has
been tested and stored in version
control we might want to run some
additional tests for that we need the
testers the testers are going to test
the code that we built to make sure
there are no errors that perhaps weren't
caught by our our automated testing that
was part of the development process so
the testers are going to perform
functional tests they may rerun some of
the unit tests created by the developers
system tests and user acceptance tests
to fully vet the solution to make sure
that it's ready for prime time so again
at this point we've done a little bit of
planning we've done some coding we've
done some building of that code and some
automated unit testing of that code and
now we've passed it off to the qa team
so they can do more exhaustive testing
of that solution now some of the
additional tests that the qa team might
run would be ui automation tests
exploratory tests smoke tests to find
issues that may not have been exposed by
the low-level testing unit testing that
developers may have done during the
development process using test-driven
development once the qa team is finished
doing that additional testing making
sure that we didn't miss anything with
our automated testing process then the
operations team will need to integrate
those changes along with anything that's
already out there in production maybe a
previous version of the solution
existing data from an old database or
what have you we can use continuous
integration to make sure that all that
code all those changes that are being
made by different team members is
compiled and tested and deployed
together on the production servers in a
consistent way so again we've gone from
planning to developing or coding rather
and building that code and testing that
code to integrating those changes with
changes that the other developers on the
team have made and finally running
additional tests and after all of our
tests are passed pushing that solution
out to production servers or production
like servers as we prepare for
additional tests like load and stress
tests now this operation this automation
process of moving these resources out
into the qa environment and on into the
pre-production staging environments and
finally off into production there are
several tools that we can use to
automate this process some of the more
common tools listed here on the slide
jenkins bamboo and travis ci that's uh
continuous integration and of course
azure devops not here on the slide so a
common example of using ci and cd and
jenkins is again we have our developers
doing their work uh hopefully writing
their tests first so when they complete
their work they can commit their work to
our source code repository uh and that
act of committing the work the source
code repository can cause a tool like
jenkins to automatically fire off a
continuous integration trigger to build
that solution test that solution and if
it passes potentially deploy that
solution off to the next environment but
if it fails we can reject that check-in
to the repository and send notification
back to the developer or other team
member that introduced that defect
allowing them to fix that defect before
it causes any problems for other team
members now of course if that build and
that test run passes then jenkins can
automatically move that change that
version of the solution onto the next
environment now that next environment
this case is the qa environment where
now the testers have access to that
solution and the testers can perform
more exhaustive exploratory testing uh
user acceptance testing and so forth if
they then find any errors then they can
push that feedback back down to the
development team who can then fix those
uh issues and then resubmit that code
through the continuous integration
pipeline now if the testers don't find
any defects then they would promote or
approve that solution for promotion into
the production environment or again we
might have a more complex environment
where we push from qa into a staging
environment where we then continue to
run load and stress testing so so far in
our ci cd pipeline here we have the
developers making the changes we have
the developers pushing those changes
into a code repository like git we have
the build system or the continuous
integration system like jenkins
detecting that change in git and then
automatically compiling and testing
those changes submitted by the developer
and on the test framework side we have
unit tests which are most likely written
by the developers as they're writing the
code or before they write the code if
we're using test driven or test first
development and then we have web ui
testing done with tools like selenium
and then integration testing which could
be additional unit tests
run with those ui tests and other
acceptance tests on our integration
server now as we move on from continuous
integration to continuous delivery and
continuous deployment uh there are other
tools that we can employ like serena and
pivotal cf as well as google's cloud
platform azure and amazon's aws to
assist in this automation of delivery
and deployment so uh a textbook
definition of continuous delivery is to
be ready and able to deploy any version
of our solution to any supported
platform at any time continuous
deployment is basically the same thing
but without the ready enable with
continuous deployment as the name
implies you are continuously deploying
every change that successfully makes it
through compile and test automatically
to the production environment or at
least to a production slot whereas
continuous delivery we're just ready to
deploy it because we've done all of our
compiling and testing maybe even we've
done some more exploratory testing
manual testing and even some automated
load and stress testing but in any event
the solution is ready to be deployed
it's just not deployed yet with
continuous delivery with continuous
deployment as the name implies we have
actually deployed the solution so now
the solution is deployed the operations
team is going to want to make sure the
systems and deploy the code onto the
production environment in a consistent
way for that we need configuration
management to help make sure the systems
are configured in a consistent state and
functioning properly for the version of
the software that's about to be deployed
this avoids configuration drift and
incorrectly configured devices using a
configuration tool like ansible puppet
or chef we can make sure that the
configuration happens automatically and
in a consistent way so every deployment
is either successful or fails the exact
same way it failed last time because the
failure was part of the automation some
devops tools that we can use for these
uh configuration operations
are puppet docker chef
and ansible now these tools are the most
common tools used for this deployment
and configuration automation phase of
our devops delivery pipeline so again
configuration management is the process
of systematically managing and handling
changes to a system in a way that
maintains integrity over time how does
it do that you might ask well it does
that by doing the configuration in the
automated and consistent way so the same
way we take our code and we compile it
we test it and make sure that it's past
those tests and compile successfully we
can take our configuration and do that
in the same automated way and once we
have a configuration automation script
that works successfully we can then take
that configuration automation script
that playbook that recipe or what have
you and store it in the source code
repository along with the rest of the
solution artifacts the code and any
documentation that we might have
collected or created over time and put
it in that central source of truth
github our central repository or
whatever tool that you choose now we
have everything either in our artifact
repository that would be the output of
our build our deployment package or in
our source code repository which is all
of our source code documents
configuration files and so forth we have
a central source of truth for all of the
resources necessary to successfully
deploy this solution so even if we had
nothing more than our source code
repository our artifact repository and
bare metal resources we could reproduce
this solution so puppet's an open source
configuration management tool for
deploying managing and configuring
multiple servers in an automated way
very consistent so we basically have uh
the notion of nodes for the the puppets
if you will that are controlled by the
puppet master so what basically happens
here is the node sends the data about
itself to the puppet master the puppet
uses that information to compile a
catalog that shows how that node is
supposed to be configured but if over
time something changes
and that node reports back the puppet
master that the configuration is
incorrect incomplete or has changed
something that's non-standard then the
puppet master can then push down uh
updated configuration to keep that
server in a standard state consistent
with its stored configuration and all
the other nodes that are necessary for
that solution to run now as far as
deployment to these different servers
and configured resources an easy way to
make sure that deployment is consistent
is to really avoid the redundant
configuration and deployment of those
solutions to multiple servers
individually by deploying into a
container and then using that container
to replicate that configuration across
multiple devices and resources
containerization is basically the
process that allows software to run
reliably when moved from one computing
environment to another because it's not
dependent on the local computing
environment itself rather on the
container host if you will basically a
virtual machine requires that we use up
a lot of resources and install a full
copy of the operating system inside of
that virtual machine and that virtual
machine basically needs all the same
hardware that the operating system needs
to run containers on the other hand
live inside of that host machine and
effectively are segmented from all of
that hardware and requirements of having
a full operating system they're
basically small containers inside of the
existing operating system so we get the
same level of isolation without all the
overhead requirements of having a full
virtual machine with installed operating
system this allows us to easily deploy
the containers without all the headaches
of installing an operating system and
redoing the configuration so docker
containers are basically standard units
of software that package the code and
all other dependencies so that the
application runs faster and it's
reliable from one computing environment
to another again because it's not
dependent on the underlying hardware or
even the underlying operating system but
just the container host so the
operations team verifies that the
website is functioning correctly and the
entire architecture is working properly
and once it is then we can continue to
monitor the website on an ongoing basis
and make sure that performance doesn't
degrade over time to check and see what
features users are actually using and
what features that they're not so we can
send that feedback back the development
team so they can make changes as needed
to make sure that we're meeting the
requirements of the customers so
operations team monitors collecting
feedback from the website and doesn't do
as much good to collect that feedback if
we don't have an easy way to push that
feedback back into the team that built
the solution in the first place so some
tools that we can use to collect that
monitoring information to collect that
ongoing usage information are splunk
nagios and new relic tools i'm sure
you've heard of before for monitoring on
the enterprise scale and being able to
collect that log information to collect
that
monitoring information that those key
metrics and display them in an easily
consumable way so basically monitoring
is that process of detecting examining
and reporting if there are any faults or
threats in the entire infrastructure so
not just with the hardware but also with
the operating system with the software
that's running on that operating system
with any of the containers with the
network with the memory anything that
might impact in a negative way the
execution of our solution should be
collected and alerted on using our
monitoring tools so nagios allows you to
monitor the server and check and see if
there are any underutilized resources or
if there are any task failures that need
to be addressed or any other critical
issues that might cause a negative
impact to the service of our customers
so basically nagios has a plug-in that
we install that allows it to load
resources or log data or alert
information from those remote servers
and send them to a central location
where they can be aggregated and
displayed through the web interface this
allows operations team members that are
monitoring those systems in production
to easily see and aggregate that data so
they don't have to go and look at
individual reports from every single
server that they're responsible for if
there's a problem then the tool will
notify the admin about the status of
whatever resource is having an issue
choose from over 300 in-demand skills
and get access to 1 000 plus hours of
video content for free visit scale up by
simply learn click on the link in the
description to know more and in this
demo we are going to demonstrate uh some
of the uses of the common commands in
git so uh we're gonna use get version to
check our get version i will use git
help to list some of the help commands
there and then we'll use
git commit
git add git init and get status to
manage a basic get repository so let's
go ahead and get started you can see i'm
on my c drive in a git repos folder here
so i'm just going to right click and say
get bash here
open a bash command prompt here and
we'll increase the size of the font so
you can see it better there and here
we'll start with uh just get version you
can see i'm running get version 2.21.0
for windows and uh to see what's in this
folder we'll do an ls as you can see the
folder is empty i do not have any
repositories yet so i'm going to do a
make directory and i'll make a directory
called uh hello
java see i've got my hello java folder
now so i will change directory into the
hello java folder and here we'll do a
get status to see if this hello java
folder is a repository no it is not a
repository yet because we just created
it so we're going to do a git admit to
initialize this repository and you can
see now at the end of the command prompt
here we have master indicating that we
are in a git repository and we are on
the master branch
so now if we run a git status it says we
are on branch master there are no
commits yet and there is nothing to
commit so let's create a new file and
we'll create the file hello
dot java see we have that file now i'm
not going to bother with the vim editor
in here i'll show you why in just a few
minutes here but i'm going to go into my
hello java folder and i'm just going to
edit this file using notepad and i'm
just going to create a very basic class
here in my class is going to be called
hello so i'm going to create a public
class
hello and my public hello class is going
to have a single public
static method let's spell static
correctly that returns no values and is
called main this method accepts string
array as
the argument list
all this function is going to do is
simply print something to the console so
this will print hello world to the
console so we're going to do that by
doing a system dot out
dot print line and what we're going to
print is hello world we can't have a
programming demo without at least one
hello world so there it is so that's our
class
i'm just going to save our class and
close the editor here you can see we've
got our hello java file there on the
windows explorer again double check that
it's here and we'll do a cat hello dot
java to see that we do have those
contents of the file now if we do a git
status you will see that we have our
hello java with untracked changes so in
order to be able to commit our new java
file to our repo we're going to have to
do a get
add and the name of the file we want to
add in this case hello java adding it to
the staging area where if we do a git
status we'll see now it's green it's a
tracked change but it still has yet to
be committed to the repository so to
commit we're going to do
git commit now normally what i want to
do is put a dash m in my commit message
but i want to show you why i didn't use
the bim editor earlier by doing a git
commit and it says hey you have to add
your commit message so here's this text
based editor for you i'm not really a
fan of this text-based editor but if we
start typing we get the insert command
and we can type added hello dot java
file and then we have to hit escape to
get out of insert mode and then we have
to type colon x
enter to save and exit in the case of
creating a file to open notepad to
create the file or in the case of
committing to just use the dash m switch
and put your message right there on the
commit line we do our git status again
you can see that we now have nothing to
commit because we have committed our
change already now the next thing that
we might want to do here is to push our
changes to a remote repository like
github but if we try to do a get
push
normally we would call that remote repo
origin
and we'd want to push to the master
branch we try to do that without first
specifying
where that remote branch is
it's going to give us a error message
and the error message basically says
origin does not appear to be a git
repository and could not read from the
remote repository make sure you have
correct access rights and the repository
exists make that message a little more
clear if we delete where we are trying
to go we just do a get push it tells us
that we first need to specify a remote
repository using get remote so if we do
get remote
add origin it wants them the url to our
remote repository so to get to that
uh what we'll do here is we will launch
a new instance of the browser and we
will go to github on github here we are
going to
first create a new repository call our
new repository hello let's call it hello
world we'll accept all the defaults here
and create our repository and then it
gives us here
the url to our repository so i'm just
going to copy the url to the clipboard
and then switch back over here to my get
remote ad and i'm going to paste in the
url to that repository now i have a
reference to my remote repository and
now we should be able to successfully
commit our changes to that remote
repository but before we do that let's
take a look at the repository you can
see this repository has no files in it
it's completely empty it says we can
create a file or upload an existing file
or import code from another repository
all we are gonna do is complete our get
push to the origin master enter and
after a few seconds here you'll see that
our push completed successfully and we
can switch back to the browser and do a
quick refresh and you can see that our
one file hello.java has been added with
our commit message added hello.java file
or class in parentheses so at this point
we have created a file added it to our
local repository uh and then pushed that
file to our remote repository where we
then might be able to share that file
with other developers or other team
members working on this solution we are
going to do another demo here on jenkins
uh and in this demo we are going to
first create a basic jenkins job uh to
run a windows batch command uh and then
we'll build another jenkins job that
pulls a very simple java class from
github and builds that java class and
executes it as part of our jenkins job
so first thing let's take a quick peek
at jenkins here and in jenkins a couple
of key locations that you're going to
want to be aware of are the manage
jenkins area here and inside of managed
jenkins we have the area where we can do
our global tool configuration and this
is where we would set up tools like
maven for compiling our solutions the
jdk for accessing java there's our maven
access if we want to set up docker
containers as part of our jenkins jobs
we'd also want to set up a reference to
our docker installation here
we're going to do a pretty basic demo so
we won't have the need for any of these
tools but if we go back to our dashboard
and then back to manage jenkins uh
there's also an area here where you can
manage the plugins that are installed in
jenkins now i here shows the updates
that are available and since i just
installed jenkins and loaded all the
updates there are no new updates
available but if we click on the
installed tab you can see all of the
default or rather recommended plug-ins
that jenkins loaded after installation
after installation it will basically ask
if you want to do a manual installation
of just the plug-ins that you want or if
you want jenkins to go ahead and install
the recommended plug-ins and this is
what you get if you install the
recommended plugins for our purposes uh
in a later demo we'll be using the get
plug-in and you can see here that's
installed by default as part of that
recommended setup okay so we're going to
start by creating a new jenkins job
pretty basic jenkins job here and we're
going to call it
uh hello
jenkins you can see i've done this
before and we're going to set that as a
freestyle project so we can build it
from scratch and in this demo we're not
going to pull anything from github we're
just going to send a very simple command
and so we're going to scroll down to the
build step and we're going to add a
build step called execute windows batch
command and in this windows batch
command we are just going to echo
something to the console where we're
going to say hello
from the jenkins job and we're also
going to display the date and the time
that this request came in and then we'll
go ahead and save that and now when we
go and build this project very quickly
we get a success because there wasn't
much to execute and then if we click on
the build there we go look at the
console output you can see that we
successfully
ran this job and printed to the console
hello from the jenkins job wednesday 3
20 2019 15 39
and 29.96 seconds
success so let's up the ante a little
bit let's go back to the dashboard and
now we'll build another new project uh
this project we'll call this one yep you
guessed it hello github and i again
we'll make it a freestyle project so we
can build from scratch and we're going
to tell it that we're getting
this code that we want to build from our
remote repository so it's going to want
the url to our remote repository just so
happens i have that open over here we're
going to get our hello world repository
here so i'm going to grab the clone or
download and copy the link to the
repository once i have that link i can
come back over here into github
i'm sorry into jenkins and i can paste
that link to my github repository now uh
if your repository requires
authentication you'll want to go and add
that credential in your jenkins
credential provider and add those
additional credentials that you want to
use here believe i've already added the
credential for that github account so
all we need to do now is just add our
build step and our build step in this
case is again going to be a
windows command your windows batch
command and we're going to do java
c for the java compiler and we want to
compile
hello dot java and then we want to run
using the java runtime the
hello java class that we just created so
now we can go ahead and save and then we
can now build this job
small delay while we compile and the
blue sphere there means that we were
successful with our compile and run of
this job if we go and look here in the
console output we can see
that
we compiled our java hello and then we
executed our java hello and got hello
world on the console that concludes our
jenkins demo and in this demo we are
going to uh install puppet and the
puppet agent on three nodes in aws so to
that end we'll create three instances in
our aws console here we'll start with
the puppet master instance and we'll
create that on an ubuntu server and
we're going to use a t2 medium with dual
core cpus and four gigabytes of ram now
we're gonna put it into a security group
that has all ports open just so we don't
have to deal with any firewall issues
and we'll just double check in the
instance details subnet usage
uh we'll let it go ahead and create its
own subnet here and then we'll review
after it's created to make sure that our
other nodes end up in the same subnet as
for tags here we're just going to add a
new name tag and we're going to say
puppet master and then we will launch
this server and use the
oregon key here since we are using the
oregon data center go ahead and launch
that instance and we'll view this
instance again just to review the subnet
id that it's on and it's on subnet with
the last three characters of 4d4 so now
we'll go ahead and launch our two
nodes again using ubuntu server this
time we're just going to use the t2
micro one cpu one gigabyte ram because
it's in our free tier eligible tier so
we'll go ahead and again set the
security group to everybody all in
review and launch and then we'll update
in the instance details the number of
nodes we're going to get two nodes this
time 12 two nodes this time and then the
subnet and going to use that
4d4 subnet so that we can access the
master node and then we'll add a tag
name tag called puppet nodes and review
and launch and we'll launch those nodes
again with the oregon key and we'll
launch those instances all right so if
you view our instances we've got our
puppet master and i'm going to edit
these names here and call this puppet
nodes 1 and we'll call this one puppet
nodes 2 just so we can keep track of
which is which now first things first
here we want to connect to our puppet
master using putty and to do that we're
going to use its public ip address and
then we'll go launch putty here i've
already got a setting here for puppet
master but we need to paste in that
updated ip address and then just to make
sure that we are using the correct key
and there's our oregon key now we can go
ahead and connect but before i connect
i'm going to go ahead and save that and
now we have a connection to our puppet
master then now that our nodes are up
we'll connect to the public ip of our
puppet node 1 again using putty agent
connection here paste in our proper ip
address and again just double check to
make sure we're using the right
certificate and no we're not so let's
change that to our
oregon key and again we'll
save that just so we can reference it
usually later i'm going to move this
window over here and then go and connect
to node 2 using its public ip and again
to putty we'll use that same agent
setting we shouldn't have to double
check and make sure that the certificate
is correct because we just saved it just
in case anything has gone horribly wrong
yes we see we're using the same organ
i'm not going to save this one i'll just
switch the ip back and forth and we have
a connection to our second node so we
now have
node 1 node 2 and our master node over
here so now we can begin
to add our settings so first up on our
puppet master we are going to set its
hostname to puppet we're going to do
that using the hostname ctl set hostname
command and we're going to do that using
a
super user do and set that host name to
puppet now we'll do uh the same on the
nodes setting them to puppet agent and
puppet node respectively but before we
do that let's go ahead and edit our host
file so that we can tell the system what
the local ip address is for our puppet
master now to do this we're going to go
back over to aws we're going to grab our
puppet master and grab its private ip
address then we'll jump back over to our
puppet masters host file and we'll paste
in that ip address along with the name
of our server puppet then we'll use
control x
y and enter to save that file now we'll
do the same on each of our puppet nodes
we'll first set our agent to puppet
agent and then we'll set our node to
puppet node and then we'll go back and
edit the host file on each of those
machines and again we're going to grab
that private ip for our puppet master
and we'll include that as well as the
name of that server and we'll do the
same down here and then control x yes to
save the changes enter to save that file
name control x yes to save the changes
and enter to save that file name so now
that we've got the basic dns info set
setup we can continue on with installing
resources on these servers so to do that
we're first going to do a sudo apt get
update to update the package repository
and we'll do that on all three of these
servers here first on the puppet master
then on the agent then or rather than on
node one then on node two and once our
update is complete we will then uh do a
wget to set the puppet labs installation
repository and since we'll need to
install uh the puppet master on the
puppet master obviously and then the
puppet agent on each of our nodes we'll
use this same statement on all three
nodes so wget https colon slash slash
apt dot puppet labs dot com slash puppet
labs dash release dash pc one dash x e n
i a l dot deb go ahead and execute that
on the puppet master on node one and on
node two then after that we want to
reference the package again on all three
nodes sudo
g dash i puppet labs dash release dash p
c one dash x e n i a l dot d e b again
we'll execute that on all three nodes
because we'll need access to that
repository to install both the puppet
master as well as the puppet agent on
all of our nodes and then we'll do a git
update to update our package
repositories again again on all three
nodes we'll do that and finally on the
first node we can go ahead and install
the puppet server so we'll do that with
a super user do
apt get install puppet server dash y
obviously that's going to be a little
bit different than what we do on the
puppet agent on our nodes so on those
additional servers we're going to
execute super user do at get install
puppet dash agent so puppet agent this
time instead of puppet server so sudo
get install puppet dash agent dash y
we'll do that on both of our nodes here
and then we'll jump back to our puppet
master so that on our puppet master we
can complete the configuration by uh
editing the puppet server configuration
file and we'll do that with the super
user do using the nano editor to edit
etc
default slash puppet server now in this
file we need to modify the java args so
we can adjust the memory allocation for
our puppet installation or change that
from two gigabytes down to 512 megabytes
so do that by adding a xms
and xmx 512 m to the java args and then
again we'll control x
yes to save and enter to save to this
file now that we've got the memory
configured we can go ahead and start
puppet server and to do that we'll use
system ctl start puppet server super
user do system ctl start puppet server
and once we've started the puppet server
then we can go ahead and enable it for
auto start when the system starts back
up again and then before we can go any
further on our agents we'll want to set
up a manifest file to install something
on those agents and for this demo we'll
do something pretty simple and
straightforward we'll go ahead and
install maven so that we can later build
java projects but first let's enable our
puppet server for auto start now our
server is up and running we can check
the status of our server using systemctl
status puppet server check and make sure
our puppet server is up and running we
can see here that it is active it's up
and running that means we can now go
ahead and add our maven manifest file so
we'll do that this time using the them
editor and we'll do that with the super
user do them and then the path to our
manifest etc puppet labs slash code
slash environments slash production so
we're working with the production
environment here and in the production
environment we have a manifest folder
that we are going to create a file
called maven dot ppn now in this file
we're going to specify a node
configuration for default nodes so
that's every node that we encounter
we're going to set up a package the
maven package to be installed so we're
going to ensure that that package is
installed and we'll close our package
reference as well as closing our node
configuration and then we will x
enter to save that file all right so now
that we've got our manifest file over
there we can go to our
two puppet nodes and on those puppet
nodes we can edit their puppet
configuration files so that they can
reference the environment that we want
to install our configuration from so
we're going to edit using nano again
using the path etc
puppet labs slash puppet slash puppet
config and in this file we are simply
going to add a reference
to a main section and then we'll include
cert name and we'll set the cert name in
this case to puppet dash
notes node one and then the server equal
to
puppet and the environment
equal to production and again we'll
control x
and y to save and enter to save to that
file we'll do the same down here on node
2 and again we'll create a main section
we'll add a
reference to the cert name puppet dash
node 2 this time and then the server
will still be puppet and the environment
will be production and one more time
we'll control x yes and enter to save
the file now that we've got that set up
we can go ahead and start our puppet
agent service so we'll do that with the
same command that we used earlier sudo
system ctl start puppet this time
instead of puppet server both servers
and then we'll configure those servers
for auto start and just to make sure
everything is doing what it's supposed
to be doing we'll try to telnet to the
puppet server see there that we have
successfully connected to puppet on its
private i p the same thing down here on
node two make sure node two is good also
successfully connected to puppet so now
we can go back to our puppet server and
the act of starting the puppet agent
service on each of our nodes should have
sent a certificate signing request to
our puppet master just to make sure that
we have secure communication so let's
take a look at the cert list on puppet
to see if we have a list of two
certificates to do that we're going to
use uh super user do
opt puppet lab
bin and puppet cert list this should
give us a list of the cert requests that
have come in and you can see there we
have one from node one and another from
node two now we could either sign these
requests one at a time by adding puppet
node one and then puppet node two or we
can sign the requests all at once using
this command super user do slash opt
slash puppet labs slash ben slash puppet
cert sign dash dash all that will sign
both of those requests with one command
instead of having to execute two
separate commands successfully signed
both of our cert requests and now we can
go and execute our configuration now
before we do that let's just double
check and make sure maven is not
installed here we try to do an mvn dash
dash version we get a message that says
command mvn is not found but can be
installed with sudo app install
maven so that tells us very clearly that
mvn is not installed on either of these
nodes so now we can run a super user do
opt slash puppet lab slash ben slash
puppet agent test and this will attempt
to go out to the master uh server the
puppet master and retrieve manifest
files that are configured for this node
or in our case default which is all
nodes that connect and then it'll
install whatever's in the manifest so
we'll run that first on node one and
then we'll run that same command on node
two and you can see that ran very
quickly in .04 seconds and now if we run
mvn
version you can see that maven 3.5.2
was successfully installed on both nodes
and that concludes our demo of puppet
running on aws so from this section the
key takeaways are that devops is largely
an organization-wide cultural shift it's
mostly cultural there's a lot of tools
there's a lot of technologies that we'll
talk about but for the most part devops
is a cultural shift from one way of
doing business from one way of
developing software to a new more agile
optimized way of delivering software and
resources to do that we need tools
obviously so uh things like version
control we talked about git and github
and once we have some changes loaded
into version control then we also need
to have some system in place that can
detect those changes and then make sure
that those changes haven't introduced
defects by making sure that they still
compile or build and after we get a
successful compile making sure that
those changes pass the tests and that
automated tests that we have in place
don't start failing after we've made a
change and then using those same tools
we want to make sure that we get that
successfully compiled and successfully
tested solution off into an environment
where we can do more exhaustive testing
where the qa team can do some manual
testing some exploratory testing or do
more in-depth automated testing and then
finally we want to move into an
environment where the operations team
can make sure the configuration is done
correctly we can make sure the
infrastructure is in place before we
begin to deploy in an automated way to
those production environments and again
with that deployment we want to make
sure that we're doing it in an automated
consistent and reliable way so we'd want
to use an automation tool like puppet or
chef or ansible now to simplify the
deployment plot process and make the
deployment process more repeatable we
can use containerization and
consideration tools like docker to allow
us to deploy in a repeatable reliable
way while minimizing the need for
excessive operating system configuration
or dependency on multiple virtual
machines and finally using log
aggregation tools and monitoring tools
like nagios and splunk and elk we can
collect all the information from these
multiple servers on our devops delivery
pipeline and make sure that we're
alerted instantly if anything happens
that would negatively impact the service
to our customers now in this one this
tutorial by simplylearn is designed in
such a way so that we can give you a
basic understanding that how exactly git
really works now in this one we are
going to talk about various concepts uh
which we involve in gate we are going to
also talk about the various git commands
which we are going to talk about here
and a variety of things and different
kind of demos are also a part of this
one
now git is something which is a really
popular at right now over here before
they get subversion was quite popular
and a lot of organizations were actually
using it but now git is in kind of a
version control system which helps us to
track the changes just like any other
version control system into us a
particular working copy or into our
particular laptop now it's having a
certain benefits which is exactly not
available in any of the other version
control system
so it's used to coordinate the work
among the developers so different
developers are actually
collaborating with each other with the
help of this version control system
they're able to track the progress the
senior developers or the uh leads or the
managers can always find out that what
are the different changes a developer is
doing how the different commits are
happening there so uh it's a wonderful
feature of a version control system that
you get out to complete tracking you get
a complete history so any person can go
ahead with the version control system
and they can really find out that what
exactly it's happening into this one so
all those features are definitely
provided by git also it is used to have
act as a kind of collaboration tool so
that multiple developers can really push
their source code to this remote
repository and then again it also
provides us the tracking mechanism to
track the overall progress of the
development
so the main work of git is to manage the
projects and a couple of repositories
are managed here and in these
repositories you manage your work you
manage your source code and the
developers perform various kind of
activities like checkout check in push
pull different activities they do to
interact with the source code
right so git can be useful for both
programming professionals like the
developers and all and non-programming
particular professionals also now as a
devops engineer if you are not doing the
programming still you can use the get
repositories for having your files for
having your source codes your scripts
you can store ansible scripts you can
store a puppet script you can store
python shell scripts all that things you
can do it for you it is a kind of a
source code for developers they can
store java source code.net source core
android projects so that's a kind of a
source code for those particular
programming language or for those teams
now that is the reason why git is a
really helpful over here because it
provides the comfort or it provides the
help to both the programming
professionals and the non-programming or
non-technical professionals also
right
so uh it also helps in coordinating the
work among the team because of the
tracking feature history feature and the
collaboration here so different
developers can actually use these
repositories so that they can push their
source code to this single location and
then in fact different developers can
you know take updates they can even find
out that what other developers are doing
so they can uh do the uh sync up and
even if someone is not giving you the
you know the particular details still
you will be able to get it from the
repository so that's a kind of a good
collaboration mechanism or tool which
can really help to increase or improve
the communication between the different
developers
so what exactly is a git repository now
a git repository is a place where we
keep all the files related to our
project stored there now there are two
types of git repositories
one is local repository and one is the
remote repository now when we work with
git version control system so what
happens
that we have a central remote repository
which is available there on the git
server now this is something not present
in local system it's an remote server so
when you do a clone activity when you
you know bring that repository into your
local system now what happens that in
git version control system it does not
creates only a working copy but in fact
a local repository is created now this
local repository is having the link up
or it's having the connectivity with the
remote repository so whatever the
changes you will do if you push your
changes to the remote repository that is
something which will be possible with
the help of this version control system
so here it's not like every time you
will be interacting with the remote
repository whenever you feel that you
want to push some changes to the remote
repository at that moment of time there
are some couple of operations like push
and pull activity which you will be
using to interact from the local
repository to the remote repository so
local repository is the one which you
will be bringing on when you clone the
remote repository now remote repository
is the repository which is having the
main important source code so using the
local repository you will be interacting
with the remote repository and that's
how the various kind of operations you
know you can do the modifications
whatever the comments you have performed
you will push it you will pull it so all
those activities you will be able to do
with the help of local and remote
repository so these two type of
repositories are available which we can
further use to make our changes and
perform our particular source code
changes here
right now let's talk about some of the
uh git commands because ultimately when
we work with the get version control
system we have to do a various kind of
operations like pushing the comments
performing the merging so all those
commands let's talk about that
now
the very first one the basic commands
over here is
that git config so git config is the
mechanism using which we can configure
the username and email id now why we
require this when you will be doing some
git comments or you will be doing the
modification so as a standard feature of
version control system it preserves the
author details like uh whatever commit
it wants to do whenever he wants to
create a new version it has to invent uh
some of the author details now this
author details involve an email id and a
particular username
now this email id and username if you
don't configure in that case some dummy
system related email id and username
will be picked up so in that situation
we will not be able to understand that
whether the
particular check-in is done by a
developer or it's being done by a
particular machine so for better
understanding to get a better comfort
that's the reason why we use the git
config over here to configure the
username and email address over here
then we have git init command now this
kit in any command is used to create an
empty bare repository so this command
when you run you will be able to create
a bare empty repository and after that
you can further on do the modifications
you can add some comments you can add
some files and all that stuff you can do
over there pretty much
then when you add some files now what
happens that when you do you want to go
for a git commit activity before that
the files should be present in the
staging area now staging area is a
location where you will be preparing or
you will be storing the files temporary
before even performing any kind of
comment so git add and get commit
command is something which is executed
into a sequence first of all you will
run the git add command to bring all the
changes or all the change file into a
staging area and when you've done the
git commit command so all the files will
be committed now git commit command will
not take up how many files you want to
commit because whatever the files you
will put up into the staging area git
commit command will read all those files
and it will perform single commit for
them so if you feel that you want to
only check in uh two files out of 20
files
please go for the git add command and
first add only these two files into the
staging area if you add all the 20 files
into the staging area then all the 20
files will be modified and a new commit
will be created there
then we have git diff command now the
git div command is used to change to see
the changes made to the files to see the
difference you can use get diff command
with the branches also to see the
difference between the two branches
so git commit command is something which
make sure that all the
changes are saved permanently into the
local repository so get add and get
commit command are executed into a
sequence so that first of all you can
add the files to the staging area and
then git commit command will pick up
those files from the staging area and
preserve permanently as a commit into
the local
repository then we have git reset
command get reset command used in
various types one time you can use it as
in kind of uh just to reset the changes
in the files and in a certain way you
can also use it to delete the comments
from the git repository
git status command displays you the
state of working and the staging area so
uh git status command also tells you
certain particular features like what
are the different files which is you
know in the modification state uh how
many files are there present in the
modified states so all those information
is something which we are getting from
the git status
git merge is on very
good feature because whenever we work
with our different branches so get
merges and mechanism to move the changes
from one branches to another so if you
are required to do the modification to
the develop branch and you want to move
those changes to the master branch in
that situation we have to merge develop
branch into the master branch so it's a
kind of a mechanism to move the changes
from one branch to another
then we have git push now till get merge
command all the commands you can run to
the local repository which means that
you don't require any kind of remote
repository you can simply
work on the local system and without any
network connectivity with the remote
repository you will be able to perform
those changes but git push is a
mechanism to push or move the changes
from the local repository to the remote
repository so whatever the comments you
have done every time it will not
interact with the remote repository only
when you run the git push and pull
command that is where you will be
performing the interaction or
communication between the local
repository and the remote repository
push is to push the changes from local
to remote repository and pull is
something which is pulling up the
updates from the remote repository to
your local repository
right now let's talk about some of the
basic git operations here now
so far we have seen that one of the
different basic git commands are there
which we use time to time to perform the
various operations and various tasks
within the version control system of kit
here now let's talk about the some of
the basic kit operations as such here
now first one the very first one
operation over here is the initialize of
a git repository now this is something
which we perform to create a kind of a
new repository or a new project
then we have add operation
to add some files then
add operation is used to add some
changes or modified files to the staging
area git commit is something which is
used to create a new version of the
group of files then pull is to bring
down the changes from the remote
repository to the local repository then
push is there to push the changes from
the local repository to the remote
repository so these are some of the
basic operations which we perform so
that we can move the changes from one
state to another and the first one is
git init command now it's used to create
a new and empty repository where a
repository over here now once they get a
init command is executed what will
happen uh you will run the git init
command in a folder for example i have
created a folder called gate repo and in
that i have initialized or executed the
git init command now the moment you did
the execution of git init command so
what will happen a dot git directory
will be created in that system
so this dot get directory represents
that you are working right now onto a
git repository
you can also further run the git status
command and find out that okay this is
the repositories preserved over here but
if you don't have the dot get directory
it means that it's a plain folder and it
is not a kind of a git repository
now remember dot git folder is only the
folder which is created there there will
be no files which will be created as
such in this one so git init is only
creating a bare empty repository onto
the system
right now once the repository is
initialized so you can further on go
ahead and add some files some folders or
whatever stuff you want to perform in
that repository
right so in this diagram you can see
that uh when you run the git init
command you will be able to see the dot
get directory created over here and you
will also see that that's the only
folder structure which is created as
such over here so on windows machine you
will be able to see it pretty easily
because of the file name but usually in
the linux platforms dot git is uh
specifically designed or is known as an
hidden folder so all the files and
folder with dot in front will be
considered as hidden there so in that
case you can run ls iphone la rt to get
on and to see the content over there
then we have add operation now once you
fire the modification has done so once
you all the changes are performed there
so you will be adding the uh in order to
perform the comments first of all you
have to add the files to the staging
area so staging area is in a particular
temporary location where the git commit
command will look upon and all the files
which is present in the staging area
will be picked up and all of them will
be preserved or will be converted to a
git comment so before running the git
commit command git add command is
required for the files to be added so
that we will be able to move them to the
comment here now in this case you can
see that git status is the one which we
are running to check on which status we
are right now and uh we have modified
like a file called alpha.txt so git add
dot is what we are trying to run over
here
and uh then you can see that from the
red color earlier it was an untracked
file but now it's became in tracked
files and it says new file and then
further we did the git commit so at that
moment of time what will happen that
this file will be completely checked out
into the repository and uh further after
this one commit if you run git status
command there will be no file present
there so git add and git commit command
i re executed into a sequence so that
they will be able to have a proper
comments there now the commit is in
situation where you will be changing
your history of your repository it makes
sure that the changes which you are
doing is permanently preserved into the
gate repository so get commit command
requires a particular flag called hyphen
m now hyphen m is something which is
there for providing custom message for
what reason you are doing the git
comment now if you don't provide this
message your git commit will fail but
you need to provide a message to uh
specify that what is the reason behind
performing this commit activity so that
is what you are trying to provide over
here with the hyphen m over here and
preserving and providing the details
that yes this is the reason why you are
performing a commit activity into your
local repository
so you can see here that we are giving a
particular comment message called beta
gamma but in real world you will be
providing some comments like fixed
develop bug one two zero or fix this
feature or fixed you know this
functionality so that we will be able to
see from the commit message that what is
the reason behind this commit here so we
don't have to unnecessarily go inside
the commit and find out the details all
the details we should be able to get it
from the commit message so that's the
reason why it's very important that we
provide a valid commit message
right then we have the next operation
over here is the pull now pull is
something which is used to fetch the
latest updates from the remote
repository and then merge those changes
back to your local repository so just
kind of operation in which we are taking
up the update from the remote repository
the purpose of taking update from the
remote repository is that because
different developers are collaborating
or uploading their source code to this
remote repository
so in that situation if we want to take
some updates from the remote repository
that is the reason why we will be using
the git pull command to get those
changes and merge it into your local
repository
then you can have some example like we
can run the command called get pull
origin master now it will copies all the
files from the remote repository to your
local repository so it will do a sync up
of master branch of remote approachity
into the local repository master branch
you can have the uh it's in combination
of two commands one is a git fetch so
first of all it downloads all the
content and then get merged it combines
all the uh sequence of comments into the
specific branch so it's internally when
you run git pull command it fetches the
uh specific contents now when git fetch
command runs it does not uh really
changes any kind of modifications into
your local repository
ultimately when the git merge happens
that is where the code changes into your
local repository but if you alone run
git fetch command it will not perform
any kind of changes to your local
repository right here you can see that
we are pulling up the details so here we
are pulling up the details of our first
repo and when that is done so we will be
able to see some details out of that
right now then we have git push command
which is used to and push the changes
from your local repository to the remote
repository you will be doing a various
kind of comments into your local
repository so at some moment of time you
need to sync up or move those changes to
a remote repository that is where we
will be running the git push command so
git kubush command is required it needs
a network connectivity and uh before get
push command if you want to do some
changes you can do that and once you
want to share or you want to bring those
changes to the remote repository that is
where you will be able to run the git
push activity as such so this is a kind
of a mechanism using which you will be
able to push some changes from the local
repository to the remote repository so
here you can see that we are pushing the
changes from the master branch of our
local repository to a remote repository
and in this case as you can see that it
here says here as a new branch because
the remote repository was empty and
there is no master branch present over
there so that is the reason why it says
new branch over here
so these were some of the git operations
which uh talk about that how we can do
some basic information and basic stuff
over there but now next thing which we
have over here is the advanced git
operations now in this one some couple
of operations involved
as in git branch
then we have the uh get merge and then
we have the get free base here now the
first one is the branch now a branch is
in kind of a way of doing a parallel and
independent development over here now at
some moment of time you feel that the
developers needs to work on the source
code or the changes independent of each
other so in this situation you will be
giving either a feature branch or a
development branch to different
different developers they will be doing
their respective changes to these
branches and then further on you can
do the sync up and you can merge the
changes to a single branch according to
the requirement
so the commits are done isolated from
each other so if you're doing some
comments in developer branch it will not
put any kind of impact on the master
branch so git branch command is used to
see to create a branch to list a branch
to delete a branch or to particular you
know rename a specific branch also
then we have merch when we are working
talking about branching then merging is
also an important task so the merge
command is used to move the changes on
one or multiple changes from one branch
to another so it is a mechanism to
perform a sync up of the commits from
one branch to another
so git merge command is used to combine
two branches and uh it's in kind of a
mechanism in which we find out a single
base a common base and then on top of
that we move the changes or we combine
the two branches here now git previous
is also performed for the same approach
but the process of rebasing refers to
moving or combining a sequence of a
comment into a new base comment so git
rebase is something which is doing a
little bit restructuring of the commits
and normally get merge command is
involved in which it can you know
preserve the specific base comet and on
top of that it can add up your comets
and it can do the modifications but when
we talk about rebase rebase is something
which is combining the comets but it
also preserves or it may end up in
having a new base commit as such over
here so get reverse is somehow doing
some modifications and uh restructuring
the overall
baseline of the comments
right so git rebase command is used to
integrate the changes from one branch to
another here
now these were some of the advanced
features which is there which is
primarily used by the development team
to do the modifications in different
branches
then use the merge or rebase command to
move those changes across different
different branches here now let's talk
about github now what exactly is a
github there now there are some common
uh scenarios where we think that okay
git is different and github is different
uh no it's not like that ultimately
github is nothing but an organization
which internally uses the get repository
only so they are using the git solution
only but it's kind of a web based
graphical interface which is given to
you just to you know have a better
interaction with the git repositories so
it's kind of a get repository hosting
service which is available there so for
example you have the various hosting
machines like godaddy is there different
other vendors are there but ultimately
they provide the same virtual machines
like linux windows and all that
similarly here also they are all using
the git only but they are providing it
in as in kind of a good interface
they're providing you certain features
and these features are somewhere you can
have the security you can have the user
ways you can have the permissions so all
those features you get with the help of
the github here so it's a kind of a web
interface which is given to you just to
interact with the git repository to
create them to manage them to delete
them all those activities
so it helps every team member to uh
integrate with each other and at any
moment of time now this is uh something
which you can access anywhere if you are
using the public version of github you
can use the repository anywhere with any
network but if you are using a private
network or a private repository in that
situation definitely in your office or
into your network you will be able to
access but it primarily depends on the
way that how you are doing the
modification and how exactly you have
done the changes so far and so over here
right so it's one of the good
collaboration tool which is present
which primary you know talks about that
how we can do the modifications and how
we can move the changes from you know we
can have the collaboration between
different developers and they can really
do the changes and those
modifications right now one of the
different features which we have of
github so let's talk about that now some
of the features are present over here in
this way that uh represents it what are
the mechanism and understanding about
the
specific github here so let's talk about
these features
now the very first feature of this one
is the easy project management now uh
it's a very good platform where you can
you know have different kind of access
levels project managers and you know
developers can coordinate they can track
and they can update their work
you can manage the repositories you can
manage the access you can perform the
changes you can perform the rollback a
lot of things can really happen there
and everything is recorded nothing so
even the account activity is also
recorded so if someone is creating the
repository is deleting the repository
all that information is there so it's
kind of a easy project management where
at a single location all the
repositories are there so it's quite
easy for you to manage and to work on
these repositories and to talk about
them
next we have effective team management
now it helps all the team members to
stay on the same page and stay organized
so it's in kind of a modernized tool
which is available there to so that
different people can you know work on
the same platform uh they don't have to
learn different different platforms here
as such on the same platform they will
be able to collaborate and they will be
able to uh you know work with each other
then improved code writing so there are
some features like you know pull request
which gives you
functionality before even doing the
merge activity
you will be able to do some review so it
definitely helps a kind of a check which
is there that before even doing some
kind of uh merging you should be able to
review it you should be able to see that
what exactly you are trying to do what
kind of comments you are performing and
that can really helps to you know do
some
improvements to your source go to your
overall source code so that's an
additional check which is provided by
the pull request feature of github it's
not a typical merge only it's something
someone will review someone approve it
then only the merge activity will happen
now github uses different uh tools uh to
identify and analyze the issues there so
there are some tools or features which
is available there in github where you
can also further on increase or you know
analyze the source code and analyze the
issues with your source code there so
development teams can work together to
you know to secure the software uh
supply chain uh these uh particular uh
say repositories are quite secured and
that is the reason why not everyone have
the access or default access to the
source code so this is quite extended
and due to this feature it's easy to
maintain the high quality of your source
code
right and then we have the easy code
hosting here so all the codes and
documentations are present in one
location there are millions of
repositories which is available there on
github and each repository is comprises
of its own source code and its own
different different people having the
access
right and then it increased safety with
packages those packages can be published
privately you can have both public and
private access the packages can be used
or reused by downloading it from github
and other variety of applications is
there so if you are working on open
source in that situation it will be
publicly available if you're working as
in privately foreign secured
organization in that case it will be
available privately there
right so these were some of the various
operations which was there related to
git now let's talk about some demo and
see that how exactly we can go for that
implementation and we can see some real
operations of kit so let's connect to
our get simply learn lab over here a
linux lab where we can perform all these
various operations and we can see that
how exactly it works so let's log into
the lab
okay so we have logged into the simply
done lab over here in the linux now in
this one the various steps we are going
to do is step by step so first of all we
have our particular github account
logged in so that's the account which we
were using okay so we will create a
remote repository here so first of all
we will be preparing a bare empty
repository now after that we will be
adding some files we will be doing some
uh get comment activities and then we
are going to talk about like some
branching concepts and then the emerging
concepts and all that stuff right so now
let's log into the uh particular lab
here so i'm opening the terminal now
here does not requires any kind of root
access or those kind of stuff so i'm
going to create a folder structure with
the name called
repo so repo is the folder which i'm
going to create as such over here so in
this case right now as you can see that
there is no repository or nothing is
present here so i will run the git init
command which will do nothing but it
will initialize a bare repository over
here so as you can see that when you run
the uh get in it command you will be
able to see a dot get directory created
now this dot get directory represents
that you are working with uh empty where
git repository now once you get the
repository now if you have to execute
some git commands like i can run the get
status command which can really let us
know that yes you are working on a git
repository if you don't have the dot
gate directory definitely this kind of
response you will not be able to get
right so so far we have only added up a
particular kind of a git empty
repository over here now i'm going to
create some files okay so uh these files
i'm going to create so as i should be
able to do some modifications and i
should be able to add some files so i'm
going to create a file called
master.txt
in this case when you edit file so i'm
going to add like
my first repository over here so that's
what i need to do
so this is my master.txt file here so
once they master.txt file is created now
if i run the git status command what
will be the response the response will
show me that you are basically trying to
add a new file so there is an untrad
file new file over here in order to
track it and in order to add it to the
staging area we have to further undo the
git add command now get add command
alone will not work you have to further
on after that run the git commit command
also to preserve it or to showcase it as
an kind of a git commit here so first of
all i will add the master.txt file so
what will happen to the status so you
can see that the color of the file is
being uh you know changed from red to
green here green represents that this is
a new file and the master.txt file is
being printed over there so so far we
have added this master.txt file into the
staging area staging area is in kind of
an area in which we will be adding up
some couple of files and the whole
purpose of adding those files is that we
should be able to proceed to the next
level which is nothing but the git
commit activity so we are going to run
the git commit activity over here now in
this one i can say like
first commit according to my comfort i
can give whatever the message i want to
provide
i can provide that information
right now in this case as you can see
that it picked up my default author over
here right so if i want to do that
modification if i want to you know
perform that activity and i want to
change my author details i can run the
get config command over here now get
config command i can go for global i can
say like user dot name i can have like
my name
some dummy ip i can provide here so what
will happen that all the further
comments which i will be doing that i
will be able to
do and i will be able to set up there
right now my author details is you know
configured so i will reset my author
using this command here so this isn't
kind of a mechanism that once your
details is being changed your username
and email ids details is changed you
should be able to reset your author
details right so it will open the commit
message again you just have to save it
and after that the comment should be
performed here so earlier the commit was
uh being done with the details called
ubuntu which is the user right now and
uh some dummy ip address but
at any moment of time you want to have
your own username password so you can
say like git config iphone iphone global
user dot name you have added a username
here then you are going for get config
high fifth and global user email id over
here and after that what you have to do
you just have to reset the author
details so that whatever the comments
you have done so far that also should be
updated so instead of having a ubuntu
user under some random email id now
you're giving a specific author in this
case it's me a specific author details
as such into the history so once the git
committee command is executed so what
will happen that entry will be made up
into the history now there is only one
commit which means that the last commit
which you have performed that have
eventually added up the git commit
activity so this is the overall
mechanism that how exactly you can
create a rear repository then you have
added up some couple of files then you
added or executed git add command and
further on you did the git commit
command during the git commit command we
faced the difficulty the author details
was not proper then we added the author
details and then we reset our author
details so that we should be able to
perform a basic operation and uh this
mechanism should let us know that how
the execution and the performance is
happening here
so the overall mechanism you can perform
as such over here is that how exactly
this particular mechanism or this
activity is really performing right so
this is the way that how exactly the
overall operation is really happening
and you are able to get a kind of a log
kind of a history in the repository that
what is the change which is being done
who is the person who have performed the
changes now if you want to get the
changes that what was changed over here
so for that you can run the command
called get show
and the
specific commit id
once that is done so what will happen
you will also be able to say that yes
you have added the content called my
first repo that is what you have added
so far in this commit here so these are
some of the basic operations which time
to time we perform so that
we can do some changes really to our
particular repository
right so this was some of the steps
there now further on what we will be
doing we will be basically performing a
branching mechanism so let's talk about
branching so right now
the branch which we have connected so
far is the master branch
you can see a static symbol in front of
which it means that you are pointing
down to this specific branch as such
over here so next what you're going to
do is that you are going to create a new
branch so we will say that i'm going to
create a develop branch here
so when you run the git branch hyphen l
here so it says that the develop branch
is created but it's not pointed out
right now so in order to move to that
branch so you have to run the git
checkout command to move to that branch
now once you move to that branch you
will be able to see the static symbol is
in front of develop branch so this
movement of from one branch to another
is important because ultimately if you
want to do the modification to the
develop branch you have to be there in
that developed branch if you want to go
to the master branch you have to be
there in master branch so this is
something which ultimately you need to
understand so that there should not be
any kind of interface between the
branches as such over here
so this is the overall mechanism so now
whatever the comments we will be doing
that will be checked in into the
specific develop branch and all the
changes being will be performed as such
over there
so now the next activity which we are
going to talk about over here is that
how exactly we can proceed further to
these activities now what mechanism we
are going to follow over next over here
is that right now in this case you can
see that git branch hyphen l is there so
develop is being pointed out if you want
to see the difference so you can say
like get div master so that will show
you the difference right now there is no
difference as such over here which
represents the difference is
not at all present so far in this case
right
so the next activity which we need to do
uh over here in this mechanism is
we will be performing some changes
to this master branch here so i will add
some content here saying
adding
content in develop branch
just to you know have a proper check so
that if somehow you know i will see the
files i should be able to see that okay
this is what i have changed in the
develop branch now this two lines are
there definitely uh when i'm going to
see the difference here again
when i run the diff command so it will
do a branch to branch comparison and it
will say that yes in this branch you
have some additions which is not present
in master branch right so that's the
whole idea the particular master branch
should not be touched upon if i'm doing
some modification to develop branch that
changes should be present in the
particular this branch only
now in this case what happens now we
know that get add command
and uh get
commit command we have to run
so i'm going to say like
develop
branch
right so just an uh kind of a message
you want to provide so
that's done so if i do the git log here
so i should be able to see a new commit
instead of one commit two comments are
there
in master branch only one commit is
there that you can eventually check also
i can go
to the master branch and i can check
that also
so in master branch right now you can
see the last output is showing one
commit
this one is showing one commit because
it's present in the master branch this
one is showing two commits because it's
present in the developed branch so both
the branches
are having two different set of commits
now definitely if you want to move the
changes from the develop branch to the
master branch all you have to do is that
you have to sync up and how this sync up
is done it's done using the help of
merge activity so we will double check
that on which branch we are right now so
we have check that we are on to the
master branch
we have to merge the specific develop
branch into the master branch so for
that what we will be doing we will be
running the command called get merge
develop so when we do that what will
happen that it will eventually let me
know or it will eventually move or sync
those changes
from the develop branch to the master
branch so earlier in the previous
situation master branch was showing one
commit but now in this case it's also
showing the specific that commit also
moved on along over here so this is how
the sync up really happens and the
comments really move from one branch to
another now in this case it's not only
the commit which is being reproductive
but even the file is also being updated
over here as such so the master.txt file
is also showing that the second line is
being added as such over here
right so this is the overall mechanism
and the system that how exactly this
whole activity is really working and how
we will be able to get some execution
and we will be able to get some
particular results out of this one so
this is the way that how the branching
and emerging really happens as such over
here
so right now we are working on the
repository and this repository is
nothing but a local repository so so far
now next we will be talking about the
interaction between the github and this
local repository our remote and local
repository so we'll go to the github
remote repository here we'll click on
the particular new repository here
so i'm going to create a particular repo
called git repo here
the name is available but if i give some
different name so if it is not available
so that will not allow me to create a
repository so here the public and
private specifier you have to select
public anyone can see but no one will be
able to do the modification unless we
provide the access
private nobody will be able to see the
content unless and until he is not
having the access so only modification
and view access both is restricted if
they have the access to the repo
uh we don't have to initialize the
repository with the readme i want to
create a bare repository so create
once the repo is created you will see
three sections of the information first
if you want to create a new repository
on the command line and do that so you
can see that some of the activities we
have already done so far so we don't
require this section second section
saying that if you already have a
repository and you want to push it to
the remote repository so you have to run
these commands so these are something
which we need to really do so i am going
to run this command
now this command is something which is
trying to add the remote origin over
here
now why origin is required because every
time i cannot simply
use the lengthy url and i cannot
remember it also so you can see here
that it's kind of a shortcut over here
that origin is being referred as this
url so both for pull and push activity
we will be using this one
so you will be running like get push or
a gen
master
uh it will definitely ask for your
credentials so
you will give the url username
and you will also give the
password now once that is done so you
what you will see over here is that you
will be able to see that a new branch is
created because in github repository you
were not having any kind of code base
available so when you refresh the code
will be available there
but this is just the master branch if
you want to move the
particular develop branch here
is the same details you have to provide
the same username
credentials also are same which you need
to provide and once that is done you
will be able to see that develop branch
is also created as such over here so you
see two branches
two branches are in proper syncope and
you want to create deleter branch you
can do that you want to switch it branch
you can do that also
because of the dummy iep address you
must have seen that uh it's showing a
particular different username here
because i have just provided a different
evil id like abc that abc.com so which
is totally wrong
so idly when you will be providing the
actual information about the username
that will be presented over here and
that should be displayed but right now i
just provided a dummy email id so not
the genuine one
so here if you click on this commit id
so you will see the content this is the
last commit which we were doing uh this
is the first commit which we did on that
part
so this is how you interact with the git
repository
right from the scratch we have prepared
this repository we have executed that
and as you can see that once the
repository is created you were able to
get a particular git repository on the
github there so that's it for this demo
to today's topic on movement tutorial in
this we are going to talk about the
maven here
now we will be talking about that how
exactly we can make use of maven here in
performing various kind of operations
whether it's a build compilation various
kind of stuff there so let's talk about
it why exactly we use maven here now
meven is something which uh is a kind of
a build tool which is there for most of
the job based projects here so this tool
also helps us in building up the source
code by downloading some couple of
dependencies these dependencies are
something which is being configured by
the developers which a developer feels
that the project is dependent on and he
requires those dependencies to be
downloaded so uh this tool is
specifically used to build and manage
any kind of a job-based project whatever
the complexity of the topic or the
project is there so this tool will be
able to handle that particular
requirement or that project so it
simplifies the day-to-day work of a java
developer and helps them in their
projects for performing daily to daily
activities
right now meven also helps us in getting
the specific jar files for each and
every project so if you are going you
can pretty much make a jar file bar file
or er file any kind of a package
mechanism you can follow for your maven
day so to download the dependencies we
don't have to actually go to the
official website of each and every
software you can easily get it uh the
dependencies of each and every
third-party band race on the
mvnrepository.com this is a website
which is present on which if you visit
you will be able to download the
dependencies which is required by your
project or by your
specific
project over here so it totally depends
on how exactly you want to download and
you want to get together a specific
repository over here so
mvnrepository.com is the one if you
visit you will be able to download and
go through all the jar files dependent
jar files as independences which you
require for your current project
right so now what exactly is a maven all
about so let's see on that part
so
maven is a popular open source build
tool which is uh developed by the apache
group and the primary uh ownership of
this tool is to build publish and deploy
several projects at once maven is
written in java and it can be used to
build projects written in c shaft scala
ruby etc so apart from java these are
the different programming languages or
the tools which is supported by the
maven here for performing the build
activity so the tool is uh used for
build and management of any kind of a
job-based project it simplifies the
day-to-day
work of a java developer and helps them
to automate most of the compilation or
build
perspective tasks on the projects
right now maven is a kind of a
bomb-based project so it also known as
an project object model and it focuses
on of simplification and standardization
of the building process
in the process it take cares of all the
followings here bills dependencies
reports
distribution releases mailing list so
all these things are being taken care as
in this particular process here and
ultimately it's an availability inside
the maven that how the overall build
process needs to be automated and
standardized here so all these
particular mechanisms is can be followed
as such over here so that we can have a
good
standards and the simplifications
implemented as such here
now what exactly is in maven repository
all about
so maven repository is uh something
which
is a
kind of a directory or it's kind of a
location where we have all the jar files
packaged all together in a single
location so depending on the software
which you want to download the dependent
java files can be downloaded from there
so the metadata refers to the palm files
relevant to each project here this
metadata is what allows maven to
download the dependencies now there are
three type of repositories from where we
can download the dependencies the first
one is the local repository second one
is the remote repository and the third
one is the central repository so these
are the primary three type of
repositories which is available there
for a specific maven over here
so whatever repository you want to
follow you want to access you can pretty
much access it and you can go with that
right
now the local repository will be primary
present onto your pc that's the way that
how it's present there and the
particular remote repository is
something which you can store on any
remote machine or remote server and the
central repository is something which
you can have it onto the internet so
usually the central repositories is
something in which we can actually host
our different kind of dependencies and
the jar files over there
so local repository on the machine of
the developer where the project material
is saved so all the particular
dependencies jar file will be available
on your local machine remote machine is
the location where you can actually
store all your particular dependencies
from where you can download these
dependencies whenever you require it so
this and repositories work similar to
the central repository whenever anything
is needed from the remote repository
it's first downloaded if into your local
repository and then it will be utilized
so if you feel that the dependency is
something which is not there in the
local it will be first downloaded from
the remote repository and then it will
be utilized or will be referenced onto
the local machine there
and central repository is refers to the
maven community repository there where
you will be able to see each and every
dependency present on that repository so
maven downloads the repositories from
here in the local repository whenever
they're needed or whenever required all
these dependencies are cached locally
from where it will be referenced in the
next or you know whenever we want to
refer that we will be able to do that
particular reference easily on that part
so this is the way that how the three uh
particular repositories or movement
repositories really helps us for
performing various kind of automations
as such here
right now what are the basic concepts of
maven here so some of the couple of
basic concepts which is present in maven
is like for the first time we have the
project object model so project bomb
reference to the xml file which has all
the information regarding the project
how this particular project should be
built up how the different build process
should be automated there it also has a
description of the project details
regarding the versioning version
information is also stored as such in
this xml file in this
particular form reference file as such
over here
the xml file is which is there in the
project home directory so maven is uh
something which search for the form file
in the current directory if it's able to
find that particular pom file so it will
execute or it will proceed with the
build step otherwise they it will halt
there itself so this spawn file is very
important because it will act as a kind
of a built script and primary the
movement tool will be able to process
each and everything which is configured
as such in this
specific xml file there and according to
that only it will function or it will
proceed further
right now second thing is the
dependencies and repositories so
dependencies are usually refers to the
java files so the java libraries which
we need in our into our particular
project so while uh working on the
project we may be having the dependency
on couple of dependencies so these
dependencies we have to actually
download or we have to actually refer
and once these a particular information
or these details are referred so what
will happen that uh we need to download
these specific dependencies from the
particular maven repositories so if the
dependencies are not present in your
local repository then maven will try to
download it from the central repository
and cache it into your local repository
but first of all it will look on into
the local repository and if it is not
present in local then it will go to the
remote or the central repository
then we have build life cycles and phase
and goals there so build life cycles
consists of the sequence of build phases
and each field phase consists of
sequence of goals here now each goal is
responsible for performing a specific
task when a phase is uh running all the
goals related to that phase and its
plugins are also used to following the
compilation preparing the artifacts
downloading the dependencies all
different things being done by the
plugins here
then we have the build profile so build
profiles refers to a set of
configuration values now generally we
have the generic build process for all
the environments all the particular code
base there but sometimes we do have some
kind of a differences there so that is
where we can go for the profiles because
a specific profile can have its own
configuration and whatever it's required
for the build process we can have
different different configurations
stored inside the maven build script
here
then different build profiles are added
to the pom files and which enables the
different uh build as such here so
depending on these profiles we can
actually decide that how we need to
proceed with the build process and how
the different kind of build order
missions needs to be performed here
then a build profile helps in
customizing the build for the different
environments so that also we can perform
as such while workforming or while
working on the different components and
the different management here so a build
profile is something which you can
configure you can utilize and depending
on that build profile we will be
deciding whether to proceed further or
how to decide on that particular factor
so these are something which we need to
take care or we need to work according
to see which we can decide that how the
specific configurations and specific
automation needs to be performed here
now
usually when we go for the uh maven
there so we have to use some couple of
maven plugins now the goal of
using these specific plugins is to
automate some of the basic stuff like
compilation creating the var file
creating the java file so when we are
using the plugins we don't have to
configure the steps or write the steps
that how these uh specific plugins
should be installed or should be
referenced it's ultimately the internal
configurations which we are looking
forward or which we are using while
working on these specific plugins so you
can download some couple of plugins
using which we will be able to decide
that how a specific goals needs to be
achieved here so maven has its own
standard plugins that can be utilized so
if uh you know want to go for a custom
one so you can do that but pretty much
you can go for the default one and uh
you can pretty much have
some specific goals executed with the
help of these build plugins
now next thing is the maven architecture
so uh in maven what happens that uh
let's talk about the basic architecture
of maven here so
the maven executable when it's deployed
so it usually uh reads the palm.xml file
which is the build script here now once
the specific found xml file is being
read out so it will uh process the
components it will uh you know download
or it will process the dependencies
plugins life cycles phases and goals and
even the build profiles and uh if any
kind of interaction is required so it
will try to connect to the central
repository or remote repository and
according to that it will provide the
information and provide the details as
such so minimum repository is something
which is very important because it's
ultimately trying to connect to the
maven repository and try to achieve the
various kind of automation here
so it's very important because
ultimately it's trying to help us to go
for the uh complete end-to-end build
automation when we'll go for a specific
palm-based build automation
so a movement is going to read the
palm.xml file then download the
dependencies defined into the power xml
file and that dependencies are cached
locally from the remote or the central
repository now then uh create and
generate a remote report according to
the requirement and execute the
lifecycles phases goals plugins etcetera
so it will process the pawn rectangle
file then and whatever the plugins and
goals or the life cycles which is
configured there step by step each of
them will be executed into a sequence
here
now let's talk about the overall build
life cycle of the maven here so what
happens that uh the maven build life
cycle is something which is a kind of a
collection of different steps there and
this is something which is followed to
perform a build automation for a
specific project so they are pretty much
three steps which is being done so first
one is the default so it handles the
project deployment there second handles
the project cleaning which is a clean
there and then we have site so it
handles the creation of the project
sites documentation there
so these are the three built-in
particular lifecycles which is available
there at the beaver level which you can
utilize to perform a various kind of
particular steps execution for your
project all right so the build cycle has
uh the different build phases or stages
there because when we are performing a
build a variety of things needs to be
performed over here so the first one is
the compile then test compile is there
so compilation is there for the source
file and test compile is there for the
test cases test will execute the test
cases package will package the bundle
then we have the integration test to run
the integration test cases then we have
the verify then install goal is there
and the last one is the deploy which is
there to deploy the artifacts to the
artifactory so all these things are the
different phases and the stages which is
being followed as per a specific build
here so during these builds these are
the different phases and these stages
which we normally follow for performing
the build automation
now what is the exactly advantage of a
specific maven here so that is something
which we need to talk about that how the
particular automation needs to be done
or how we can actually go for the
configurations where we feel that yes we
want to perform or we want to
take certain benefits out of the
implementation of maven here
so for that what happens that we have to
see that the various kind of uh benefits
the first one is that apache maven helps
manage all the processes there such as
building documentation releasing and
distribution in project management here
so the tool simplifies the process of
project building it increases the
performance of the project and the
building process all together and the
task of downloading jar files and other
dependencies is also done automatically
we don't have to indulge in any kind of
download part as such manually over here
right and even provides easy access to
all the required information so maven
makes it easy for a specific developer
to build a project in the different
environments so we don't have to worry
about the environment we don't have to
worry about the infrastructure nothing
is required everything is available
there inside this package and you know
depending on the particular you can
write the source code on one machine and
you can pretty much do the build on
another machine and this is the reason
how the build automation really happens
on the first place because the developer
is writing the source code in one
location and the same code is deployed
onto the uh particular or built onto
this jenkins or any kind of build tool
there
right in maven you can easily add new
dependencies so you must write the uh
particular dependencies in the form file
so if you feel that you want to download
some particular dependencies so all you
have to do is that you have to put that
dependency into the
specific specific pom.xml file there and
depending on that the execution will be
really performed and executed as a chair
right so let's talk about the demo now
so let's see that how exactly we can go
for this demo and we can perform the
various kind of automations
so this is the virtual machine which we
have here on which the maven is already
installed so we can run like mvn
so maven will be available as in three
point six point three here now i'm going
to run a particular command called uh
mvn archetype generate here
let me create a directory here
our temp directory
and to perform this activity over there
so mvn
archetype
generate now once we run that so what
will happen that it will uh download
some of the binaries there because uh
ultimately what we are trying to do is
that we are trying to generate a new
project like a maven project so a couple
of uh particular plugins will be
downloaded by the maven executable so
that it can achieve that particular
execution so we just have to wait for
downloading all these values now here
it's trying to give us a particular
attributes like it's asking the
different attributes over here so what
exactly we want to configure so if you
want to configure you can provide that
details otherwise you can
perform or whatever the setup you want
to perform now here it's asking for the
version so which kind of version we want
to follow so i'm going to follow like
five here so i'll press five
then a group id which is there so
it's basically a kind of a group
mechanism so i can say like com
dot simply learn so that's the value
which i'm providing here artifate id i
can make it like a
sample project or something like that i
can do
so that will be the artifact uh
id which is there so
version i am keeping the same only so
and uh yeah so package same here
so i just want to create so i'll just
provide the value called yes and enter
so with this what will happen that a
sample project will be created here
right so whatever the artifact id you
provided so according to that the
project is created in this directory so
you have to go into this directory and
see that what exactly the files are
created there so you have the power.xml
file now this palm direction file when i
open so you can see here that there are
some attributes like you can have the
values uh related to what version or
group id you want to follow so this is
the group id this is the artifact id so
this is jar file by default you can
change it according to your requirement
and this is the version and if you feel
that you want to do the changes to the
name that also you can perform here
so by default the junit dependency is
added but if you want to keep on adding
your own custom dependencies you will be
able to do that
now in this case if you run like mvn
clean install so it will be considered
as in particular maven project a
pawn.xml file is already there present
in the local directory so according to
that the execution of the steps will be
performed and according to that you will
be able to get some desired values here
so ultimately in the target directory
you will be able to see that some couple
of jar file or a specific jar file is
generated here so you can see that in
the target directory this jar file or
this artifact is generated here so this
is a way that how we can actually go for
a generic one like a new particular
project and later on you can depending
on your uh understanding you can keep on
adding or you can keep on modifying the
dependencies and that's how you can get
the final result there
so that's it for this demo uh in which
we have find out that how exactly we can
go for a particular project preparation
with the help of mvn executable
so that's it for this demo things
right so that was the demo in which we
uh saw that how exactly we can go for
them even and we can execute some build
a process related to me even there hey
everyone i welcome you all to this junit
full course by simply learn in this
complete course we will learn everything
we need to know about junit and mokito j
unit
we have anuch to guide us through this
journey we shall begin with
understanding the basics of junit and
have a look at different aspects of
junit
in these aspects we shall understand the
relevance and features of junit
moving forth we shall learn the working
of junit with java and eclipse with the
help of a hands-on demo
after we have a complete knowledge about
junit and it's working we shall go on to
explore mojito
in mokito j-unit we shall understand
what mocking is and how we can perform
it
while we are at it we shall know about
the basics of stub and how to create it
to better understand the mokito j unit
we shall see all these processes and the
entire working of mokito with a hands-on
demo
but before we begin make sure you have
subscribed to our youtube channel and
don't forget to click on the bell icon
so you never miss an update from
simplylearn welcome everyone to yet
another topic on junit tutorial now in
this one we are going to talk about what
exactly is in junit uh tool all about
and how we can do various kind of test
implementations with the help of junit
so let's talk about the agenda which we
are going to cover here now in this one
specifically we are going to talk about
like what exactly is j unit uh what is
this particular framework all about then
we are going to talk about j unit
installation how we can do the
installation of junit and what are the
different steps we can get involved on
that and then we are going to talk about
like the features of junit what are the
different typical features of junit are
all about then junit annotations we're
going to talk about and then junit in
java and the actual implementations some
tutorials or some demos on how to
implement junit with eclipse so these
are some of the main topics which we are
going to cover all together over here as
such
now let's talk about what exactly is the
junit tool all about like what are the
different things we can implement with
the help of this tool here so junit is
basically a kind of unit testing
framework which is there for the java so
it's kind of a default offering for the
java programming language that we can
use the chair unit for the unit testing
framework for performing the unit
testing now the main benefit of the
junit is like it's using the same syntax
like a java programming language so it
makes it very easy for a java developer
to write and execute the test cases so
most of the times when the developers
are going to work on the java
programming languages so they prefer
that junit as a default unit testing
framework for them because they get the
language advantage they get the easily
integrations in the eclipse so those
benefits helps the developers to decide
junit specifically for writing the test
cases and running the test cases there
now whenever these test cases are
actually being executed whenever you add
up a new piece of source code so all the
unit test cases will be executed will be
again executed there every time when you
run a new belt so all the unit test
cases gets executed but you also need to
take care that if you are adding up a
new functionalities you also have to add
the corresponding test cases to that so
increasing more and more code will uh
will be done by the developers but at
the same time you have to sync or you
have to keep your test cases up to date
also and as a part of every build each
and every test cases will be re-executed
every time you're doing the build five
times six times a day every time the
all unit test cases will be executed
over there and the response will be
given back
right now let's talk about what exactly
is the unit testing now unit testing
refers to the testing of these small
small modules or the small piece of
chunks or the codes here now it's
basically used to have the early
identification of the defects and the
bugs because you cannot simply rely on
the
qa team to perform the testing and then
provide the feedback whereas on the uh
with the help of this unit testing
framework we can immediately get the
feedback right away once we are running
the test cases we immediately we will be
able to know like these are the
different test cases which we have got
over here now the developers don't even
have to spend more time on fixing the
bugs and issues because
these test cases will help them with the
easy and the fast feedback so according
to that they can fix the bugs and they
can take the decision whether the source
code is working fine as expected or
there is any kind of issues as such
present with this one so unit test
casing is something which is very
important from the developer's
perspective also because it helps the
developers to understand that they
whether they have written a successful
code or if there is any kind of scope of
issues or bugs over here
also it uh the successful unit test
cases uh increases the overall
confidence of the developers because it
uh increases the overall uh performance
and the quality of the product also so
by having the successful executions of
the unit test cases
developers can understand that yes the
source code is working fine as expected
and there is no scope of bugs or any
issues as such with this source code
here so that's the main benefit which we
get with unit testing that with this
fast feedback channel we will be able to
take uh the decisions whether the source
code is ready for the production
environment deployment or not so that's
a main benefit which we get with the
unit testing here now of course this can
be done in two ways manual testing and
automatic testing now in case of manual
testing you have to do this thing
manually within a manual tester or a
manual testing approach and in this one
you will not be depending on any kind of
automated tool which can be scheduled or
which can be executed in non-interactive
manner on the other hand automatic test
case is something which uh is used to be
executed using the
tool and uh it is something which is
being done so that you will be able to
get the complete automation there is no
manual efforts which is required as such
you are going to have like complete uh
deployment and automations being done as
such in this case so automated testing
is something in which you will be giving
more focus on the automated automation
tools you may be having one or a couple
of tools which using which you can write
the automated test cases and you can
perform the complete automation in case
of manual testing it's quite uh you know
less reliable because you are dependent
on the uh a particular
tester which can have perform the
testing uh according to his efforts and
it's quite a time consuming also because
you can only run the test cases for
probably eight to nine hours per a day
whereas on the other hand the automated
test case is something which is quite
reliable because it does not depends on
a human so so requirements so it can be
done like 24 cross 7 so anytime you can
run those
test cases and that's the reason why
these test cases are quite faster as
compared to any other manual testing
approach here
so junit test cases and the automated
test cases really helps the developers
and the qa professionals to test the
source code much faster as compared to
the manual testing now let's talk about
the genuine installation now as part the
of the installation of junit you don't
require to install any exe file or any
kind of program there there are a couple
of jar files which is required which
needs to be there into the
class path so that every time when you
write some junior test cases you should
be able to refer those jar files because
without having those jar files into your
class part of your project you will not
be able to run the change and test cases
so that's the only dependency you
require if you are running a maven build
then these dependencies will be added up
into the powered xml file if you are
referring or doing the build from the
eclipse or doing the development from
the ecrips then you have to put up these
jar files into the
class path of the project so that these
jar files can be loaded up and dj unit
can be referred over here so the
installation is pretty straightforward
but let's see like what are the
different steps we need to follow now as
a pre-request of understanding the demo
about junit the first initial two things
is like you require a jdk to be
installed now you can download the jdk8
over here from this oracle website and
uh this is something which you can
download for the windows or whatever
platform you have you can pretty much
install it for whatever platform is
there so for windows platform you can
download for 32-bit and the 64-bit both
option over here and once it's installed
so you should be able to use the eclipse
latest tool now um all you need to do is
like you need to go to eclipse.org and
there you can download the latest
version of the eclipse now these two
main things which you require because
eclipse will be required for creating
the change unit test cases and of course
how a kind of ide where you can run some
test cases changing test cases and all
and then oracle is something which is
required as a runtime for running the
jdk also and the junit uh test cases
also and eclipse here
so that's a pre-request which we got
over here in this one so i have already
got these two things installed into my
system and i have
eclipse there so let's move on to the
eclipse and see that how it going goes
on there but before that you also
require the junit jar files because in
order to have a particular junit
framework loaded up we require some
particular files jar files over here in
this case so i can just search for junit
4 over here and when you search for j
unit 4 so what happens like this
particular page
will help you or give you all the
details about the junit 4 now you can go
for the
version notes of the different different
versions but uh if you want to download
all you need to do is like you can say
like download and install and the moment
you go there so it will give you the
details now there are two jar files
which is required junit dot jar file is
required over here
j uh ham crest hyphen code jar file
these two jar files are required here if
you want to download it into the test
class path if you feel that you want to
uh use a maven based uh project then in
that case you have to specifically go
for this dependency into palm file and
according to that that particular
version will be downloaded and will be
referred over there so these are the
ways that how you can get the particular
softwares the required things into the
place so i'm going to put up these jar
files into a location so that i should
be able to get the particular details
stored and i can refer to them into my
eclipse so i'm going to download this
one here from the maven central
so i'm going to download this jar file
and then i'm going to go back
and create hyphen code so that also i
want to download
download chart
so these two jar files i have uh
downloaded and i will be referring these
ones into my project because these are
the ones which has been required into my
project as such so let's go back to the
eclipse and uh let's place this jar
files into a location so that into my
class path i can refer the complete
folder with all these two java files
inside that so let's go ahead with that
so let's create a particular new project
over here so we'll go for new
java project
and here i can give it like a simple one
a simple project name i can provide here
and jdk i'm using like 1.8 so that's the
jdk version which i have utilized over
here
and then finish
so this is the project which i have got
like in the source directory now i'm
going to create a simple
file over here a new class file over
here so i'll create it like
j
unit class so i'm going to create a
class over here in this one and of
course i need to have a particular white
main also over here in this
specific class over here because this is
the initial class i'm trying to create
over here in this one i can create a
custom
particular methods also over here but
let's see like if we can execute or we
can run some particular functions as
such over here
now i'm going to declare a function over
here public
void
junit
method
so i'm just going to create a method
over here
i'm just going to run a particular
print
statement over here
executing
j unit
test
cases right
now this is a kind of a method which is
there which of course i can run into my
uh public void main and this function
will be executed uh will be called upon
over here now the thing is that uh right
now uh since it's just a normal function
but the moment i convert it like i
have uh at the rate test mentioned over
here so what will happen like this will
be converted into the form of test cases
now of course like right now there is no
imports which is available there as part
of this one so you can see that the uh
the the time i have added this
annotation at the rate test i will be
able to see like yes add junit 4 library
to the build path is something which is
coming up over here or it's saying like
add junit 5 so whatever the library you
feel that you want to add you can do
that and that particular library will be
added up over here now let's go for the
junit 4 library here the moment i do
that what will happen
you will see some changes first you will
see the changes in the top saying that
import orj dot junit dot test that's a
first import and second import will be
like junit 4 you will see like these two
jar files is automatically being picked
up by the eclipse now even if you don't
download these jar files this is the
main benefit of the eclipse that these
are already a part of the plugins you
can see their paths that these are
already installed in plugins directory
so the moment you use these uh
particular methods that you want to use
the junit these will be automatically
imported over here into your system now
you can just simply call this method
into the main void mean and then the
specific method will be executed as a
form of test cases so this is the
mechanism that how you will be
setting up the project initially you got
the imports you got the uh particular
annotations configured and with that the
uh specific jar files will be
automatically being added up into your
class path whatever the java files we
added up we downloaded previously we can
also have that added up into the custom
class path we can modify this
build path of junit 4 which is coming up
automatically we can just simply say
right click
build path and configure so this jf unit
4 we can actually import we can remove
it from our system and we can add our
external jar files also into the
build path or the class path over here
so that depends upon you that how you
want to perform the customizations
around that part but yes the particular
main benefit of using the
eclipse is that it's already having the
junit plugin installed both four and
five version is installed whatever
version you feel that you want to
include it will be included and the
plugins are already installed so you
don't even have to download the jar
files manually so that's how you will be
able to do a very basic initial setup of
junit and how a basic project can be
created over here in case of chair unit
in the upcoming demos we'll see like how
we can execute these uh particular test
cases and we'll get the response we'll
come to that point so let's go back to
the main content right so that was the
uh junior installation demo which we saw
and we saw like how we can put up or
load the jar files related to changing
it into a class path and we can resolve
the
basic uh you know features about the
chair unit about the test cases now
let's talk about some of the certain
features of the chair unit here now
there are a lot of features which we get
primary with the chair unit let's
discuss about that one by one so the
very first feature about junit is that
it's an open source network now it's
something which is available as an open
source to you uh we have also seen the
installation so you don't have to really
go for any kind of uh
license or something like that so you
can do any number of test cases with
this particular tool and this uh
specific automation tool here you can
automate it into jenkins no way you
require any kind of license around this
so um these can be easily integrated
these are already or part of most of the
latest eclipse installation so you don't
even have to configure these manually
because it's already a part of your
system
right second is that it provides
annotations now main annotation we have
already seen in the previous case that
when we converted a normal function or a
normal method into the test method by
using an annotation called at the right
test so it provides a mechanism to
identify that which particular method is
a test method and which method is a
normal method according to our classes
so these annotations really help us to
identify the methods also and it
provides us the flexibility that these
uh particular methods are not the normal
methods we need to execute you need to
uh run it in the form of test cases so
that identification is something we will
be able to do with the help of these
annotations here uh also it provides the
excitations uh to identify like what
exactly the results are there because uh
definitely when we are running the test
cases in our test cases we need to
assert that what should be the value so
using the
uh you know we can ascertains we can
actually compare that okay this method
is giving this value suppose there is an
addition uh
method which is available there which is
giving like a plus b is equal to c so c
is like 5 plus 15 is 20 so with the help
of asset i'm saying like uh whatever the
response i'm going to get from the
function when i give the values a and b
as 5 and 15 so that should be 20 value
so in the asset i can hard code like
okay this is the value this is the
response which i should be getting and
once the function is executed i should
be able to get this particular output as
in 20 over here so that comparison when
you do you will be able to understand
easily that yes when we are doing the
asset i'm getting the proper response
i'm getting the proper output over here
so assertion is something which is very
important to compare the things to
compare the inputs which we are getting
from the application source code
next it provides the test runner so we
can basically run the test runners over
here to execute the test cases so you
can uh configure this within the
pipelines you can configure it with
eclipse and various automations during
the build automations also you can
configure it so that flexibility you
will be able to get with these test
runners here and it also
allows you provide a better feedback
channel because it acts like a very good
feedback provider because the moment you
are done with the development you will
be able to get an instant feedback so
the overall quality of the code is going
to be increased in this case and that's
definitely helpful for you because with
this uh approach with this junit uh
framework you will be able to get a
quite faster and a perfect uh code
writing tool or a quality tool which is
available there so definitely the
overall quality of the code is going to
improve with the help of this junit
framework
and it provides the automations also
because these unit uh test cases are
having the flexibility that you can
configure it within the pipelines you
can automate it with the help of this
framework that you can completely help
or you can have a complete automated
workflow with the help of this
particular framework and it provides you
an instant feedback the feedback channel
is quite instant in case of this change
unit
now let's talk about the junit
annotations we have already seen like
the main benefit of the annotation is to
define or to provide the metadata about
the methods to the different ones so
annotations also refer to the
synthetical uh method data added to the
java source code so having a particular
better of feasibility and identification
is also quite easy so also the overall
structure of the source code can be done
in a better way and the readability is
also good when we talk about the
annotations here the biggest main
difference between the uh junit and dj
unit 3 was the in the introduction of
the junit annotations so uh earlier
before j2 unit 3 we were not able to
identify like if this is in kind of a
test method or this is a kind of a
source method over here so that
identifications is quite easy after the
involvement or the introduction of the
junit 4 framework over here
also like this is something which is
really helpful to us to see like how
exactly we can overall read the overall
source code because you have so many so
many source code there present to your
project so annotation should be able to
uh you know help you to identify the
that these are the main portions with
these are the components which is part
of the unit test cases not the actual
source code so at the rate test is
something which is uh uh you know going
to tell us that uh the the specific
method with the public void declaration
can be run or can be executed as a test
cases this is not a simple method this
is not an application source code method
this is a test method over here now at
the date before is something which is uh
used to run some statement before each
and every test case is executes maybe
having some
additional or initial connectivity is
something you can do with the help of
add that it before
at the rate after is something which you
can do after the execution of the test
cases like some statements which you
want to execute after the test cases so
that's something you can do or you can
go with the help of at the rate after
and after it ignores is something which
you can configure if you feel like
during the test execution you feel to
ignore some statements so that's the way
you can use the ad that it ignores there
so add that it ignores add the red after
add that it before and at the rate test
these are the four annotations which is
being used most of the time into your
junit test cases
right let's talk about some bit more now
add that it before is something which is
being used to execute the classes uh
some statement before even you know any
kind of test class executes so not only
uh
you know before executing any method
this is something before even loading up
any kind of test classes so before at
the at the rate before class is being
used
similarly at the rate after will be
there to execute it after all the test
classes and uh if we have a timeout
configured so what we'll have that we
will be able to set up a timeout while
executing the test cases so timeout
value can be configured over here
and then uh if you feel like if you want
to handle some exceptions during the
test execution so that's where we can
use this custom annotations over here to
have the exceptions handled or
configured over here in this one so
these are some of the very important
annotations which is available there on
the chair unit perspective now let's
talk about some another demo on chair
unit testing in the java like how we can
pretty much configure the test cases in
junit for a programming language called
java and how we can get along or get
execute those things so now we are going
to see like how exactly we can you know
go for the uh execution of some java
files onto our command line and how we
can uh using the command line run some
execution of the test cases typically we
do it from the eclipse but uh from the
command line also we are going to see
like how
exactly uh you know we are performing
the setup and the executions over here
now what we really need to do is like we
need to see like how we can proceed
further with the execution so i'm going
to open this
particular java file over here so to get
a better understanding here so i'm going
to use the uh orj dot unit junit uh
class over here in this case so we are
having a couple of imports these are the
standard imports so you can do like orj
dot unit junit.star also if you don't
want to go for the specific imports here
now here we are going to create a test
unit as an uh sample class and in this
one we got the
void main over here which is the main
portion of any kind of class here the
only thing which we got over here is
that we have created a test method over
here called test print uh message so we
are assigning a value called message uh
variable over here as and simply learn
now what happens like uh we will be able
to uh like you know do the assert equals
over here that if the value of message
is like simply learn
so it will be able to help us with the
proper output and uh there will be no
errors as such over here so everything
will be smooth and that's what we are
trying to execute over here in this case
and uh we are running into the null void
that these are the test cases we want to
run or we want to execute over here now
all we need to do is we need to compile
this one we really need to compile this
scale test cases over here this file and
then we have to run that one so for that
let me open the command prompt so now in
this case we will be using the java
command prompt here and we will be
copying the junit into the class path so
that we will not be able to get any kind
of class not found issues over here so
test unit junit.java we are going to run
so if there is no exceptions as such we
will be able to get no errors here now
i'm going to run the particular class
file with the help of java command
because java c is to convert the dot
java file to the dot class file the
compile format and then in order to run
the dot class file we have to go for the
java command line here now this means
that there is no issues as such with the
test cases and everything is working
fine as expected over here in this one
so the assert equals is going to help
you to identify that if the
execution is proper and let's say like
if we put up some content like some
different content over here in this
asset equals so i'm going to again
execute this one so that i will be able
to see like if you know what will happen
that if this message value and this
value does not matches like in normal
situations it will say like okay uh the
uh particular uh you know output is
going up and there is no errors as such
right so let's see like what exactly uh
it will happen that if we go for the
executions like if we save this file in
such a way that we are providing some
wrong inputs and what will happen to our
asset equal over here so i'm going to
again compile the file here so again a
new class file will be available and
this time i'm going to execute this
class file again over here in this case
and the moment you did it the asset will
give you the uh comparison over here
saying that there is a failure of the
comparison why there is a failure of the
comparison because according to the code
base it was expecting the value called
simply learn but it simply got the value
called simplylearn12
which means that your test cases over
here got failed on so this is the real
way that how you will be providing the
comparison like what you should be
putting up to the application and what
kind of response you should be getting
in in in return of that so that's where
you will be able to provide a proper and
a complete comparison here which will
help you to understand that what exactly
output you're going to get over here and
that's where the output will be
completely uh available to you and you
will be able to get a proper output
asset here
right so this is the way that how the
comparison will be performed and how you
will be able to see like these two
comparison being done here as such so
this is the way that how you're going to
run the test cases in the form of the
from the command line here so let's go
back to the main document right now the
next one which we got over here is the
junior test cases using the eclipse
because from the command line we saw
like using the command line we can do
but we got like so many test cases which
is available there so it's not easy for
us to run those one by one so we will be
doing it through the eclipse so that we
can see like how the execution can be
really done and we can get a hold of
those particular components so let's go
back to the eclipse and this time we are
going to run the test cases in the
eclipse here now let's create a new
project again here
j
[Music]
unit
project
right and finish so a new j project a
junit project will be created now in
this one you can see like there is no
executables libraries for the junit but
you can include it now also but i'm
going to do it later on so i'll go for
the
j unit
project class right so this is a kind of
a test class here so i'm not going to
put the null the public void mean over
here in this one so finish now in this
case what i'm going to do is like i'm
going to you know replace this content
over here so uh with this particular
ones
and uh going to have some basic code
base added up over here so i'm going to
import some
particular junit uh libraries over here
so over here like oj.j unit i'm going to
import these ones and i got like this
class over here junit uh you know
project so i just have to rename it a
little bit so that it can be the name of
the actual class uh name here so that's
fine so everything is fine but the only
thing is that we are getting some
failures and problems over here because
it's not able to identify these specific
junit related executables like the
functions and the methods for this one
again the previous like previous case
you have to do the uh particular
addition of the
library to the build path so that you
will be able to have like these
automatically resolved over here in this
one right so you can see now that the
unit 4 started reflecting over here in
this case and you did not got any kind
of errors now over here in this one so
you can simply save this and now you can
you are good to go for running the
executions over here so you can simply
say like right click over here run s and
j unit test
and when you do that on the left hand
side you will be able to get a little
bit different viewpoint over here which
says like yes test unless code junit is
something which is executed perfectly
fine
if for any reason let's say like i
change the value of string one here as
in string one just an typo error i'm
trying to do here so that i can show you
that how the test cases really fails so
assert equals is basically helping to
find out that if the comparison between
the two attributes is correct that means
that the you know the inputs which we
are putting up and whatever the output
we are getting it's both the same here
when you do that you will say like there
is a failure over here to the test cases
now i'm seeing the failure trace over
here so i'll just move this one to the
console view so it says like it should
be like string but i got like string one
over here which is causing the problem
here because of the type of error which
i did the whole execution of the test
cases got failed so i'm just going to
revert my changes back here and again
run the test cases
it will all be okay right now again over
here so that's a main reason that how
the execution really happens in the
overall mechanism and the system can be
implemented over here in this case so
that's how we basically go on and we
execute some junit test cases here now
in this one we are going to talk about
like how exactly we can use both
marketer and junit here to go for the
unit testing but before even talking
about these two tools here let's focus
on to understand like what is exactly a
unit testing here now there are various
kind of testing which is actually
available into our particular industry
and into our software testing world
there but yes there is a very important
scope and a position of the unit testing
here so unit testing is something which
uh we also call is an kind of a
component
testing is actually a software testing
technique in which single component of a
software is being tested we are not
talking about like how exactly our
application is going to interact with
other applications and it's going to
interact with uh it's not a complete
full-fledged application testing so
in this case what we are looking forward
is like it this is something in which we
are focusing on how exactly we can only
validate and test out a single component
a single component is what we are
basically talking about over here right
and uh when we say like how exactly uh
we want to perform we want to achieve
the setup here so this is the main uh
mechanism or this is the main kind of
testing which an individual developer
performs at its own end to see like
whatever the piece of source code he's
writing whether it's working fine as
expected or not
so this is where
we are able to see like uh the exactly
what we are trying to achieve here and
how a full-fledged or a basic testing
validation can be done now the main
objective of this unit testing is to
pick a unit a very basic small small
unit of the source code to verify it so
that it will be uh
the moment the developer develops the
code base at that moment of time only
this thing will be validated and will be
fixed on so this is something which we
are looking forward over here to achieve
like how the automation needs to be done
and needs to be achieved over here in
this case
next thing is what exactly is the
marking here now we talked about like j
unit here but next one is like what
exactly we are talking about as in a
particular mocking over here now when we
talk about mocking so we are basically
uh trying to understand like what
exactly uh we are performing for what
purpose we are going for the mocking
process here so mocking refers to the
development of objects which are mock or
clone of real objects they are not the
exact uh objects or we can say like
that's not the exact scenario which we
are going to implement but it's kind of
a duplicate or it's kind of a temporary
marks which we are creating so that we
will be able to get it implemented so
mocking is something which is kind of a
reference or a kind of a clone of an
existing or a real object here
so in this technique what happens that
the mock objects are being used instead
of the actual real object so it's not
like we are directly or we are going to
access the exact real objects over here
so we are talking about like uh using or
going through the
specific mock objects over here in this
one so that's where we are putting up
the main focus right and more objects
actually give a particular output
uh
for each and every input whatever the
inputs your pro you are going to provide
you are going to get any particular
desired output so the mocking is going
to process all these inputs give you the
desired output and to understand like
how the implementations and the setups
can be done right so for these kind of
mocking process mocking a framework is
something which is quite popular so uh
marketer is one of the framework which
is available there which is desired for
this kind of uh work or this kind of
approach only where we are trying to see
like how we are we want to perform a
mocking implementation over here right
so let's talk about the marketer tool
because that's a primary tool which is
there for the mocking activity and we
have already focused on like marketing
is and process in which we are uh trying
to uh process uh the mock objects rather
than the real objects so that's kind of
uh verification here so marketo is a
kind of a job-based framework which is
being used for
doing the unit testing on the job
application so if you have written the
source code in java programming language
then marketer is a kind of a framework
for you so this is something which is
helpful for validating the development
of the um kind of application source
code here so you will be able to
validate it how your application is
going to behave and it's going to work
so when we talk about market market over
here so it basically gives you a variety
of information like what exactly
approach you are looking forward and
what is the end result you are trying to
establish over here so that's the main
focus of the market which we are going
to get and it's for the basic uh
approach over here
so java reflection api is basically used
uh internally to generate the mock
objects that's a core component you can
say like the backbone of this whole uh
mocking approach over here mokito is
used to simplify the test development by
marking the external dependencies and
using them in the source code so it's
kind of a
blending in the whole environment there
so that your application is going to get
the desired
environment and uh
being in that environment it can start
processing the inputs and then give the
desired output accordingly so this is
what we are trying to uh
you know implement as such over here to
see like how exactly this mocking can be
done and mokito can really help us in
this approach here
right now what are the different pre
requests which we require to learn more
so we basically need two important p
request over here first of all we need
the hands-on experience in java
programming language so java programming
language is very important because
mokito is something which we can write
in the java programming language it uses
the java programming language syntax so
that's a very important thing there to
be considered and second one is the
junit framework implementation so these
two things we basically require for
performing a complete full-fledged
marketer approach or mocking testing
over here so these are the two important
uh components or you can say like the
two core prerequisites which we need to
process before going for the mokito
implementation
right so let's go to see understand like
how mokito framework can be configured
in eclipse because eclipse is the prime
tool for creating the uh development
source code for the java programming
language so we need to see like how we
can configure the emojito framework over
there because that's the one that's a
single id which will be utilized by the
developers there so let's go ahead in
that
in this demo we are going to talk about
like how we can create a simple
junit and mokito related uh program over
here so that we can have a basic project
created and we can also have some basic
program created on that part so let me
open the eclipse here now in this one
what i'm going to do is like first of
all i'm going to create a maven project
once my maven project is created then
i'm going to include market to nj unit
related dependencies
and after that i'm going to write a very
small source code
just to see like how exactly our
dependencies are getting dissolved and
my source code which will come up as an
error earlier will come up as unhealthy
over there
so all i have to do is i have to just
right click over here
new and here i need to go for project
like i want to go for a particular maven
project here so i can expand the maven
over here and go for maven project
here it will basically ask me certain
values uh i want to use the default
workspace location so i'll just say next
um then i want to have it uh like i want
to go ahead with this overall process so
these all projects like what exactly uh
you know archetype you architecture type
you want to go so i can just go for the
default whatever is selected i can just
go with that
and here i will be providing like what
is a group id so i can provide a group
id called com.simplylearn or depending
on your organization you can actually
provide it so here i can provide marketo
and the version will be like this and
this is the same way like how the
project will also be created the package
will be created in case of the project
here so then i'll just say finish
and uh on the left hand side i will be
able to see like my
specific
source code which is available there so
this is something which is
uh going to come up over here so it's
actually trying to uh resolve some of
the uh particular options like some of
the uh
you know like uh the components like
test executions those are required over
here so i'll just
uh go for this particular reservation
later on
right so i'll just open this pom.xml
file here
and this is the palm xml file right so
it's basically looking forward for
certain changes like this
jar file so this jar file is not
actually available over here so
once i ran the build and you know those
kind of setup can be done then it will
be able to download those particular
dependencies so if you right click on
this one you will be able to see that
particular maven build option here so i
can just run the maven build or i can
just run the maven clean here
so according to that the maven will be
downloading certain plugins and it's
just trying to do some uh particular
process over here so
on the left hand side the source
main
test the same package which is available
they're the same packages is coming up
there so
app test is available there so here the
test
is being available here i can see like
some couple of junit related test cases
is already being there like i created a
kind of a sample project so in here a
basic java and a basic uh class file or
a test suite is already being available
here
so all i have to do is like i have to
just try to see like if i can go ahead
with this uh executions there now it's
using like junit uh 3.8.1 over here so i
can definitely go for a version which is
uh higher like around junit four or five
there but let me try to do a clean build
over here maven build over here so uh to
see like if it really works on there so
uh what are the goals i need to do i
need to go for the goals called clean
install so that's a goal which we need
to do here so uh mvn will automatically
be resolved there but clean install is
the goal which i want to look forward
over here so let's see like what it
really happens so it's going to download
some couple of plugins whatever the
plugins i'm trying to provide here some
dependent plugins will be downloading so
all that stuff will be downloaded this
is the first time we are running there
so that's why it made download some
little bit more uh jar files than
expected ones not you must have seen
like these are all jar files is not like
something we are using into our project
but these are kind of for jar files
which is being used by the plugins by
the maven itself so for that purpose
it's actually going to that particular
level but once these are cached up there
next time if you do the run if you do
any kind of burst there you are not
going to see all these entries so let me
rerun the wheel here to show you like
how clean the output would be there
so i can just go for clean install again
and say run
and this time the output will be a
little bit less there so in this case as
you can see if i expand the output
so here first of all it ran like it
performed the clean activity
then it compiled my source code here it
also compiled my test cases here in this
one then my test cases got executed over
here so you can see like it's something
which got xx
executable over here so this is the test
which is available i can click on that
and i can see that and after that uh it
went on and prepared the uh final
artifact here which also means like it
performs both the compilation and the
test cases execution and this is what we
are doing in any kind of movement
project and on top of that i'm using a
j-unit related frameworks so this is a
mechanism where we can have some
dependencies like i can go for j-unit
here i can increase the dependencies i
can try out the pair so all that stuff i
can do here
right and one more dependency which i
can include is of the mokito here so i
can uh include the marketo related
dependency also over here so that uh we
can see like how exactly the response is
coming up there so
you can see like it's uh you know
when i go for the
resolution over here like clean build
clean install so i can just go ahead
with this
so this time it's actually going for the
mokito one so you can see like all the
steps has been executed and we have got
the end result so the build is
successful and i have got the test cases
also so this is the test file where i'm
actually loading up some junit related
uh
executables there so i can just go with
that and uh whatever the activity assert
uh we are using over here so uh using
which we can do the comparison so this
is a way like how a basic project can be
created in maven and on top of that how
we can manage the dependencies for
mojito and for change unit here right so
that was a demo in which we talked about
like how exactly we can configure mokito
into our eclipse here now let's see like
when exactly we
require the marketer to be implemented
now in this case
what happens like uh when when exactly
you feel like you need to have a mokito
implementation or how we can go for the
mokito
implementation all together here so for
example when a component is to be tested
or a single unit needs to be tested so
this unit or component actually depends
on some other component which is a kind
of uh in entertainment process or maybe
some other developer owns that component
and you are not exactly validating that
component you are validating your own
component but since it's actually
dependent on other component or some
other
unit of the of the whole application
so
that's the reason why you may not be
going you may not be able to perform the
end-to-end testing but yes with the help
of mokito you will be able to get the
mock objects so that you can perform the
uh testing there you don't have to held
up with that other component dependency
you can resolve all these dependencies
like that and you can just proceed
further with your verification and your
implementation so this is the main
benefit which you get when you talk
about the marketer so that you can get
see that a full-fledged understanding
like how exactly these different
components are going to be processed
here
right and uh when there is any kind of
concern like uh if if uh you know like
if you feel like there are some
infrastructure components which is
making the testing impossible so in that
case also we can use the marketer to
mark some infrastructure components so
that we can proceed further with the
validation and the testing here so all
the hindrances and all the problems
which we normally face when we talk
about the implementation all those
things can be really implemented with
the help of mokito here so that's the
main benefit which you get over here in
this one
now let's talk about the next concept so
the next concept which we have is what
exactly is a stub very important concept
here so stub is a kind of object
which holds up a predefined information
a predefined data we cannot do a kind of
a dynamic verification in case of unit
testing because we have to
uh
limit the scope of testing we are
putting up some inputs over here just to
see like how our application is going to
behave
these predefined data will act like a
inputs and
the test cases are going to process
these inputs and give us the desired
output so these outputs we will be then
analyzing to understand that how our
application is going to behave or in
other terms like how application is
reacting to these inputs so that we can
get an end-to-end desired output as a
chain
also it can be referred to as an object
that looks like
exactly a carbon copy of a real object
of course it's not a real object it's a
kind of
mock object over here in this one but it
will give you the exact different uh
details or you can say like the exact
output as such over here in this one so
that's a main benefit which we get with
the stuff that it helps us to get a
mock object instead of the real object
so that we can get ahead with the
testing and we can get all our
environment for our test uh executions
there
right and stubs actually uh
they can actually return uh the
specific uh output here like whatever
the output you require so that will be
returned over here whatever the inputs
you provide that is going to be
processed by this one and the desired
output will be provided to you over here
in this one now these stubs are used to
reduce the complexities right so that
occur while uh creating the real object
so that's also the complexity which is
going to be reduced when we talked about
the uh these specific stubs as such here
so whenever we talk about these tabs we
talk about the implementation so this is
where the complexities get reduced when
we talk about the uh replication or the
marking of the real objects here
right so let's talk about like how we
can see the stub in real action so that
we can get a better understanding
because from there we will be able to
know like what is the mean uh importance
of stub in the whole mocking approach
here so let's go ahead with that
in this demo we are going to talk about
like how we can create some pre-request
for testing out a stub here so i'm going
to create a required maven project and a
couple of class files over here to make
a kind of environment so that we can
test it out the stub implementation in
mokito so first what i need to do is
like
i need to just go ahead with the maven
project so movement project is what i
need to create a very basic project i
want to create over here
you don't have to do much of the changes
like not
much things you need to talk about over
here
so uh the package
direction i can make it like
uh okay i just want the uh particular
package if uh if you don't want to have
the package and you would want to
directly store the source code in source
meaning java and you want to put the
class directly over there without having
any kind of uh particular comm and all
that stuff so you can do that also over
here in this case so that will be much
faster so then you can just go for the
finish here
and you will be able to see like a
project created like a source main java
then uh this particular package name is
there and source uh test java is also
there so here is the test file here is
the main file
i i can go ahead with this one i can
create a file over here
you can pretty much do that stuff also
so or you can change like this existing
one also so what i'm going to do is like
i'm going to create a new class file
here so i'm going to say like okay
create new class file and in this one
i'm going to put uh the particular class
name and a specific content
so uh let's see like how exactly we can
go so we can go for a particular
class creations as a chair or we want to
create so one class and one interface we
want to create so that we will be
creating over here so i'm going to
create an interface here
right
so
to
to
service so that's the interface name
which i'm trying to provide here
and uh
in this one
i'm just pasting the content
so this is already configured here so
you just have to configure like this
right
so uh
then i'm just going to resolve
this one so the
java.util.list is also resolved so this
is the to do service.java which is
available there now what i have to do is
like i i'm just trying to create it over
here and i'm just trying to create an
another class file over here in this one
so which is like my to do business impl
over here which will be using this
interface
right so i'm going to
create
a particular class file in this one
and uh we are going to create it
okay great so in this one again i'm
going to paste this content so
i have to
just sync
this one so this is what so i have to
just rename it a little bit of this one
so
i have to just
rename as in particular
this as over here
great
so now
i'm pretty much done here so whatever
the inputs are required
i can actually go it just this delta i
want to remove it
and uh here we go so we are creating a
particular to do service uh mechanism
over here in this one so we are also
talking about
the uh list here so these list where i
can
go for the auto resolution here so i'm
just going to save it
and uh then i'm going to see like for to
do here so to do is something which is
coming up as an uh particular uh
service here so a little bit changes in
this uh
interface also so
i can just you just have to sync it on
the names
so uh whatever name you are following
you are using so that you need to
change over here in this case so here
also in dodo service i have got it
renamed so that's where it got
successfully resolved and uh as far as
the error list is confirmed so i can
just import that also so i'm just done
here so if you by chance change this
class name then you change the java file
name also calling there so that you will
be there in in proper sync up over here
so that's uh something uh which is
available there which we can use to see
like how the implementation can be done
and that's a basic output which you're
getting over here now this is where we
have got all the required source code
available there when we will be testing
out the stub so at that time we can
actually use these one interface and one
class over here so this class is
basically going for the interface call
over here in this one and that's how
it's going on the implementation
so we'll come back during the testing
during the verification of this stuff at
that moment of time this will act as a
kind of basis for us here so this is a
kind of basic structure that how you
create a basic
program or a basic source code over here
in this one so what i'm going to do is
like i'm going to just create these
stubs over here in this one to test it
out to validate that things there so
last time we created the java source
codes here now the stubs we will be
creating
over here in this one
then we are just trying to
create first one is for the to do
service so to do
service
stop so that's the name which i'm going
to use
and just finish it off
and uh i'm just going to put the content
over here so i'm just in order to try
out the uh particular matching over here
in this one so uh to do stub is what we
are trying to implement so that's what
we are going to see here so i'm just
going to remove
uh this mechanism so i'm able to see
like all the imports is working fine
in this case we are just trying to put
some a dummy information so you can see
like this is the array this is the error
list content which we are trying to
provide over here in this stuff so we
are basically trying to understand like
how in the mocking activity we are
trying to mark some particular inputs
here so that my stubs will be able to
pick those up and they will be able to
return those there so that's what we are
trying to do here now as far as this uh
stub is configured this is done so we
have to go for an another step here
which will be there for the to do
business impl so we have to create uh
this one for uh that particular
implementation so we have to put the
content over here in this one to do to
put the two uh do business impl stuff
here right so i'm going to paste the
content here just to just to match up
the things so i have to uh just put this
content here so i have to just rename
this one because uh
even if we create some files sometimes
we may have to rename it so that keeping
in mind i can just put this one here and
say okay and uh i'm just going to remove
this component here
and here we go so we have got like uh
these components like this is something
which is available there we have got
the implementations which we are trying
to do we have got to do service and to
do service stuff both here but i can
these are the kind of wrong interfaces
so ideally my interfaces is com dot
simply learn dot stub
so that's where we have got
the
particular to do service over there and
uh similarly here also we have got
the particular ones which is available
so which is also there in the uh
specific
com.simplylearn.stop.to do service stub
here so this is a mechanism where we
will be able to find out even if i don't
give this import that's totally fine
because i'm already there in that
package so i can just refer it from
there
and we also have the junit related ones
which is available there so we are
getting the errors for the junit uh
components over here in this case so
we also have the palm.xml file here in
which my junit is being utilized so uh
you know in this one we are basically
trying to use some references around the
j unit here so you can get it on board
on that case so i can just try to run on
the particular movement build here to
see like if all the dependencies are
getting implemented so that we will be
able to
download some required dependencies so
clean install again i'm going to just
refer it over here
i can just uh run the
specific test also like if i feel but
i'm just trying to download some couple
of components over here in this case
so if there is any kind of issues which
you are getting during the execution so
you will be able to see over here for
instance like oj.junit does not exist
over there right so uh since these
packages are not downloaded or not
installed so that's why you're getting
the issues as such over here in this
case
right so these are the uh references
which is available there i can just go
ahead and
import some of the
junit related ones in this case
if i feel like i want to run it so i can
run this java file also over here this
file also i can run it over here right
so those are different options which is
available which we can utilize in this
case
so i'm just adding the junit 4 library
so that my
all references related to junit should
be resolved here and the moment i picked
up that one you can see like all the
errors related to j-unit is gone now i
can run my build here to see like if
it's getting successful so uh this time
okay so uh it's it's going for that
particular mechanism so i can change
the specific
uh version as in 4.0 let's see like
uh it's getting resolved so it should be
able to download that particular
artifact so i just have to find out that
what is the version what is the latest
version we want to provide and according
to that the artifacts will be there and
it will be executed so uh there are some
cases when we are using
the default mechanism of creating a
junit or um even project in eclipse
sometimes it actually uses an older
version so it was using 3.8.1 version
which is old version so i'm using 4.0 so
this source code is actually prepared
according to 4.0 and the moment i
started using that the moment i tried on
that one there so you can see like here
it got executed like both the test cases
got executed over here i have got the
response over here in this one like
these two test cases is being provided
over here so test run is two there is no
failure all good and then ultimately it
went on to the jaw file preparation here
so this is a way like how the stub is
actually going to uh particular uh you
know it's going to call the particular
specific classes but yes in this case we
are just trying to input some values
some static values which is not the real
objects but it's kind of a mock often a
real object and that's how we are going
to continue with our test cases just to
see like you know some inputs if they
are not there we can still go for the
testing and we can do the verification
here so this is a mechanism like how we
can test out a stub to go to see like to
understand like how the overall mocking
is going to happen here so that was the
main uh implementation on how this a
stub can be implemented in the whole
process to see like how exactly we can
go ahead with them now the next demo
which we are going to talk about is like
how we can full fledge implement the
complete marketer code here so that the
end-to-end implementation of the marking
of real objects is what we can get over
here in this one so this will give us
the complete insight about this whole
process
now first we will be creating a specific
uh we are taking up a stock inventory
kind of example over here so we are
going to create a java file over here
which is named as stock.java so i'm just
going to create a class file here called
stock
and in that case we will be providing
the content here so i'm going to create
a stock class which is having certain
methods certain functions stock is the
main function which is available there
now we have to create a particular uh
interface which is going to uh you which
is going to be used to get this talk
there and uh then ultimately and last we
will be getting a one test file which
will be testing out this thing the
communication and see like if the
marketer is getting passed or the test
case is getting passed or not so this is
the class file which is available there
get stock id set stock id so basic
getter and setters are being used i used
over here in this case
so now i have to create a particular
interface here
with the name called stock service
and in this case
i have to
call
the
get price over there
so git price is basically configured
over here in this one
right so we are going to just call upon
on that to see like how exactly it goes
out there right
so we will be utilizing this one so this
is the interface which is calling up the
class called stock.java
now once the stock main class in stock
service or stock interface has been
created now we have to create a
particular portfolio class here this
portfolio is a kind of interface which
is going to
consume this specific stock here so
portfolio uh class is what we are going
to create here so i'm just going to use
it
and
it's using some list operation so i'm
going to just import the java.util also
so that these can be imported so these
are some couple of
activities like under this one we are
also calling up these uh stock service
interface so that that can be calling up
the stock internally and uh this is kind
of a business logic which is happening
so portfolio.java is kind of a business
logic business layer where i'm just
trying to call them uh the main class
there to fetch the details through an
interface and in this one we are
basically doing the all processing like
whatever the activities i'm trying to do
so here i'm doing the processing about
the data here right so this is what we
have uh from the source core perspective
now we will be moving on to the test
cases perspective where we will be
writing a test file to uh do the mocking
over here and to get the stocks and uh
try to do some verification
so now i'm going to create a particular
portfolio tester here
which
will be testing this specific uh
portfolio here so that's what we are
going to do
right
so it's going to use some of the mokito
related uh jar files here and uh since
we already have those uh dependencies
like the we already got those added up
to our palm.xml file so and these are
also being shown up as an maven
dependency here so both 4.0 and this
market to dependency is there in the
maven dependencies and that's why we are
not getting any errors for these imports
here
and we are getting some list related
errors so let me import those also and
uh we should be fine by now here so as
you can see like here we are when we are
doing the verification right so using
this portfolio tester we are actually
inducing some stacks so here you can see
like we are doing some setup
we are calling that stock service okay
so that we will be able to call upon or
we will be able to get the information
and here we are actually putting up some
content so the whole idea why we are
putting up this content just to uh have
the implementation we are just trying to
replicate uh real objects here uh these
are not the actual real uh
configurations or the real information
which we are getting from the uh end
users but these are the the dummy
informations or the domain data which we
are trying to provide here and depending
on that we will be able to get like how
it's going on there so we are basically
trying to
call a function called tester.setup
there tester.setup is what we are trying
to uh call upon over here which will set
up the initial information and then we
are calling the test market value so my
test market value will basically give me
a a pass or fail kind of uh result set
here so that depending on that i can
decide that whether it's successful or
not and this test market value only here
we are putting up some dummy
informations and against these dummy
informations the test cases will be
executed so let's just run it uh my
build is already successful i don't have
to run it again there so what i need to
do is like i need to go for this
portfolio tester dot java here so that i
will be able to get the results and here
we go we are getting the pass
output over here in this one
right so this is what we are trying to
do just to see like how the
implementation should be done there i
can go for a negative scenario like
where i can just a little bit modify uh
something over here in the output and uh
i'm just trying to change a little bit
of uh specific uh output so that's what
i'm trying to do here so um i can
definitely go and see like if this is
something going to uh process properly
or is there any kind of problem which we
are getting over here
i can also remove this decimal value
just to see like if uh i'm getting
successful over here or not so i'm just
running the test cases again
and here we go we got the response as in
failure because uh the expected thing is
not coming up like whatever we are
returning so that's where the failed uh
it's going down for the failure i'm
going to roll back my things here and
see like if it's again getting success
or not
so
yes here we go we got the pass success
over here the past status over here in
this one so just like that you can
actually mock the objects you can put
some inputs and according to that the
responses will be coming up there and
you can go ahead with that particular
mechanism so this is the way that how
the things really gets moved on when we
talk about the marketo and how we can
mark the real objects and we can uh test
out our application here so that's what
we do with the market okay so that was a
complete uh marketo code or you can see
like a complete demo over here like how
the overall process really gets
implemented over here in this one
right now what are the different
benefits of mokito let's process that
one by one so
the main benefits of marketo is like
first of all we'll get started with the
very first one is like the no
handwriting so that's a very first
benefit which is coming up over here now
second one is the object creation
third one is the safe refactoring
then we have an exception support uh
benefit which we get over here then we
have got like the annotation support
which is available there and then the
order support so these are some couple
of benefits which we got over here to
completely understand like how exactly
the
uh particular mokito can be really
achieved over here in this one right so
this is the real benefits of marketer
here hello and welcome to continuous
integration tutorial using jenkins my
name is chidanand and i am with the
simply learn team today let's get
started with jenkins jenkins in my
opinion is one of the most popular
continuous integration servers of recent
times what began as a hobby project by a
developer working for sun microsystems
way back in early or mid 2000s has
gradually and eventually evolved into a
very very powerful and robust automation
servers it has a wide adoption since it
is released under mit license and is
almost free to use
jenkins has a vast developer community
that supports it by writing all kinds of
plugins plugins is the heart and soul of
jenkins because using plugins one can
connect jenkins to anything and
everything under the sun
with that introduction let's get into
what all will be covered as a part of
this tutorial i will get into some of
the prerequisites required for
installing jenkins post which i will go
ahead and install jenkins on a windows
box there are few first time
configuration that needs to be done and
i will be covering those as well so once
i have jenkins installed and configured
properly i will get into the user
administrative part i create few users
and i will use some plugins for setting
up various kinds of access permissions
for these users i will also put in some
freestyle jobs freestyle job is nothing
but a very very simple job and i will
also show you the powerfulness of
jenkins by scheduling this particular
job to run based upon time schedule i
will also connect jenkins with github
github is our source code where source
code repository where i've got some
repositories put up there so using
jenkins i will connect to github pull up
a repository that is existing on github
onto the jenkins box and run few
commands to build this particular
repository that is pulled from github
sending out emails is a very very
important configurations of jenkins or
any other continuous integration server
for that matter whenever there is any
notifications that has to be sent out as
a part of either a build going bad or
built being good or built being
propagated to some environment and all
these scenarios you would need the
contains integration servers to be
sending out notifications so i will get
into a little bit details of how to
configure jenkins for sending out emails
i will also get into a scenario where i
would have a web application a maven
based java web application which will be
pulled from a github repository and i
will deploy it onto a tomcat server the
tomcat server will be locally running on
my system eventually i will get into one
other very very important topic which is
the master slave configuration it's a
very very important and pretty
interesting topic where distributed
builds is achieved using a master slave
configuration so i will bring up a slave
i will connect the slave with the master
and i will also put in a job and kind of
delegate that particular job to the
slave configuration finally i will let
you know how to use some plugins to
backup your jenkins so jenkins has got a
lot of useful information set up on it
in terms of the build environments in
terms of workspace all this can be very
very easily backed up using a plugin so
this is what i'm going to be covering as
a part of this tutorial jenkins is a web
application that is written in java and
there are various ways in which you can
use and install jenkins i have listed
popular three mechanisms in which
jenkins is usually installed on any
system the topmost one is as a windows
or a linux based services so if at all
you have windows like the way i have and
i'm going to use this mechanism for this
demo so i would download a msi installer
that is specific to jenkins and install
this service so whenever installed as a
service it goes ahead and nicely
installs all that is required for my
jenkins and i have a service that can be
started or stopped based upon my need
any flavor of linux as well one other
way of running jenkins is downloading
this generic warf file and as long as
you have jdk installed you can launch
this war file by the command opening up
a command prompt or shell prompt
differently on linux box specifying java
hyphen jar and the name of this war file
it typically brings up your web
application and you know you can
continue with your installation the only
thing being if at all you want to stop
using jenkins you just go ahead and
close this prompt you either do a
control c and then bring down this
prompt and your jenkins server would be
down other older versions of jenkins
were run popularly using this way in
which you already have a java based web
server running up and running so you
kind of drop in this war file into the
root folder or the httpd root folder of
your web server so jenkins would explode
and kind of bring up your application
all user credentials or user
administration is all taken care of by
the apache or the tomcat server or the
web server on which jenkins is running
this was a very older way of running but
still some people use it because if they
don't want to maintain two servers if
they already have a java web server
which it's being nicely maintained and
backed up jenkins can run attached to it
all right so either ways it doesn't
matter however you're going to bring up
your jenkins instance the way we're
going to operate jenkins is all going to
be very very same or similar one with
the subtle changes in terms of user
administration if at all you're
launching it through any other web
server which will take care of the user
administration otherwise all the
commands or all the configuration or the
way in which i'm going to run this demo
it is going to be same across any of
these installations all right so the
prerequisites for running jenkins as i
mentioned earlier jenkins is nothing but
a simple web application that is written
in java so all that it needs is java
preferably jdk 1.7 or 1.8 2gb ram is the
recommended ram for running jenkins and
also like any other open source tool
sets when you install jdk ensure that
you set in the environment variable java
home to point to the right directory
this is something very specific to jdk
but for any other open source tools that
you've installed there's always a
preferred environment variable that you
got to set in which is specific to that
particular tool that you're going to use
this is a generic thing that is there
for you know for any other open source
projects because the way open source
projects discover themselves is using
this environment variables so as a
general practice or a good practice
always set these environment variables
accordingly so i already have jdk 1.8
installed on my system but in case you
do not what i would recommend is just
navigate on your browser to the oracle
homepage and just type in or search for
install
jdk 1.8
and navigate to the oracle homepage
you'll have to accept the license
agreement and there are a bunch of
installers that is okay that you can
pick up based upon the operating system
on which you're running so
i have this windows 64 installer that is
already installed and running on my
system so i will not get into the
details of downloading this or
installing it let me show you once i
install this what i've done with regard
to my path
so
if you get into this environment
variables
all right so i have just set in a java
home variable
if you see this c colon program files
java jdk 1.8 this is where my my java is
located see program files c program
files java
okay so this is the home directory of my
jdk so that is what i've been
i've set it up here in my environment
variable
so if you see here this is my java home
all right one other thing to do is
ensure that in case you want to run java
or java c from a command prompt ensure
that you also add that path into this
path variable so if you see this
somewhere i will see yes there you go c
colon program files java jdk 1.8 pin so
with these two i'll ensure that my java
installation is nice and you know good
enough so to check that to double check
that or to verify that let me just open
up a simple command prompt
and if i type in java iphone version
all right
and java c
iphone version
so the compiler is on the path java is
on the path and if at all i do this
even the environment variable specific
to my java is
installed correctly so i'm good to go
ahead with my jenkins installation
now that i have my prerequisites
all set for installing jenkins let me
just go ahead and download jenkins
so let me open up a browser and say
download
jenkins
all right lts is nothing but the long
term support these are all stable
versions weeklies i would not recommend
that you try these unless until you have
a real need for that
long term support is good enough and as
i mentioned there are so many flavors of
jenkins that is available for download
all right so what i want is
yes this is the war file with the
generic war file that i was talking to
you earlier and this is the windows msi
installer so go ahead and download this
msi installer i already have that
downloaded so let me just open that up
all right so this is my downloaded
jenkins instance
or other installer this is a pretty
maybe a few months old but this is good
enough for me
before you start jenkins installation
just be aware of one fact that there is
a variable called jenkins home this is
where jenkins would store all this
configuration data jobs project
workspace and all that specific to
jenkins so by default if at all you
don't set this to any particular
directory if at all you install an msi
installer all your installation gets
into c colon program files 86 and
jenkins folder if at all you run a war
file depending upon the user id with
which you're running your war file the
jenkins folder there's a dot jenkins
folder that gets created inside the user
home directory so in case you have any
need wherein you want to backup your
jenkins or you want jenkins
installations to get into some specific
directories go ahead and set this
jenkins home variable accordingly before
you even begin your installation for now
i don't need to do any of these things
so i've already downloaded the installer
let me just go ahead with the default
installation
all right so this is my jenkins msi
installer i would just i don't want to
make any changes into the jenkins
configuration c colon program files is
good for me yeah this is where all my
destination folder and all the
configuration specific to it goes i'm
happy with this i don't want to change
this
i would just say go ahead and click
installation
okay so what typically happens once the
jenkins installation gets through is
it'll start installing itself and there
are some small checks that needs to be
done
so and by default jenkins launches on
the port 8080 so let me just open up
localhost 8080
there's a small checking that will be
done as a part of the installation
process wherein i need to type in the
hash key all right so there's a very
very simple hash key that gets
stored out here so i'll have to just
copy this path
if i told you you're running as a war
file you would see that in your logs
all right so this is a simple hash key
that gets created every time when you do
a jenkins station so as a part of the
installation it just asks you to do this
so if that is not great it will crib
about it but this looks good so it's
going ahead
all right one important part during the
installation
so you would need to install some
recommended plugins
what happens is the plugins are all
related to each other so it's like the
typical rpm kind of a problem where you
try to install some plugin and it's got
a dependency which is not installed and
you get into all those issues in order
to get rid of that what jenkins
recommends there's a bunch of plugins
that is already recommended so just go
ahead and blindly click that
install recommended plugin so if you see
there is
a whole lot of plugins which are bare
essential plugins that is required for
jenkins in order to run properly so
jenkins as a part of the installation
would get all these plugins and then
install it for you
this is a good combination to kind of
begin with and mind you at this moment
jenkins needs uh lots of bandwidth in
terms of network so in case your you
know your network is not so good few of
these plugins would kind of fail
and these plugins are all you know on
available on openly
or mirrored sites and sometimes some of
them may be down so do not worry in case
some of these plugins kind of fail to
install you'll get an option to kind of
retry installing them but just ensure
that you know at least most or 90 95 of
all these plugins are installed without
any problems let me pause the video here
for a minute and then get back once all
these plugins are installed my plugin
installation is all good there was no
failures in any of my plugins so after
that i get to create this first admin
user again this is one important point
that you got to remember
keen given any username and password but
ensure that you kind of remember that
because it's very hard to get back your
username and password in case you forget
it alright so i'm going to create a very
very simple username and password
something that i can remember
i will
that's my name and um an email id is
kind of optional but it doesn't allow me
to go ahead in case i don't so i just
given an admin and i got a password i've
got i remember my password this is my
full name
all right i say save and finish
all right that kind of completed my
jenkins installation
it was not that tough was it
now that i have my jenkins installed
correctly let me quickly walk you
through some bare minimal configurations
that is required these are kind of a
first time configuration that is
required so and also let me warn you the
ui is little hard for many people to
wrap their head around it specifically
the windows guys but if at all you're a
java guy you know how painful it is to
write ui in java you will kind of
appreciate you know all the effort that
has gone into the ui bottom line you are
a little hard to you know wrap your head
around it but once you start using it
possibly you'll start liking it
all right so let me get into something
called as manage and cans
this can be viewed like a
main menu for all jenkins configuration
so i'll get into some of those important
ones
something called as configure system
configure system this is where you kind
of put in the configuration for your
complete jenkins instance few things to
kind of look out for this is a home
directory this is a java home where all
the configurations all the workspace
anything and everything regarding
jenkins is stored out here
system message you want to put in some
message on the system you just type in
whatever you want and is possibly show
up somewhere up here on the menu number
of executors very very important
configuration
this just lets jenkin know at any point
in time how many jobs or how many
threads can be run you can kind of
visualize it like a thread that can be
run on this particular instance as a
thumb rule if at all you're on a single
core system number of executors two
should be good enough
in case at any point in time if there
are multiple jobs that kind of get
triggered the same time in case the
number of executors are less compared to
the number of jobs that have that woken
up no need to panic because they will
all get queued up and eventually jenkins
will get to running those jobs just bear
in mind that whenever a new job kind of
you know gets triggered the cpu usage
and the memory usage in terms of the
disk right is very high on the jenkins
instance
so that's something that you got to kind
of keep in mind all right but number of
executors two for my system is kind of
good label for my jenkins i don't want
any of these things usage how do you
want to use your jenkins this is good
for me because i only have a primary
server that is running so i want to use
this note as much as possible quite
pretty each of these options have got
some pair minimal
help kind of a thing that is that is out
here by clicking on these question marks
you will get to know as to what are
these particular configurations
all right so this all look good what i
want to show you here is there's
something regarding the docker
timestamps git plugin svn
email notifications
i don't want that what i want the yes i
want this smtp server configuration
remember i mentioned earlier that i
would want jenkins to be sending out
some emails and what i've done here is
i've just configured
the smtp details of my personal email id
in case you're in a in organization you
would have some sort of an email id that
is set up for a jenkins server so you
can specify the smtp server details of
your company so that you know you can
authorize jenkins to kind of send out
emails
but in case you want to try it out like
me i have configured my personal email
id which is on my gmail for sending out
notifications so the smtp server would
be smtp.gmail.com
i'm using the smtp authentication i have
provided my email id and my password i'm
using the smtp port which is 465 and i'm
you know reply to address is the same as
mine i can just send out an email
and see if at all this configuration
works again gmail would not allow you to
allow anybody to send out notifications
on your behalf so you'll have to lower
the security level of your gmail id so
that you can allow a programmatically
somebody to send out email notifications
on your behalf so i've done already that
i'm just trying to see if i can send a
test email with the configuration that
i've set in
yes
all right so the email configuration
looks good
so this is how you configure your
you know your gmail account in case you
want to do that if not put in your
organization smtp server details which
are for the valid username and password
and it should all be set
all right so no other configurations
that i'm going to change here all of
these look good
all right so i come back to managing
kins okay one other thing that i want to
kind of go over is the global tool
configuration
imagine this scenario look at it this
way jenkins is a is a continuous
integration server it doesn't know what
kind of a code base it's going to pull
in what kind of a tool set that is
required or what is the code that is
going to pull in and how is it going to
build so you would have to put in all
the tools that is required for building
the appropriate kind of code that you're
going to pull in from you know your
source code repositories so just to give
you an example in case your source code
is a java source code and assuming that
you know because in this demo this is my
laptop and i've put in all the
configurations jdk everything on my
laptop because i'm a developer i'm
working on the laptop but my continuous
integration server would be you know a
separate server without anything being
installed on it so in case i want
jenkins to you know run a java code i
would need to install jdk on it i need
to specify the jdk location of this out
here this way
okay since i already have the jdk
installed and i've already put in the
java home directory or rather the
environment variable correctly i don't
need to do it get if at all i want the
jenkins server to use git git is a you
know command bash or the command prompt
for for running git and connecting to
any other git server so you would need
git to be you know installed on that
particular system and set the path
accordingly
gradle and maven if at all you have some
mavens as well you want to do this any
other tool that you're going to install
on your system
which is your continuous integration
server
you will have to come in here and
configure something
in case you don't configure it when
jenkins runs you'll not be able to
find these tools for building your task
and it'll crib about it
that's good i don't want to save
anything
manage jenkins let me see what else is
required yes configure global security
all right the security is enabled and if
you see by default it's the security
access control is set to jenkins own
user database so what does this mean you
know jenkins by default it uses file
system where it stores all the user
names which hashes up these user names
and kind of stores them
so as of now it jenkins is configured to
use its own database assuming that you
are running in an organization you would
probably want to have a you know some
sort of an ad or an ldap server using
which you would want to control access
to your jenkins repository rather
jenkins tool
so you would specify your ldap server
details the root dn
password or the manager dn and the
manager password and all these details
in case you want to connect your jenkins
instance with your
ldap or ad or any of the authentication
servers that you have in your
organization
but for now since i don't have any of
these things i'm going to use this own
database that's good enough
all right so i will set up some
authorization methods and stuff like
that once i put in few jobs so for now
let me not get into any of these details
of this just be aware that jenkins can
be connected for authorization to an
ldap server or you can have jenkins
managing its own servers which is
happening as of now so i'm going to save
all this stuff
that's good for me so enough of all
these configurations let me put in a
very very simple job
all right so job new item you know a
little difficult to kind of figure out
but then that's the new item so i'll
just say you know first job this is good
for me i just give a name for my job i
would say it's a freestyle project
that's good enough for me i don't want
to choose any of that so unless until
you choose any of this this particular
button would not be up i'll give a
description
this is an optional thing this is my
first
jenkins job
all right i don't want to choose any of
these again there are some helps
available here
i don't want to choose any of this i
don't want to connect it into any source
code for now
i don't want any triggers for now i'll
come back to this in a while build the
environment i don't want any build
environment as a part of this build step
you know i just want to you know run few
things so that i kind of complete this
particular job so since i'm on a windows
box i would say execute windows batch
command
all right so what do you want to do i
would let me just echo something echo
uh hello
this is my first jenkins job
and possibly i would want the date and
the time stamp
pertaining to the job i mean the date
and time in which this job was run all
right very very simple command that says
you know this is my first job it just
puts out something along with the date
and the time
all right i don't want to do anything
else i want to keep this job as simple
as this so let me
save this job
all right so once i save this job you
know the job names comes up here and
then i need to build this job and you
will see some buildings tray out here
nothing is there as of now because i've
just put in a job i've not run it yet
all right so let me try to build it now
you see a build number you will see a
date and a time stamp so if i click on
this you will see a console output if i
go here
okay as simple as that
and where is all the job details that is
getting into if you see this
if i navigate to this particular
directory
all right so this is the directory what
i was mentioning earlier regarding
jenkins home so all the job related
stuff that is specific to this
particular jenkins installation is all
here
all the plugins that is installed the
details of each of those plugins can be
found here
all right so the workspace is where all
the jobs that i've created whichever i'm
running would you know there will be
individual folders specific to the jobs
that has been put up here all right so
one job one quick run
that's what it looks like pretty simple
okay let me do one thing let me put up a
second job
i would say second job
i would say freestyle project
right this is my second job
i just want to demonstrate the
powerfulness of the automation server
and how simple it is to automate a job
that is put up on jenkins
which will be triggered automatically
remember what i said earlier about
jenkins because at the core of jenkins
is a very very powerful automation
server all right so what i'm going to do
i will just keep everything else the
same i'm going to put in a build script
pretty much similar to
second job
that
gets triggered
automatically
every minute all right let me do that
percentage date
and i'll put in the time
all right so i just put in another job
called second job and it pretty much
does the same thing as what i was doing
earlier in terms of printing the date
and the time but this time i'm just
going to demonstrate the powerfulness of
the automation server that is there if
you see here
there's a build trigger
so a build can be triggered using
various triggers that is there so we'll
get into this github
triggering or hook or a web hook kind of
a triggering later on but for now what i
want to do i want to ensure that this
job that i'm going to put in would be
automatically triggered on its own let's
say every minute i want this job to be
run on its own
so build periodically is my setting
if you see here there's a bunch of
help that is available for me so for
those of you who have written cron jobs
on linux boxes you'll find it very very
simple but for others don't panic let me
just put up a very very simple regular
expression for scheduling this job every
minute
all right so that's
one
two
three four
five
all right come up come up come up all
right so five stars is all that i'm
going to put in and jenkins got a little
worried and is asking me do you really
mean every minute oh yeah i want to do
this every minute let me save this and
how do i check whether it gets triggered
every minute or not i just don't do
anything i'll just wait for a minute
and if at all everything goes well
jenkins would automatically trigger my
second job in a minutes time from now
this time around i'm not going to
trigger anything look there you see
it's automatically got trigger
if i go in here
yep second job that gets triggered
automatically you know it was triggered
at 42
1642 which is 442 my time that looks
good
and if everything goes well every one
minute onwards this jog would be
automatically triggered
now that i have
my jenkins up and running a few jobs
that has been put up here on my jenkins
instance i would need a way of
controlling access to my jenkins server
this is wherein i would use a plugin
called role based access plugin and
create few rules the rules are something
like a global rule and a project rule
project specific growth i can have
different roles and i can have users who
have signed up or the users who might
create kind of assigned to these roles
so that each of these users fall into
some category this is my way of kind of
controlling access to my jenkins
instance and
ensuring that people don't do something
unwarranted all right so first things
first let me go ahead and install a
plugin
for doing that so i get into manage
jenkins and manage plug-in
a little bit of a confusing screen in my
opinion there's updates available
installed in advance as of now we don't
have the role-based plugin so let me go
to available it will take some time for
it to get refreshed all right now these
are the available plugins these are the
install plugins
all right so let me come back to
available and i would want to search for
my role based access plugin so i would
just search for role and hit enter
okay role based authorization strategy
enables user authorization using a role
based strategy roles can be defined
globally or for particular jobs or nodes
and stuff like that so exactly this is
the plugin that i want
i would want to install it without a
restart
all right looks good so far
yes
go back to the top of the page yes
remember jenkins is running on a java
using a java instance so typically many
things would work the same way unless
and until you want to restart jenkins
once in a while but as a good practice
whenever you do some sort of a big
installations or big patches on your
jenkins instance just ensure that you
kind of restart it otherwise there would
be a difference in terms of what is
installed on the system and what is
there on the file system you will need
to flush out few of those settings later
on but for now these are all very small
plugins so this would run without any
problems but otherwise if at all there
are some plugins which would need a
restart you know kindly go ahead and
restart your jenkins instance but for
now i don't need that it looks good i've
installed the plugin so where do i see
my plugin i installed the plug-in that
is specific to the
user control or the access control so
let me go into
yes
global security
and
i would see this role-based strategy
showing up now
all right so this comes in because of my
installation of my role-based uh plugin
so this is what i would want to enable
because i already have my own database
set up and for the authorization part in
the sense that who can do what i'm going
to install i mean i have already
installed a role based strategy
plugin and i'm going to enable that
strategy all right i would say save
okay
now i've installed the role based access
plugin i would need to just set it up
and check that you know i would go ahead
and create some roles and ensure that i
assign users as per these roles all
right so let me go to
manage jenkins
configure
all right let me see where is this
configure configure global security is
that where i create my roles
nope not here
yes manage and assign roles
okay again you would see these options
only after you install these plugins so
for now i've just enabled the plugin i
have enabled role based access control
and i would go ahead and create some
rules for this particular jenkins
instance so i would say first
manage rules
so i would need to create some roles
here and the rules are at a very high
level these are global rules and there
are some project rules and there are
some slave rules i'll not get into
details of all of these at a very very
high level which is a global role let me
just create a role a role can be kind of
visualized like a group so i would
create a role called developer typically
the jenkins instance or the ca instance
are kind of owned up or controlled by qa
guys so qa guys would need to provide
some sort of you know limited access to
developers so that's why i'm creating a
role called developer
and i'm adding this role at a global
role level so i would say add this here
and you would see this developer role
that is there and each of these options
if we hover over it you would see some
sort of a help on what what are these uh
you know permissions specific to so what
i want is like you know it sounds a
little
different but i would want to give very
very little permissions for the
developer so from an administration
perspective i would just want him to
have a read
kind of a role credentials again i would
just want to view kind of a rule i don't
want him to create any agents and all
that stuff that looks good for me
for a job i would want him to just
possibly
read i don't want him to build i don't
want him to cancel any jobs i don't want
him to configure any job i don't even
want him to create any job i would just
want him to read through things i would
not give him possibly a role to the
workspace as well i mean i don't want
him to have access to the workspace i
would just want him to
read a job
or check you know have read-only access
to the job run
no i don't want him to give him any any
particular
access which will allow him to run any
jobs view configure
yeah possibly create yeah
delete i don't want to read yes
definitely and this is the specific role
so what i'm doing i'm just creating a
global role called developer and i'm
giving him very very limited roles
in the sense that i don't want this
developer to be able to run any agents
nor create jobs or build jobs or cancel
jobs or configure jobs at the max i just
want him to read a job that is already
put up there
okay
so i would save
now i created a role
i still don't have any users that is
there on the system so let me go ahead
and create some user on the system
that's not here i'll say configure
manage jenkins manage users
okay let me create a new user
i would call this user as yeah developer
one sounds good
some password
some password that i can remember
okay his name is developer1
d at
d.com or something like that
okay so this is the admin with with
which i kind of configured or brought up
the system and developer one is a user
that i have configured so still have not
set any rules for this particular user
yet so i would go to manage and gains
i would say
manage and assign roles i would say
assign rules
okay so if you see what i'm going to do
now is assign a role that is specific to
that particular i will find the
particular user and assign him the
developer role that i have already
configured
the role shows up here i would need to
find my user whoever created and then
assign him to that particular role so if
you remember the user that i created was
developer1 i would add this particular
user and now this particular user what
kind of a role i want him to have
because this is the global rule that it
created so developer i would assign this
developer one to this particular global
rule and i would go ahead and save my
changes
now let me check the permissions of this
particular user by logging out of my
admin account and logging back as
developer one
if you remember this role was created
with very less privileges
so
there you go i have jenkins but i don't
see a new item i can't trigger a new job
i can't do anything i see these jobs
however i don't think so i'll be able to
start this job i don't have the
permission set for that the maximum i
can do is look at the job see what was
there as a part of the console output
and stuff like that so this is a limited
role that was created and i added this
developer to that particular role which
was a developer role
so that the developers don't get to
configure any of the jobs because the
jenkins instance is owned by a qr person
he doesn't want to give developer any
administrative rights so the rights that
he set out by creating a developer role
and anybody who is tagged any user who's
tagged as a part of this developer role
would get the same kind of permissions
and these permissions can be you know
fine grain it can be a project specific
permissions as well but for now i just
demonstrated the high level permission
that i had set in
let me quickly log out of this user and
get back
as the admin user because i need to
continue with my demo with the developer
role that was created i have very very
less privileges one of the reasons for
jenkins being so popular as i mentioned
earlier is the bunch of plugins that is
provided by users or community users who
don't charge any money for these plugins
but it's got plugins for connecting
anything and everything so if you can
navigate to or if you can find jenkins
plugins
you would see index of over so many
plugins that is there all of these are
wonderful plugins whatever connectors
that you would need if you want to
connect jenkins to an aws instance or
you want to connect jenkins to a docker
instance or any of those containers you
would have a plug-in you can go and
search up if i want to connect jenkins
to bitbucket
bitbucket is one of the git servers
there's so many plugins that is
available okay so
bottom line jenkins without plugins is
nothing so plugins is the heart of
jenkins for you to connect or for in
order to connect jenkins with any of the
containers or any of the other tool sets
you would need the plugins if you want
to connect or you want to build a
repository which has got java and maven
you would need to install maven and jdk
on your jenkins instance if at all
you're looking for a net build or a
microsoft build you would need to have
ms build installed on your on your
jenkins instance and the plugins that
will trigger ms build if at all you want
to listen to some server-side web hooks
from github you will need github
specific plugins if you want to connect
jenkins to aws you need those plugins if
you want to connect to a docker instance
that is running anywhere in the world as
long as you have the url which is
publicly reachable you just have a
docker plug-in that is installed on your
jenkins instance sonarcube is one of the
popular static code analyzers so you can
connect a jenkins build you can build a
job on jenkins and push it to sonar cube
and get sonar cube to run analysis on
that and get back the results in jenkins
all of these works very well because of
the plugins now with that let me connect
our jenkins instance to github i already
have very very simple java repository up
on my github instance so let me connect
jenkins to this particular github
instance and pull out a job that is put
up there all right so this is my very
very simple uh you know repository that
is there called hello java and this is
what is there in the repositories hello
hello.java application that is here or a
simple class file that is there it's got
just one line of system dot out so this
is already present on github.com at this
place and this would be the url for this
repository
if i pick up the https url this is my
stps url so what i would do is i would
connect my jenkins instance to go to
github provide my credentials and pull
out this repository which is on the
cloudhosted github.com and get it to my
jenkins instance and then build this
particular java file
i'm keeping the source code very very
simple it's just a java file how do i
build my java file how do i compile my
java file i just say java c and the name
of my
class file which is hello java and how
to run my java file i would say java and
hello
okay so remember i don't need to install
any plugins now because
what it needs is a git plugin so if you
remember when we were doing the
installation there was a bunch of
recommended plugins so git is already
installed on my system so i don't need
to install it again so let me put up a
new job here it says git job it will be
a freestyle project that's good for me i
would say okay
all right so the source code management
remember in the earlier examples we did
not use any source code because we were
just putting up some echo kind of uh
jobs we did not need any integration
with any of the source code systems so
now let me connect this so i'm going to
put up a source code and git would show
up because the plugin is already there
svn perforce any of those additional
source code management tools if at all
you would need just install those
plugins and jenkins connects wonderfully
well to all these particular source
control tools okay so i would copy the
https url from here i would say this is
the url that i'm supposed to
go and grab my source code from but all
right that sounds good but what is the
username and password so i'll have to
specify a username
and password all right so i would say
the username this is my username and
this is my https credential for my job
okay so this is my username and this is
my password i just save this i say add
and then i would say you know use this
credentials to go to github and then on
my behalf
pull out a repository all right if at
all at this stage if there's any error
in terms of not able to jenkins not able
to find gate or the git dot exe or if my
credentials are wrong somewhere down
here you would see a red message saying
that you know something is not right you
can just go ahead and kind of fix that
for now this looks good for me i'm going
to grab this
url what am i going to do
this step would pull the source code
from the github
and then what would be there as a part
of my build step
because this repository just has a java
file correct hello.java so in order to
for me to build this i would just say
execute windows batch command and i
would say java c hello dot
java that is the way i would build my
java code and if i have to run it i
would just say java
hello
pretty simple two steps and this would
run after the repository contents are
fetched from github
so java c java that sounds good i would
say save this
and let me try to run this
okay if you see
there's a lot of you know it executes
git on your behalf it goes out here it
provides my credentials and says you
know it pulls all my repository and by
default it will pull up the master
branch that is there on my repository
and it kind of builds this whole thing
java c hello java and it runs this
project java hello and there you see
this is the output that is there and if
at all you want to look at the contents
of the repository if you can go here
this is my
workspace
of my system hang on this is not right
okay good job if you see here this is my
hello.java this is the same program that
was there on my github repository
okay so this is a program that was there
on the github repository all right so
this was the same program that was here
and jenkins on our behalf went over all
the way to github pulled this repository
from there and then you know it brought
it down to my local system on my jenkins
instance it compiled it and it ran this
particular application
okay now that i have integrated jenkins
successfully with github for a simple
java application let me build a little
bit on top of it what i will do is i
have a maven based web application that
is up there as a repository in my
github so this is the repository that
i'm talking about it's called amv and
web app it's got it's a maven based
repository as you would know maven is a
very very simple java based
build tool that will allow you to run
various targets and it'll compile it
will based upon the goals that you
specify it can compile it can run some
tests and you can you can build a war
file and even deploy it into some other
server for now what we're going to use
maven is just for building and creating
a package out of this particular web
application it contains a bunch of
things and what is important is just the
index.jsp it just contains an html file
that is there as a part of this web
application so from a perspective of
requirements now since i'm going to
connect jenkins with this particular
repository okay we already have that set
we only need two other things one is
maven because jenkins will use maven so
in order to use maven jenkins would have
to have a maven installation that is
there on the jenkins box and in this
case the jenkins box is this laptop
and after i have my maven installed i
also need a tomcat server tomcat is a
very very simple web server that you can
freely download i'll let you know how to
quickly uh download and install the
tomcat all right so download maven first
there are various ways in which you can
kind of download this maven there is zip
files
binary zip files and archive files so
what i've done is i've just already
downloaded maven and if you see i've
unzipped it here so this is the folder
with which i have unzipped my maven
so as you know maven again is is one
open source build tool so you'll have to
set in a few configurations and set up
the path so mvn hyphen iphone version if
i specify this after i set in my path my
one should work and if at all i echo m2
home which is nothing but the variable
environment variable specific to my
onenote it is already set here
so once you unzip mav1 just set this m2
home variable to the directory where you
unzip your i1 also just set the path to
this particular directory slash bin
because that is where your maven
executables are all found
all right so that's with maven and you
know since i've set the path and the
environment variable maven is running
perfectly fine on my system i just
verified it okay next one is a tomcat
server
download apache tomcat
server 8.5 is what i have on my system
so i'm just going to show you where to
download this from
this is where you download tomcat server
and
i already have the server downloaded
again this doesn't need any installation
i just unzip it here and it kind of has
a bin and configuration i have made some
subtle changes in the configuration
first and foremost tomcat server also by
default runs on port 8080. since we
already have our jenkins server running
on port 8080 we cannot let tomcat run on
the same port there will be a port clash
so what i've done i have configured
tomcat to use a different port so if i
go to this configuration file here there
is a server.xml
let me open this up here
all right okay so this is the port by
default it will be 8080 i've just
modified it to 8081. so i've changed the
port on which my tomcat server would run
all right so that's one chain second
change when jenkins kind of tries to get
into my tomcat and deploy something for
someone he would need some
authentications so that he'll be alloyed
deployment by tomcat so for that i need
to create a user on tomcat and provide
this user credentials to my jenkins
instance
so i would go to tomcat users.xml file
here
i've already created
a username called deployer and the
password is deployer and i've added a
role called manager hyphen script
manager hyphen script will allow
programmatic access to the tomcat server
so this is the role that is there so
using this credentials i will enable or
i'll empower jenkins to get into my
tomcat server and deploy my application
all right only these two things that is
required
let me just start my tomcat server first
so i get into my bin folder i open a
command prompt here and there's a
startup.bat
pretty fast it just takes a few seconds
yes there you go tomcat server is up and
running now this is running on port 8081
so let me just check if that looks good
so localhost
8081
okay my tomcat server is up and running
that sounds good the user is already
configured on this that's also fine so
what i'll do as a part of my first job
my one is also installed on my system so
i'm good to use maven as a part of my
jenkins so i will put up a simple job
now
i will say job
mbn
web app i call this
freestyle job that's good
okay so this will be a git repository
what is the url of my git repository is
this guy
https url
okay
that's this url i will use the
credentials the old credentials that i
set up will work well because it's the
same git user that i'm kind of
connecting into
all right so now the change happens here
where after i get this since i said this
is a simple maven repository i will have
some maven targets to run
so the simple target first is
let me run maven package this creates a
war file
okay so mvn package is the target
package is the target so when whenever i
run this package it kind of creates it
it builds it it tests it and then
creates a package so this is all that is
required maybe let me try to save this
and let me first run this and see
if it connects well if there's any
problem with my war file or the war file
gets created properly
okay
wonderful so it built a war file and if
you see it all shows you
what is the location where this war file
was generated
so this will be the workspace if you see
this this war file was successfully
built now i need to grab this particular
war file and then i would need to deploy
it into tomcat server
again i would need a small plugin to do
this because i need to connect tomcat
with my jenkins server
let me go ahead and
install the plugin for the container
deployment so i will go to manage
plugins
available
type in container
container container
deploy to container okay so let's put
this the plugin that i would need i will
install it without a restart
right seems to be very fast
nope sorry it's still installing
okay
it installed the plugin so if at all you
see this
if you go to my workspace
okay in the target folder
i would see this web application war
file that is already built
so i would need to configure this plugin
to pull up this war file and deploy it
onto the tomcat server for deploying
onto the tomcat server i will use the
credentials of the user that i've
created
okay so let me go to configure this
particular project again
and um
okay all this is good
so the package is good i'm going to just
create a package that's all fine
now
add a post build step
so after the war file is built as a part
of this package directive let me use
this
deployment to container now if this will
show up after you install the plugin so
deploy this one to the container
now what is that you're supposed to
specify you're supposed to specify
what is the location
okay so this is a global uh you know
configuration that is there that will
allow you to
from the root folder it will pick up the
war file that is there so star star
forward slash star dot war that's good
for me
okay what is the context path context
path is nothing but just the name of an
application that you know under which it
will get deployed into the tomcat server
i will just say mvn web app
that's the name of my thing now i need
to specify what kind of a container that
i'm talking about all right so the
deployment would be for
this tomcat 8.5 is what i need
okay because the server that we have is
a tomcat 8.5 server that i have so this
would be the url so the credentials yes
i need to add a credential for this
particular
server so if you remember i had created
a credential
for my web application so let me just
find that
my tomcat server yes configuration of
this
okay so deployer and deployer username
is deployer password is deployer
okay so let me use that credential
i would say i would say add a new
credential jenkins credential the
username is deployer and the password is
nipplier
so i would use this deployer credentials
for that and what is the url of my
tomcat instance so this is the url of my
tomcat instance
so take the war file that is fine found
in this particular
folder
and then you know context path is mn web
use the deployer deployment credentials
and get into this localhost which is
there
8081 this is the tomcat server that is
running on my system and then go ahead
and deploy it
okay so that is all that is required so
i would say just save this
and let me run it now
okay it builds successfully built the
war file it is trying to deploy it and
looks like a deployment went ahead
perfectly well
so
the context path was mvn web app so if i
type in this
all right if at all i go ahead into my
tomcat server there would be a web apps
folder
you would see the
you know the date timestamp so this is
the file that get got recently copied
and this is the explorer version of our
application
so the application was built the source
code of this application was pulled from
the github server it was built locally
on the jenkins instance and then it was
pushed into a tomcat server which is
running on a different port which is
808.1 now for this demo i'm running
everything locally on my system but
assuming that you know this particular
tomcat instance was running on
some other server with some other
different ip address all that you got to
go and change is the url of the server
so this would be the server in case you
you already have that uh you know if you
have a tomcat server which is running on
some other machine that's all fine with
a different ipa that's all good enough
the whole bundle or the war file that
was built as a part of this jenkins job
gets transferred onto the other server
and gets deployed that's the beauty of
jenkins and automatic deployments or
other deployments using jenkins and
maven
distributed build or master slave
configuration in jenkins as you would
have seen you know we just have one
instance of jenkins server up and
running all the time and also i told you
that whenever any job that kind of you
know gets started on the jenkins server
it is little heavy on in terms of disk
space and the cpu utilization so which
kind of you know if at all you're in an
organization wherein you're heavily
reliant on the jenkins server you don't
want your jenkins server to go down so
that's where you kind of start
distributing the load that is there on
the jenkins server so you primarily have
a server which is just a placeholder or
like a master who will take in all the
kind of jobs and what he will do is
based upon trigger that has happened to
the job or whichever job needs to be
built he if at all he can delegate these
jobs onto some other machines or some
other slaves you know that's a wonderful
thing to have okay use case one use case
two assuming that you know if you have a
jenkins server that is running on a
windows box or on a linux one and if at
all you have a need where you need to
build based upon operating systems you
have multiple build configurations to
support maybe you need to build a
windows you know windows based dot net
kind of a projects where you would need
a windows machine to build this
particular project you also have a
requirement where you want to build
linux linux based systems you also have
a mac you you support some sort of apps
or something that is built on mac os you
would need to build you know mac based
system as well so how are you going to
support all these needs so that's where
in a beautiful concept of master slave
or you know primary and delegations or
agent and master comes into play so
typically you would have one jenkins
server who will just you know configure
with all the proper authorizations users
configurations and everything is set up
on this jenkins server his job is just
delegations he will listen to some sort
of triggers or based upon the job that
is coming in he will if there is a way
nice way of delegating these jobs to
somebody else and you know taking back
the results he can control a lot of
other systems and these systems may not
have a complete or there's no need to
put in a complete jenkins installation
all that you got to do is have a very
very simple runner or a slave that's a
simple jar file that is run as a low
priority thread or a process within
these systems so with that you can have
a wonderful distributed build server
that can be set up and in case one of
the servers goes down the master would
know that what went down and kind of
delegate the task to somebody else so
this is the kind of distributed build or
the master slave configuration so what
i'll do in this exercise or in this demo
is i'll set up a simple slave but since
i don't have too many machines to kind
of play around what i'll do is i will
set up a slave in in one other folder
within my hard drive so i've got the c
drive and d drive my jenkins is on my c
drive so what i do is i would just use
my e drive and set up a very very simple
slave out there i'll just show you how
to provision a slave and how to connect
to a slave and how to delegate a job to
that slave let me go back to my jenkins
master and configure him to you know
talk to an agent
so there are various ways in which this
client and server talk to each other
what i'm going to choose is something
called as jnlp java network launch
protocol so using this i would ensure
that you know the client and server talk
to each other so for that i need to
ensure that i kind of enable this jnlp
port so let me try to find out where is
that let me try this
okay yes
agents and by default this jlp agent's
thing would be disabled so if you see
here there's a small help on this
so i'm going to use this jnlp which is
nothing but java network launch protocol
and you know i'll configure the master
and server to talk to each other using
jlp so for that i need to enable this
guide so i enable this guy instead of
making the by default the configuration
was disabled so i make him random i make
him you know enabled and i say save this
configuration
all right so now configured or is made a
setting for the master
so that the jlp
port is kind of opened up so let me go
ahead and you know create an agent
so i'll go to manage nodes so if you see
here there's only one master here so let
me provision a new node here so this is
the way you know in which you bring up a
new node you have to configure it on the
server jenkins would put in some sort of
security around this particular
agent and let you know how to launch
this particular engine so that he can
connect to our jenkins master so i would
say new node i would give a name for my
node i would say windows
note because both of these are windows
only so that's fine i just give an
identifier saying that windows note i
would say this is a permanent agent i'll
say okay
so if you see the name let me just copy
this name here with the description
number of executors since it's a slave
node and both of these are running on my
system i'll keep the number of executors
as one
that's fine remote root directory now
this is where let me just clarify this
since i have both my
my master is running on my c drive c
drive program files 86
or
not 86
c colon program files
it is indeed 86
all right jenkins so this is where my
master is running so i don't want the c
drive what i'll do is i'll use something
called as a drive i have another drive
in my system but please visualize this
like you know you're running this on a
separate system altogether
so i create a folder here called jenkins
node and this is where i'm going to
place my or i'm going to provision my
slave
and i'm going to run him from here so
this is the directory in which i'm going
to provision my slave node so i'm going
to copy this here and that is the remote
root directory of your particular agent
or slave so i just copy it here the
label you know probably this is fine for
me
and usage
how do you want to use this guy
so i would don't want him to run all
kinds of jobs i will only build jobs
with label expressions that match this
particular node and so this is the label
of this node so in order for somebody to
kind of delegate any task to them they
will have to specify this particular
label
so imagine this way if i have a bunch of
windows system i name it as windows star
anything that says from windows i can
give a regular expression and say that
anything that matches windows run this
particular task there if i have some mac
machines i name all these mac agents as
a mac star or something like that and i
can delegate all tasks you know saying
that start with whatever starts with mac
this node run the mac jobs there
so you identify a node using the label
and then delegate the task there
all right so launch method you know we
will use java web start because we're
going to
we we're going to use jnlp protocol okay
that sounds good directory i think
nothing else is required availability
yes we'll keep this agent yep online as
much as possible that sounds good all
right let me save this
right i'm just provisioning this
particular node now
so if i click on this node i get a bunch
of commands
along with an agent.jar
so this is the agent.chart that has to
be taken down to the other machine or
the slave node and from there i need to
run this along with a small security
credential so let me copy this whole
[Music]
text here in my notepad
not bad plus plus is good for me
okay i copy this whole
path there i also want to download this
alien.jar
i would say yes
and this agent.jar is the one that is
configured by our server so all the
details that is required for launching
this agent.jar is found in this uh sorry
for launching this agent is found is
agent.jar so typically i need to
take this jar file onto the other system
and then
kind of run it from there so
i have this alien.jar i copy this or i
cut this i come back to my folder my
jenkins node i paste it here
okay so now with this provisionagen.jar
and i need to use this whole command
ctrl a ctrl c and then launch this
particular agent so let me
bring up a command prompt right here
and then launched it so i'm saying in
the same folder where there is agent.jar
i'm going to launch this a particular
agent java hyphen.jar agent.jar jnlp
this is the url of my server in case the
server and client are on different
locations or different ips you have to
specify the ipad address all this any
way would show up
and then the secret and you know the
root folder of your jenkins or the slave
node okay
so
something ran and then you know it says
it's connected very well it seems to
connected very well so let me come back
to my
jenkins instance
and see you know if you told me you see
earlier this was not connected now let
me refresh this guy
okay now these two guys are connected
provision are jenkins node and then i
copied all the credentials or the
slave.jar along with the launch code and
then took it to the other system and
kind of
ran it from there since i don't have
another system i've just got a separate
directory in another folder another
drive and i'm launching the agent from
here as long as this particular agent is
up and running or this command prompt is
up and running the agent would be
connected so once i close this the
connection goes down
all right so successfully you've
launched this particular agent now this
would be the home directory of this
jenkins node or the gen can slave so any
task that i'm going to delegate to this
particular slave would all be run here
it'll create a workspace right here all
right so good
so let me just come back and let me kind
of put up a new task here i will say
that you know delegate job is good i say
freestyle project i'm going to create a
very very simple job here
i don't want it to connect to gate or
anything like that let me just create a
very very simple
echo
relegated to the
slave negative two i don't like the word
slave delegate it to
agent
put this way
all right so delegated to agent sounds
good now how am i going to ensure that
this particular job
runs on the agent or on the slave that
i've configured
right you see this if at all you
remember how we provisioned our
particular slave we give a label
right so now i'm going to put in a job
that will only match this particular
label
so i'm going to say that whatever
matches this you know windows label run
this job on that particular node so we
have only one node that's matching this
in a windows node so this job will be
delegated out there so i save this
and let me build this
this is again a very very simple job
there's nothing in this i just want to
demonstrate how to kind of delegate it
to an agent so if you see this
it ran successfully
and uh where is the workspace the
workspace is right inside our jenkins
node it created a new workspace
delegated job it put in here so my old
order my primary master
job is in sql
program files under jenkins and this is
the slave job that was successfully run
very very simple but very very powerful
concept of master slave configuration or
distributed build and jenkins
okay approaching the final section where
we've done all this hard work in
bringing up our jenkins server
configuring it putting up some jobs on
it creating users and all this stuff now
we don't want this configuration to kind
of go away we want a very nice way of
ensuring that we backup all this
configuration and in case there is any
failure hardware crash or a machine
crash we would want to kind of restore
from the existing configuration that we
kind of backed up
so one quick way to do that would be or
one dirty way to do that would be just
you know take a complete backup of our
colon program files colon jenkins
directory because that's where our whole
jenkins configuration is present but we
don't want to do that let's use some
plugins for taking up a backup so let me
go to manage jenkins
and click on available
and let me search for some back there
are a bunch of backup plugins so i would
recommend one of these plugins that i
specifically use
so this is the backup plugin so let me
go ahead and install this plugin
all right so we went ahead and installed
this plugin
so let me come back to my
manage plugins
this plugin is there
so
hang on backup manager so you will see
this option once you uninstall this
plugin so first time i can you know do a
setup i would say backup this particular
i'll give a folder uh this folder is
pertaining to the folder where i want
jkins to backup some data
and i would say the format should be zip
format is good enough let me give a name
or a template or a file name for my
you know backup this is good i want it
in verbose mode i don't want to shut on
my jenkins or should i shut it down no
okay one thing that you got to remember
is that whenever a backup happens if
there are too many jobs that is running
on the server
it can kind of slow down your uh jenkins
instance because it's it's in the
process of copying a few of those things
and the files are being changed at that
moment it's little bit problematic for
jenkins so typically you back up your
servers only when there is very less
load or typically try to you know bring
it to a shutdown kind of a state and
then take a backup
all right so i'm going to back up all
these things you know i don't want to
exclude anything else i want the history
i want the maven artifacts
possibly i don't want this guy i would
just say save and then i would say
back him up
so this would run a bunch of you know
steps and all the files that is required
as a part of this is pretty fast but
then if at all you have too many things
up on your server for now we didn't have
too many things up on our server but in
case you had too many things to kind of
backup this may take a while so let me
just pause this
recording and get back to you once the
backup is complete so there you go the
backup was successful
created a backup of all the workspace
the configurations the users and you
know all that so all this is kind of
hidden down in this particular
zip file so at any instance if at all i
kind of crash my system for some
instance or say hard disk failure and i
bring up a new instance of jenkins i can
kind of use the backup plugin for
restoring this particular
configurations
so how do i do that i just come back to
my manager and gains
come back to
backup manager and i will say restore
her that's an or
jenkins configuration
monitoring as the term says you're
monitoring you're watching you're the
logging your production environment so
of course there are a whole bunch of
monitoring tools so they become an
important part of your production
environment and a lot of these uh
monitoring tools are also i've seen them
also being used especially in your uac
environment
and uh you can optionally have them for
some time even in your uh you know
development and by
not not development different
development services are usually not
very
high end configurations but you know
maybe a decent development flash
integration
server especially if you have long
running scripts and if you have uh
programs that use a lot of
servers uh you know maybe cpu or
processing power
so then you can have monitoring tools
when you're writing such scripts and you
know
you're
doing the uh unit testing for those
scripts
so that you know to see uh what kind of
server utilization
happens when you run this script you
know if you'll put this in production
will it actually you know slow down your
production server and what kind of uh
impact that you have on the you know
your rest of your application
or other applications running on that
server
but
this particular chapter is more in
context with production environment
so these uh tools they basically monitor
your server they monitor your switches
of course they monitor your application
then any services that you have deployed
on your servers
and they generate alerts when something
goes wrong that's the whole job of
monitoring it just continuously watching
continuously looking at what is running
what is happening what is going up what
is going down
when is the cpu peaking when is memory
peaking and all that so that you can
you typically send limits for these
all these different parameters
and anytime any of these parameters goes
outside of that limit you know even more
than that or less than that
these monitoring tools usually send out
an alert
and these alerts could again be sms
alert the email alerts and there are
there are usually people monitoring
these monitoring tools uh to look uh
look out for any
issues reported
and they also generate alerts when the
problem has been dissolved so it will
work both ways
so nagios
is an open source monitoring tool
and it can
even monitor your network services
there's a little diagram here which is
a little too small
but here is najib somewhere what i can
read
and
status
these are different devices
[Applause]
i think no no no yeah these are
different devices to which nagios is
sending the status there's a browser
there's an sms there's an email
and then there's a graph also
and these are different objects
that nigeria is basically monitoring
this is an smtp server i can read smtp
i don't know tcpip no i don't know some
database server okay this is a database
server and this is an application server
this is a switch router okay okay i can
read that now so these are the different
kind of objects these are different kind
of servers that nigeria's
monitors
and these are the different kind of
devices or statuses that it can send
so it helps uh monitor your cpu usage
your disk usage and you know even your
system logs
and it uses a plug-in script that can be
written you know in
any scripting language actually you know
exactly
the
remote plugin executors are basically
agents that allow remote scripts
to be executed as well and
these scripts are usually executed to
monitor
again
your cpu you just use a number of users
logged in who is logged in who's logged
in at what time logged out at what time
and all uh
so all these monitoring tools work on
the concept of polling uh so
polling is more like you know they
so the nrp agent is a program that will
continuously keep polling a machine
for certain parameters that are
configured
in nagios to be monitored so this
program continues to keep pinging the
server bringing the program
uh you know to keep checking for what it
has been asked to check so in case of
logged in users you keep checking uh at
a you know like maybe every 30 seconds
or every one minute
you keep uh pinging
uh to see how many users have logged in
onto this server and who are the users
who have logged in what time they're
logged in what time they logged out and
things like that
so now just poll agents on remote
missions this is what basically it means
i just have
agent programs that can you know help
you
hold
or ping even remote machines
the nigeria's remote data processor is
an agent that allows the you know
flexible data transports and you know it
uses http and
xml protocols to do that
and we'll be talking about uh
essentially your databases and
data server usages like you know within
if you have an oracle database how many
database instances are there you know
how
your load balancing is set up on that
how
data is moving
between different
database servers within oracle
and how
data is moving within the load balancers
and
there's always a drp uh there's always a
backup with database so that's why you
see me mention trp as soon as i say the
word database
and uh if there's a
backup plan you know
uh
how how is the data moving how much time
does did the backup take did it take too
much time
and why you know why did it take so it
helps you do all those kind of
monitoring
the ns client is basically mainly used
to monitor windows machines and
typically when we talk about servers
we end up
talking more about you know unix or
linux servers
of course now with a lot of microsoft
technologies being uh robust to them
they were you know
uh like sharepoint or uh
things like that there are windows
servers too but uh
10 years ago if you
would talk about having a windows server
it was actually
kind of frowned upon especially for
production
and again you know this helps you
monitor usual your cpu your this uh
usage and uh it pulls the plugin and
this particular
agent listens to this particular port
always so that's a reserved port
and usually your system administrators
or server admin administrators know all
these things
so a quick overview uh on uh
genios so it's a tpr architecture
basically for monitoring system
so it has an instrumentation layer which
you know has all your software agents
that are called netpro sits on all your
monitoring system nodes
uh monitoring system knows basically you
know what all uh objects you want
to monitor
you know what all different kind of
objects different kind of servers you
want to monitor
then it has an analysis and
consolidation layer you know which
basically
deploys all these networks these agent
programs that you've
set on your nodes
and
they will basically go and
start monitoring what you want them to
monitor by processing the data they're
receiving from servers from applications
from databases from
user activity etc
and of course then it has a
visualization
layer that
basically is a control that lets you
view the status of environment and you
know any current alerts if this these
kind of
monitoring tools usually have a very
good ui i mean they will do a whole
bunch of things in the background but
when you look at the user interfaces
they're pretty crisp you know there's
like a way a place for you to see
uh things that need your immediate
attention they'll use a lot of color
coding you know to indicate something is
amber uh
green red etc etc
so this thing also has a control where
you can see the status of different
environments you know where your
networks are deployed and what's that
status everything is fine everything's
green if there's a spike uh you know
when was this fight what happened did
anything crash uh how did it stabilize
after that
and of course you know any alerts
that are being thrown on any of these
nodes
so this is uh an overview of the
architecture so these are basically your
uh
different controls your uh visualization
layer
you know you can have multiple controls
doing that you can even have the phone
or a tablet to
view that and then this is your analysis
and consolidation layer you know which
has
yours different rules uh what are what
am i uh monitoring
you know
capturing data for monitoring computing
that and also
they have knowledge base based on what
limits your set what you wanted to
monitor with uh
which off limits uh
you wanted to monitor and it you know
does the appropriate database logging
and sends out the appropriate
notifications and then these are your
net probes different nodes where your
networks are running which are basically
doing the monitoring for like one two
three here see here these boxes
represent your servers
see very clean uh
easy to understand hello everyone
welcome to simply learn's youtube
channel in this full session we will
learn about puppet chef and ansible from
scratch
right from their installation to a
full-fledged use case
we will begin the session with the
comparison between chef
puppet ansible and soul stack
followed by that we will learn what is
shift then we will learn the
installation of chef in our local system
once the fundamentals are done then we
will start with a complete tutorial
where you can learn chef with us with
the perfect hands-on experience
next in the same way we will get started
with puppet and lastly we will have
ansible in the stack and finally we will
wind up the session with the most
frequently asked interview questions to
make sure that you're on the safer side
during your interviews so i hope i made
myself clear with the agenda but before
we begin make sure that you have
subscribed to our youtube channel and
don't forget to hit that bell icon to
never miss an update from simply run
so without further ado let's get started
hello this is matthew with simply learn
and today we're going to go through a
real tough battle we're going to decide
which is better for your operations
environment is it chef puppet antipal or
salt stack all four are going to go head
to head so let's go through the scenario
of why you'd want to use these tools so
let's meet tim he's our system
administrator and tim is a happy camper
putting and working on all of the
systems in his network but what happens
if a system fails if there's a fire a
server goes down well tim knows exactly
what to do he can fix that fire really
easily the problems become really
difficult for tim however if multiple
servers start failing particularly when
you have large and expanding networks so
this is why tim really needs to have a
configuration management tool and we
need to now decide what would be the
best tool for him because configuration
management tools can help make tim look
like a superstar
all he has to do is configure the right
codes that allows him to push out the
instructions on how to set up each of
the servers quickly effectively and at
scale all right let's go through the
tools and see which ones we can use the
tools that we're going to go through are
chef puppet and support and salt stacks
and we have videos on most of these
software services that you can go and
view to get an overview or a deep dive
in how those products work so let's go
and get to know our contestants so our
first contestant is chef and chef is a
tool that allows you to configure very
large environments it allows you to
scale very effectively across the entire
ecosystem and infrastructure chef is by
default an open source code and one of
the things that you find is a consistent
metaphor for the tools that we recommend
on simplylearn is to use open source
code the code itself is actually written
in language of ruby and erlang and it's
really designed for heterogeneous
infrastructures that are looking for a
mature solution the way that chef works
is that you write recipes that are
compiled into cookbooks and those
cookbooks are the definition of how you
would set up a node and a node is a
selection of servers that you have
configured in a specific way so for
instance you may have apache linux
servers running or you may have a my sql
server running or you may have a python
server running and chef is able to
communicate back and forth between the
nodes to understand what nodes are being
impacted and need to have instructions
sent out to them to correct that impact
you can also send instructions from the
server to the nodes to make a
significant update or a minor update so
there's great communication going back
and forth if we look at the pros and
cons the pros for chef is that there is
a significant following for chef and
that has resulted in a very large
collection of recipes that allow you to
be able to quickly stand up environments
there's no need for you to have to learn
complex recipes the first thing you
should do is go out and find the recipes
that are available it integrates with
git really well and provides for really
good strong version control some of the
cons though are really around the
learning speed it takes to go from
beginner user with chef to being an
expert there is a considerable amount of
learning that has to take place and it's
compounded by having to learn ruby as
the programming language and the main
server itself doesn't really have a
whole lot of control it's really
dependent on the communication
throughout the whole network all right
let's look at our second contender
puppet and puppet is actually in many
ways very similar to chef there are some
differences but again puppet is designed
to be able to support very large
heterogeneous organization it is also
built with ruby and uses dsl for writing
manifests so there are some strong
similarities here to chef as with a chef
there is a master slave infrastructure
with puppet and you have a master server
that has the manifests that you put
together in a single catalog and those
catalogs are then pushed out to the
clients of an ssl connection some of the
pros with puppet is that as with chef
there is a really strong community
around puppies and there's just a great
amount of information and support that
you can get right out of the gate it is
a very well developed reporting
mechanism that makes it easier for you
as an administrator to be able to
understand your infrastructure one of
the cons is that you have to really be
good at learning ruby again as with
shaft you know the more advanced tasks
really need to have those ruby skills
and as with chef the server also doesn't
have much control so let's look at our
third contender here ansible and so
ansible is slightly different it is the
way the ansible works is that it
actually just pushes out the
instructions to the server environment
there isn't a client server or master
slave environment where ansible would be
communicating backwards and forwards
with its infrastructure it is merely
going to push that instructions out the
good news is that the instructions are
written in yaml and yawl stands for yaml
a markup language yaml is actually
pretty easy to learn if you know xml and
xml is pretty easy if you know xml
you're going to get yamo really well
ansible does work very well on
environments where the focus is getting
servers up and running really fast it's
very very responsive and can allow you
to move quickly to get your
infrastructure up quick very fast and
we're talking seconds and minutes here
really really quick uh so again the way
that ansible works is that you put
together a playbook and an inventory or
you have a playbook so the way the
ansible works is that you have a
playbook in the playbook it then goes
against the inventory of servers and
will push out the instructions for that
playbook to those servers so some of the
pros that we have for ansible we don't
need to have an agent installed on the
remote nodes and servers it makes it
easier for the configuration yaml is
really easy to learn you can get up to
speed and get very proficient with the
ammo quickly the actual performance once
you actually have your infrastructure up
and running is less than other tools
that we have on our list now i do have
to add a proviso this is a relative less
it's still very fast it's going to be a
lot faster than individuals manually
standing up servers but it's just not as
fast as some of the other tools that we
have on this list and yaml itself as a
language while it's easy to learn it's
not as powerful as ruby ruby will allow
you to do things that at an advanced
level that you can't do easily with the
ammo so let's look at our final
contender here salt stack so sort stack
is a cli based tool it means that you
will have to get your command line tools
out or your terminal window out so you
can actually manage the entire
environment via salt sac the
instructions themselves are based on
python but you can actually write them
in yaml or dsl which is really
convenient and as a product it's really
designed for environments that want to
scale quickly and be very resilient now
the way that sort snap works is that you
have a master environment that pushes
out the instructions to what they call
grains which is your network and so
let's step through some of the pros and
cons that we have here with saltstag so
subscribe is very easy to use once it's
up and running it has a really good
reporting mechanism that makes your job
as an operator in your devops
environment much much easier the actual
setup though is a little bit tougher
than some of the other tools and and
it's getting easier with the newer
releases but it's just a little bit
tougher and related to that is that soul
stack is fairly late in the game when it
comes to actually having a graphical
user interface for being able to create
and manage your environment other tools
such as ansible have actually had a ui
environment for quite some time all
right so we've gone through all four
tools let's see how they all stack up
next to each other so let the race begin
let's start with the first stage
architecture so the architecture for
most of our environments is a server
client environment so for chef puppet
and salt snack so very similar
architecture there the one exception is
ansible which is a client only solution
so you're pushing out the instructions
from a server and pushing them out into
your network and there isn't a client
environment that there isn't a two-way
communication back to that main client
for what's actually happening in your
network so let's talk about the next
stage ease of setup so we look at the
four tools there is one tool that really
stands out for ease of setup and that is
ansible it is going to be the easiest
tool for you to set up and if you are
new to having these types of tools in
your environment you may want to start
with ansible just to try out and see how
easy it is to create automated
configuration before looking at other
tools now and so with that said chef
puppet and solstack aren't that hard to
set up either and you'll find there's
actually some great instructions on how
to do that setup in the online community
let's talk about the languages that you
can use in your configuration so we have
two different types of language with
both chef and ansible being procedural
and that they actually specify at how
you actually supposed to do the task in
your instructions with puppet and sort
stack it's decorative where you specify
only what to do in the instructions
let's talk about scalability which tools
scale the most effectively and as you
can imagine all of these tools are
designed for scalability that is the
driver for these kind of tools you want
them to be able to scale to massive
organizations what do the management
tools look like for our four contenders
so again we have a two-way split with
ansible and sort stack the management
tools are really easy to use you're
gonna love using them they're just
fantastic to use with puppet and chef
the management tools are much harder to
learn and they do require that you learn
some either the puppet dsl or the ruby
dsl to be able to be a true master in
that environment but what does
interoperability look like again as
you'd imagine with the similar to
scalability interoperability with these
products is very high in all four cases
now let's talk about cloud availability
this is increasingly becoming more
important for organizations as they move
rapidly onto cloud services well both
ansible and sort stack have a big fail
here neither of them are available in
the most popular cloud environments and
puppet and chef are actually available
in both amazon and azure now we've
actually just haven't had a chance to
update our chef link here but chef is
now available on azure as well as amazon
so what does communication look like
with all of our four tools so the
communication is slightly different with
them chef has its own knife tool and
whereas puppet uses ssl to secure
sockets layout and ansible and saltsec
use secure socket hashing and ssh as
their communication tool bottom line all
four tools are very secure in their
communication so who wins well here's
the reality all four tools are very good
and it's really dependent on your
capabilities and the type of environment
that you're looking to manage that will
determine which of these four tools you
should use the tools themselves are open
source so go out and experiment with
them there's a lot of videos our team
has done a ton of videos on these tools
and so feel free to find out other tools
that we have then covered so you can
learn very quickly how to use them but
consider the requirements that you have
and consider the capabilities of your
team if you have ruby developers or you
have someone on your team that knows
ruby your ability to choose a broader
set of tools becomes much more
interesting if however you're new to
coding then you may want to consider
yaml-based tools again the final answer
is going to be up to you and will be
really interested on what your decision
is please post in the comments below
which tool you have decided to go with
and what are the challenges that you're
i'm coming up with because we'll help
answer those challenges for you today
we're looking at how we can use chef to
improve the way that you administer
hardware within your devops environment
this is going to be six things that
we're going to step through the first is
really looking at what is the world that
many of you already work in today what
how do you administer your networks and
your systems today then we're going to
look at how chef can be the tool that
really helps improve the efficiencies of
creating a consistent operations
environment we're going to look at the
tools and the components and the
architecture that takes to construct
chef and then finally we're going to
take a use case of one of the many
companies that is using chef today to
improve the efficiency of their
operations environment so let's take a
step back at what life was like before
chef this may well be the life that
you're experiencing right now so as a
system administrator typically the way
that you work is that you are
responsible for the uptime of all of the
systems within your network and you may
have many many systems that you are
responsible for now if one system goes
down that's not a problem because as a
system administrator you can get
notifications and you can jump right
onto the problem and solve it when
things start getting really difficult
however is when you have multiple
systems and you are not able as a single
person to get to all those systems and
sold them as quickly as possible the
problem that you start having is that
your environments are not in sync if
only this could all be automated well
this is where chef comes to the rescue
for you so let me take some time and
introduce you to the concepts behind
chef and why it's a tool that you would
probably want to be using in your
environment so what actually is chef so
chef is a way in which you can use code
to fix your physical hardware
environment so what does that look like
well the way that we write out scripts
in chef is that you can actually code
your entire environment so you don't
have to actually be managing your
environment on a hardware by hardware
basis but actually use scripts called
recipes that will actually manage the
environment for you so chef will
actually ensure that every system is
automatically set to the right states
that meet the requirements you have
defined in your code so you don't have
any issues where hardware and starts to
fail because it references the code to
reset the state within that environment
and that makes you a happy system
administrator so let's go through the
mechanics of how this actually works
with chef so chef is ultimately an
automation tool that converts
infrastructure to code and you'll often
hear the term infrastructure as code or
iac and this really starts as a output
of the work that chef has done because
you take the policies that you as an
organization have created and you
convert that into a scripted language
that can then be implemented
automatically this enables chef to be
able to manage multiple systems very
very easily and considering how broad
and deep our systems become it's very
easy to see how this can help you as a
system administrator the code is then
tested continuously and deployed by chef
so that you're able to guarantee that
your standards and appropriate states
for your hardware and operating
environment are always maintained so
let's step through the different
components that are available in chef so
the first one is actually creating the
actual recipes for chef so you actually
work on these on a workstation and
you'll write out your code which is
referred to as a recipe and that recipe
will be written using a language called
ruby good thing for you is that there
are lots of examples of ruby's recipes
that have been created by the open
source community a lot of examples knife
is the command tool that you use that
communicates between the recipes and the
server so your recipe is the instruction
and knife is the tool that makes that
instruction work and sets the
appropriate state on the server
environment when you create more than
one recipe you start creating a
collection those collections are
referred to as cookbooks and you may
take an environment such as a large
network where you have multiple nodes
potentially hundreds of servers that
have to all have a consistent and equal
state environment and you would put that
cookbook and use that cookbook to ensure
with chef that the state of each of
those notes is consistent and then ohi
fetches the current state of your nodes
and then the chef client configures the
nodes as defined within your cookbook so
let's step through the architecture and
working environment of chef so for an
administrator a systems administrator
you only have to now work from your
workstation and from that workstation
you can then configure all the nodes of
your environment you can use
different recipes that you create and
those recipes can be compiled into a
cookbook that can be then applied to a
node the thing that's of value is that
as you change the environment as you
move and mature as an organization and
your nodes need to mature consistently
and quickly with your organization all
you have to do is roll out a different
recipe to your nodes and then the nodes
will use the tools within chef to make
the updates so you can create a second
recipe or even a third recipe to be
deployed out to your server environment
knife is going to be the tool that does
the hard work of doing the updates on
the server with the server you have your
collection of recipes in a single
cookbook however understanding the state
of the individual nodes is important to
ensure that the information is broadcast
from the server with the instructions on
how to set up the network within those
nodes in this instance we use ohi and
ohai will fetch the state of the nodes
and send that back to
the server and get the information from
the cookbook using the chef client
in your chef node network there is the
potential at times that maybe one of
your node fails if there are two failed
nodes then a request is sent back to the
server and information on the latest
node structure that is identified and
defined in the cookbook will be sent to
the failed nodes if that fails to reset
the nodes then the workstation is
notified and you as the administrator
will receive a notification to manually
reset those nodes it should be noted
that this is a very rare occasion within
the chef network setup so let's step
through a use case in this instance
we're going to look at herpolium and how
they used chef so
polom is a bank and it's the largest
bank in israel and they have a mixture
of linux and windows servers that they
have to maintain and as you can imagine
this requires a lot of constant
configuration and work and this has led
to issues in the past so the challenge
that the team polium faced was creating
and hardening software that ran the
major tasks and was repeatable on those
servers that it didn't matter who the
people were performing the jobs that
there was consistency in the work that
was being done and address the problem
that the servers including the hard run
the servers was not consistent
throughout the organization chef
addresses those specific problems and
became the go-to product for her polium
they were able to write the recipes and
the cookbooks that could be deployed out
to the network effectively and it didn't
matter what the system was the recipes
reflected the standards that the system
administration team put together and
they were able to ensure and test each
script and use standard testing tools
for those scripts it didn't matter what
kind of environment that apollo had if
certain ports need to be closed or if a
firewall needs to be installed or modify
or if custom strong passwords had to be
created all of this could be done using
the recipes that chef offers and once
those recipes had been finalized they
could be packaged into a common cookbook
that could then be deployed to the
entire network ensuring a consistency in
results for the company and also it
didn't matter whether the cookbooks were
being deployed to linux or windows
machine because the scripts were being
put together in the recipes and were
written in ruby you could actually go
through and update and modify those
scripts depending on the environment so
if you needed to make a modification for
linux you could make those modifications
so they were consistent across all the
linux servers or all the windows servers
and this really drove in the ability to
harden and secure the environment in the
entire network within a matter of
minutes using chef versus the days and
weeks that it previously took so we take
a before and after scenario using uh
chef before chef tasks were repeated
multiple times and it was just hard to
keep track of all the people doing the
work and the reality is because so many
people were touching all the different
systems specific standards that the
banks had established was simply not
being made after chef all of the tasks
could be scripted using ruby and using
the recipe and cookbook model that chef
has created the chef tool was able to
deploy out to the entire network
specific cookbooks that provided a
consistent experience and consistent
setup and operation environment for all
the hardware the end result is that the
system administration team could
guarantee that the standards of the bank
were being met consistently so just the
takeaways that we have here of chef so
life before chef is complicated if one
server goes down you can probably get it
back up and running but if you are
working in a modern system
administration environment you have many
systems and if multiple systems start
going down or having failure points it
is difficult to identify where those
failure points are and how to solve them
chef resolves this issue and it does so
by turning the environment that you're
managing with hardware and software into
code and once you have it written as
code you're able to then test that code
chef itself is made up of a number of
key components as a system administrator
you work on your desktop at your
workstation and you create recipes those
recipes are then bundled together into a
cookbook and that cookbook communicates
with the server the main chef server and
the node of servers within your
environment and knife is the tool that
does that communication ohi and the chef
client on the various node servers will
communicate back to the chef server what
the standards and the environment are so
that they can provide a two-way
communication to validate that the
system has been set up and is being
maintained to the same standards as
defined by the individual recipes as an
architect and working in this chef
environment it makes it much easier for
you to be able to control the entire
system administration instead of having
many people having to work on all the
servers you can now have one person
controlling hundreds of servers
simultaneously and at poland have been
able to prove conclusively that chef is
the tool that can help improve the
consistent experience of working with
hardware a very warm welcome to all our
viewers this is anjali from simply learn
and today we'll be looking at the
installation for the tool chef as you
probably already know chef is a
configuration management tool so that
basically means that chef is a tool
which can automate the entire process of
configuring multiple systems it also
comes with a variety of other
functionalities which you can check out
in our video on what a chef and the chef
tutorial so before we move on to the
installation process let me just explain
to you in brief the architecture of chef
so chef has three components there's the
workstation which is where the system
admin sits and he or she writes the
configuration files here your second
system is the server the server is where
all these configuration files are stored
and finally you have the client or the
node systems so these are the systems
that require the configuration you can
have any number of clients but for a
demo to keep it simple we'll just have
one client now i'm using my oracle vm
virtualbox manager as you can see here
i'll have two machines the master and
the node both of these are centos 7
machines as of the server we'll be using
this as a service on the cloud so let's
begin let's have a look at our master
system first this is my master system
the terminals open over here and the
terminal color here it's black
background with green text
and this is my note system so the
terminal here has a black background
with white text so you can differentiate
between the both so we start at our
master system the first thing we need to
do is we need to download the chef dk so
you can write w get which is the command
for downloading and then go to your
browser and just type chef dk here
the first link
so here you have different versions of
chef dk depending on the operating
system that you're using you need to
select the appropriate one i'm using the
red hat enterprise version and that's
number seven so i'm using centos 7 so
this is my link for downloading chef dk
just copy this link and go back to your
terminal
and paste it here
so your chef dk is being downloaded this
will take a while right after we
download the chef dk our next step is to
install it on our system
so our chef dk is downloaded now let's
install it
so guys this is the version of chef dk
that you have downloaded so make sure
this is exactly what you type down here
too
so great our chef dk is installed so
basically our installation for the
workstation is done right now but just
so you understand how the flow is we'll
also write a sample recipe on our
workstation so before we do that let's
first create a folder
my folder name chef repo basically the
chef repository
and let's move into this folder
okay so we're in next what we need to do
is as i mentioned earlier all your
recipes will be within a cookbook so
let's create a folder which will hold
all our cookbooks
and let's move into this too
okay so our next stage is to create the
actual cookbook within which we'll have
our recipe so the command for creating
the cookbook is chef generate
cookbook
sample because so samples the name of my
cookbook so guys please notice here cook
books is the directory that i created
which will hold all our cookbooks and
here cookbook is the key word so sample
is that one cookbook that we are
creating under our folder cookbooks
and our cookbooks been created great so
that's done moving into our kubo
okay so when our cookbook sample was
created automatically there's this
hierarchical structure associated with
it so let's have a look at this
hierarchical structure to understand
what our cookbook sample exactly is
before we move on so the command for
looking at a hierarchical structure is
tree so as you see here within our
cookbook we have a folder recipes and
under this there's the default.rb recipe
this is where we'll be creating our
recipe so we'll just alter the content
of default.rb so let's move on to
finally writing our recipes so we'll
move into this recipes folder first
so now we'll open our recipe default at
rb in geoedit
so the recipe for this particular demo
is to install the http package on our
client node that is basically your
apache server and we'll also be hosting
a very simple web page so let's begin
so the recipes in chef is written in
ruby
so i'll explain you the recipe in a
while
okay so the first line is where you
install httpd the second line for
service is where you start or enable the
httpd service on the client node that's
our first task the second part where we
need to create our web page
so this is the part where your web page
will be stored
if you have written any html file
previously you know that this is
probably like a default path where our
web pages are created
yep that's it so this is the content
that will be displayed on your web page
if everything works right and i'm pretty
sure it will so now we can save our
recipe and that's done close your grid
so now that we have created the recipe
all our work at the workstation is
completed the next thing we do is we
move on to the server so as i mentioned
earlier we'll be using the server as a
service on the cloud so go to your
browser and here just type manage dot
chef dot io
so this is the home page of your chef
server click here to get started we need
to first create an account for using the
chef server this completely free we just
need to give our email id and a few
other details it's in fact a lot like
creating an account on facebook or
instagram
fill in all the details check the terms
of service box
so the next thing you need to do is go
back to your inbox and verify your email
id so i have my inbox opened here on my
windows machine so this is my inbox you
would have received a mail from chef
software just click on this link to
verify it and create your password
and that's done so let's continue this
on our workstation machine
so type in your username and password
so the first time you log into your chef
server you'll have this pop-up appear
where you need to create a new
organization so create your organization
so this organization is basically the
name that will be associated with the
collection of the client machines first
thing you do go to your administration
tab and download the starter kit so guys
when you're doing this part make sure
that you're on your workstation that is
you're opening your shep server on the
workstation because you need this folder
to be installed here
you save the file so this gets
downloaded so the chef starter kit is
the key to connecting your workstation
with the server and the server with the
node so basically it has a tool called
knife which we'll come across later in
our demo this knife is what takes care
of all the communication and the
transferring of cookbooks between the
three machines
in our case the two machines the
workstation and the node and the one
server so let's go back to our root
directory so our chef starter zip file
is within our downloads folder what we
do first is we'll move the sip folder
into our cookbooks folder and then we'll
unzip it there because our cookbooks
folder is the one that contains the
recipe and that is where we require
knife tool command to be present so we
can send this recipes over to the server
so we'll just check the contents of our
cookbooks right now to ensure that our
chef starter.zip file is within the
cookbooks
yep so it's here so next thing we do is
we need to unzip this folder
great so that's unzipped
and this means that our workstation and
our server are now linked
so we just need to use the knife command
tool to transfer or to upload our
recipes which we created on the
workstation onto the server so before we
execute this command we need to move
into our cookbooks directory as you know
that is where we unzipped our chef's
starter kit so that is where our knife
command is present too
and now let's execute the knife command
so it's nice
cookbook
upload and sample so as you probably
recall sample is the name of the
cookbook that we created and within
sample we created our recipe which is
default.rb so we uploading the entire
cookbook onto the server execute the
command
great so our cookbooks uploaded now
let's check this on our server so move
to your browser where you opened your
chef server and go to policy so here you
go this is the cookbook we uploaded
sample and it's the first time we
uploaded it so the version
0.1.0 the first version now what you
would notice is if you go to the notes
tab there are no notes present so if you
have no nodes you basically have no
machine to execute your cookbooks and
the nodes are not seen right now because
we have not configured them yet so
that's the next thing we need to do all
this so far was done on your master
machine now we'll move on to the node
machine
so before moving on let's just check the
ip of our node machine
so that's our ip note this down
somewhere and now we move back to our
workstation
as we already saw that we uploaded a
sample workbook next thing we need to
make sure that our server and node are
able to communicate with each other so
again we use the knife tool for this
tool
the command here is knife bootstrap and
enter the ip address of your node which
we just checked
we'll be logging in there so we'll be
using the node as the root user
and then we also need to specify our
root password for the node and we give a
name to this node so this is the name by
which we'll be identifying our node at
the server
so as you have probably noticed here
we're using the term ssh which is a
secure shell so it basically provides a
channel of secure communication between
two machines in an unsafe environment
okay so it's done so if your command has
executed right which in our case as we
can see has our chef's server and our
chef node must be able to communicate
with each other so if this is so we
should be able to send the cookbook that
we previously uploaded from a
workstation onto the server now from a
server to our node so to do that before
we move on to the node machine we need
to go back to our chef's server let's
refresh this page and as you see here
previously under the notes tab we did
not have any node mentioned now we do
chef node which is the node we wanted to
identify our node by which is a centos
platform and that's our ip so it's
active for two hours that's the uptime
last check in the last time we checked
into our node was a minute back and yeah
that's pretty much it so now we'll
create a run list and we'll add our
sample to this run list
so just click on your node and you'll
see the small arrow here in the end
click on that
edit run list and under available
recipes we have a cookbook sample
present so drag and drop this to the
current run list and accept it okay so
now that we updated our run list our
recipe is sent to our node what we next
need to do is that we need to execute
this at our node so now we'll move on to
our node machine
shift client is the command to execute
your
so while this recipe is executing you
can see what exactly is happening our
recipe was to install http package first
which is your apache server so the first
line that's done and it's up to date the
second line it's enabled third line the
service is started and the fourth line
is where your contents created for the
web page at this very location so by the
look of this everything should work fine
so how do we check this we can just go
to our browser and the search bar just
type localhost and there you go so our
httpd package which is the patchy server
is installed and our sample webpage is
also hosted if you look at the devops
approach or the devops lifecycle you
will see that chef falls under
operations and deployment so before we
begin let's have a brief look at all
that you'll learn today first we'll get
to know why should we use chef and what
exactly is the chef two of the most
common terms used with chef
configuration management and
infrastructure as code we'll have a
brief look at these we'll also have a
look at the components of chef and the
chef architecture quickly go through the
various flavors of chef and finally
we'll wrap it up with the demo a demo on
the installation of apache on our nodes
so let's begin guys why should we use
chef well consider a large company now
this company caters to a large number of
clients and provides a number of
services or solutions of course to get
all of this done they need a huge number
of servers and a huge number of systems
basically they will have a huge
infrastructure now this infrastructure
needs to be continuously configured and
maintained in fact when you're dealing
with an infrastructure that size there's
a good chance systems may be failing and
in the long run as your company expands
new systems may even get added so what
do you do well you could say the company
has the best system administrator out
there but all by himself could he
possibly take care of an infrastructure
that size no he can't and that's where
chef comes in because chef automates
this entire process so what does chef
provide chef provides continuous
deployment so when you look at the
market space today you see how products
and their updates are coming out in a
matter of days so it's very important
that a company is able to deploy the
product the minute it's ready so that
once it's out it's not already obsolete
chef also provides increased system
robustness as we saw chef can automate
the infrastructure but in spite of this
automation there's a good possibility
that errors do creep in chef can detect
all these bugs and remove them before
deploying them into the real environment
not only this chef also adapts to the
cloud we all know how today the services
tools solutions everything is revolving
around the cloud so chef does really
play along by making itself easily
integratable with the cloud platform so
now that you know why to use chef let's
look at what exactly is chef chef is an
open source tool developed by ops code
of course there are paid versions of
chef such as chef enterprise but other
than that most of it is freely
accessible chef is written in ruby and
erlang if you would have gone through
any previous material on chef i'm sure
you would have come across ruby being
related to chef but not erlang so this
is why because ruby and erlang are both
used to bill chef but when it comes to
actually writing the codes in chef it's
just ruby and these are the codes that's
deployed onto your multiple servers and
does the automatic configuration and
maintenance and this is why chef is a
configuration management tool so i've
used this term configuration management
a couple of times what exactly does this
mean let's start with the definition of
configuration management configuration
management is a collection of
engineering practices that provides a
systematic way to manage entities for
efficient deployment so let's break this
down configuration management basically
is a collection of practices and what
are these practices for these practices
are for managing your entities the
entities which are required for
efficient deployment so what are these
entities that you need for efficient
deployment they are code infrastructure
and people code is basically the code
the system administrators right for
configuring your various systems
infrastructure is the collection of your
systems and your servers and then
finally you have the teams that take
care of this infrastructure so codes
need to be updated whenever your
infrastructure needs a new configuration
or some sort of updation in the
operating system or the software
versions your code needs to be updated
at first and as the requirements of the
company change the infrastructure's
configuration needs to change and
finally of course the people need
coordination so if you have a team of
system administrators and say person a
makes some change to the code person b c
d and so on need to be well aware when
the change is made as to why it was made
what was the change made and where
exactly this change was made so there
are two types of configuration
management on our left we have the push
configuration here the server that holds
the files with instructions to configure
your notes pushes these files onto the
node so the complete control lies with
the server on your right side we have
the pull configuration in case of pull
configuration the nodes pole against the
server to first check if there's any
change in the configurations required if
there is the nodes themselves pull these
configuration files shelf follows pull
configuration and how it does this we'll
see further in our video another
important term often used with chef
infrastructure as code so let's
understand what this term infrastructure
as code means through this small story
so here's tim tim's a system
administrator at a large company now he
receives a task he has to set up a
server and he has to install 20 software
applications over it so he begins he
sets up the server but then it hits him
it would take him the entire night to
install 20 software applications
wouldn't things have been much simpler
if he just had a code to do so well of
course codes do make things much simpler
codes have a number of advantages
they're easily modifiable so if today
tim is told we need mysql installed on
20 systems tim simply writes a code to
do so and the very next day tim is told
we changed our mind we don't need maya
skill i think we'll just use oracle this
does not bother him because now he just
opens the file he makes a few
corrections in his code and that should
work just fine code is also testable so
if tim had to write 10 commands to do
something and at his tenth command he
realized the very first command he wrote
there was something not right there well
that would be quite tiresome wouldn't it
with codes however you can test it even
before running it and all the bugs can
be caught and corrected codes are also
deployable so they're easily deployable
and they're deployable multiple times so
now that we saw the various advantages
of having codes let's say what
infrastructure as code exactly is here's
the definition infrastructure as code is
a type of id infrastructure where the
operation team manages the code rather
than a manual procedure so
infrastructure as a code allows the
operations team to take care of a code
which automatically performs various
procedures rather than having to
manually do those procedures so with
this feature all your policies and your
configurations are written as code let's
now look at the various components of
chef so our first component is the
workstation the workstation is the
system where the system administrator
sits he or she creates the codes for
configuring your notes now these codes
which in case of chef are written in
ruby are called the recipes and you'll
have multiple number of recipes so a
collection of recipes is called a
cookbook now these cookbooks are only
created at the workstation but they need
to be stored at the server so the knife
is a command line tool so it's basically
a command that you will see us executing
in one of our demos that shifts these
cookbooks from the workstation over to
the server a second component is the
server so servers like the middleman it
lies between your workstation and your
nodes and this is where all your
cookbooks are stored because as you saw
previously the knife sends these
cookbooks over from the workstation to
the server the server can be hosted
locally that's on your workstation
itself or it can be remote so you can
have your server at a different location
you can even have it on the cloud
platform and a final components the node
so nodes are the systems that require
the configuration in a chev architecture
you can have a number of nodes oh hi is
a service which is installed on your
node and it is responsible for
collecting all the information regarding
your current state of the node this
information is then sent over to the
server to be compared against the
configuration files and check if any new
configuration is required chef client is
another such service on your node which
is responsible for all the
communications with the server so
whenever the node has a demand for a
recipe the shift client is responsible
for communicating this demand to the
server since you have a number of nodes
in a chef architecture it's not
necessary that each node is identical so
of course every node can have a
different configuration let's now have a
look at the chef architecture so here we
have a workstation one server machine
and two nodes you can have any number of
nodes first things first the system
administrator must create a recipe so
the recipes that are mentioned in our
chef architecture are just dummy recipes
we look into actual functioning recipes
later in our demo so you have one recipe
two recipes three recipes and a
collection of recipes forms a cookbook
so guys if you look at the recipe in
source you have simply learn three 3.erb
erb is the extension for your ruby files
so the cookbooks are only created at the
workstation they now need to be sent
over to the server where they are stored
and this is the task of the knife knife
is a command line tool which is
responsible for transferring all your
cookbooks onto the server from the
workstation here's the command for
running your knife knife upload simply
db where simply db is the name of the
cookbook we then move on to our node
machines at our nodes we run the ohi
service the ohio service will collect
all information regarding the current
state of your notes and send it over to
the chef client when you run the chef
client these informations are sent over
to the server and they are tested
against the cookbooks so if there is any
discrepancy between the current state of
your notes and the cookbook that is if
one of the notes does not match the
configurations required the cookbook is
then fetched from the server and
executed at the node this sets the node
to the right state there are various
flavors of chef we'll quickly go through
these first we have chef solo with chef
solo there's no separate server so your
cookbooks are located on the node itself
now this kind of configuration is used
only when you have just a single node to
take care of the next flavor is the
hosted chef with hosted chef you still
have your workstation and your note but
your server is now used as a service on
the cloud this really makes things
simple because you don't have to set up
a server yourself and it still performs
all the functioning of a typical chef
this is the configuration you will
notice that we'll be using in our demo
chef client server with chef client
server you have a workstation you have
server and you have n number of nodes
now this is the traditional chef
architecture this is the one we have
used for all the explanations previously
and finally we have private chef private
chef is also known as enterprise chef in
this case your workstation server and
node all are located within the
enterprise infrastructure this is the
main difference between chef client
server and private chef in case of shep
client server all these three machines
could be dispersed the enterprise
version of chef also provides the
liberty to add extra layers of security
and other features and we reach the
final part of our video where we'll have
the hands-on so before we dive into our
demo let me just quickly give you an
introduction to it we'll be using two
virtual boxes both sent to s7 one will
be used as workstation while the other
will be a node so we are just using one
node to make things simple the server
will be used as a service on the cloud
now these are the steps we'll be
performing during our demo we'll first
download and install the chef dk on our
workstation we then make an empty
cookbook file and we'll write a recipe
into it we need to then set up the
server so as i mentioned earlier server
will be a service on the cloud so you'll
have to create a profile but this will
be completely free we then link the
workstation to the server and will
upload the recipe to the server the
notes will now download the cookbooks
from the server and configure themselves
so now that you have some idea about
what we'll be doing let's move on to the
actual demo we begin our demo
here's my oracle vm virtualbox manager i
have two machines here i've already
created my workstation and node both of
these are sent to s7 machines
just for you to differentiate this is my
terminal
and for my workstation it's a black
background with white text and as of my
note it's a black background with green
text
the first thing you do is you go to your
workstation box and open a web browser
search for chef dk installation
go to the first link which is your
chef's official page and under red hat
enterprise because our system is a red
hat system
select the link of the version that
you're using so i'm using centos 7 so my
operating system version is 7 so i'll
take this link now this is the link for
downloading your chef dk you copy this
link and go to your terminal guys notice
i'm in the home directory of my root
user so let's install our chef dk
and it's getting installed now this will
take some time because it's quite a
large file
and chevy case download it next step we
need to install it
and this is the version of the chef dk
that we have downloaded
so type the same
okay so that's done so now we need to
make our recipes and the recipes will
exist within cookbooks so first let's
make a chef repository so within that
we'll have a folder for holding all our
cookbooks and within our cookbook we'll
write our recipe so we start with the
directory for chef repository
[Music]
move into it
create a folder called
cookbooks within which we'll stored each
of our cookbooks
move into this
folder
[Music]
okay so we'll just check the contents
here right now so we have our chef decay
we have a chef repo folder here and
let's check the content of the chef repo
and this has cookbooks okay so our first
cookbook that we'll be making will be
under this folder cookbooks so let's
move into cookbooks
we are in now we need to create our
first cookbook so the instruction for
creating your first cookbook is chef
generate
cookbook
and the name of your cookbook so i'm
just giving the name a sample
yeah so our cookbook sample is created
now when you create your cookbook you'll
notice that a hierarchy is also
automatically created so let's just
check the hierarchy of our cookbook
let's move into sample
and three is the command for checking
the hierarchy so here as you can see we
have recipes and under recipes we have
default dot rb so we'll be editing this
default.rb to create our recipe okay so
let's begin with that let's move into
our recipes folder
and open your default.rb
and here we are so now we'll type in our
code
so what's our recipe for our recipe is
for installing the httpd package
on our note and then we'll also create a
small index file where we'll just have a
simple content such as welcome or
something like that just to check if our
httpd is working fine so let's begin
typing the code here package httpd
service
http
do and what must be done with this
package is that once it's installed it
needs to be enabled
and it needs to be started
and so that's our first task our next
task
is creating our html file
so as you know all your html files
will follow this path name
and this is the content of your file
you have successfully
configured your note
and that's it that's our simple code
so our recipe is now ready save it and
exit back to your terminal now what we
need to do is that we need to configure
our server so go to your browser
on the search engine type manage dot
chef dot io
so as i mentioned earlier we'll be using
a server as a service on the cloud
so you'll enter your
login page
for the chef server most of you may not
have a profile already so you go to
click here to get started and fill in
the details
it's just like creating an account on
facebook so i already have my account
i've put in the credentials here i'll
just sign in now the first thing once
you sign in is you'll get an option to
create an organization so all you have
to do there is you gotta enter the name
of your organization and just below that
there's another box for entering a short
form of your organization now my
organization name was simply learn and
the short form was slp one two three so
when you come to the administration tab
under organization you can see this
organization name next step click on
this arrow and you gotta download your
starter kit okay so once you click on
down start a kit you'll come to this
page where there's a button for download
starter kit
so do download it
save the file
so now come back to your terminal
so you come back to your terminal and
next what you need to do is you need to
unzip your shiftstarter.zip so for that
first we'll move our chef starter to the
root so it's currently present under the
downloads folder let's move it
so we have moved our chef starter.zip
now let's unzip it
first let's just check
the contents of our root directory right
now
so we have a chef repository
chef repo fi a folder that we created
the chef starter zip
that we just moved and of course the
chef dk so now we can unzip our
chef starter kit
and that's done so our next step we
gotta move the chef
starters.zip file into a cookbook which
lies inside the chef repository this is
done because we'll be executing our
further commands to connect our
workstation with the server from the
cookbooks because that is where our
sample cookbook is
and that's moved
so now we'll run a knife command so what
knife does is that it uploads your
recipes or your cookbooks onto the
server so here's the command for running
your knife
samples the name of the cookbook that
you're uploading and uploading sample
0.1.0
and uploading sample yeah so our
cookbook is uploaded now let's just
check this at our server how we do that
is
go back to your browser where you have
open your server
so there's no node here yet
because we have not configured our node
with the server but we have configured
our workstation with the server and you
see here our cookbooks
uploaded sample so our workstation and
our server are connected so now we need
to connect our node with the server so
first we move on to our node machine
we need to take the ip address of our
node machine
so for the ip address we'll just type
ifconfig
[Music]
right so this is your ip address
192.168.2 point
note this down somewhere guys
now that's done
go back to your workstation
i'll just keep it this way so i can see
both okay go back to your workstations
terminal
but this time to connect our server with
the node so we have taken the ip of our
node and this is where we'll be using it
192.168.
point the username which is
root in our case
and then enter the password
and then finally you enter your node
name
so this is the name that will appear for
this particular node on our server i'm
just giving it chef node you can give it
whatever you like we'll just check the
command knife bootstrap the ip address
ssh user our user which is root
ssh password the password for the root
and finally the node name
and the nodes getting created
so once the node is connected to your
server we'll go back to our browser open
our server service on the cloud and
we'll check the node tab so ideally your
node name should appear there
great so our node is added also if you
notice here our chef client service on
the note has started running so let's
just check this with the server
go to your notes
and here we go so chef node a centos 7
platform
this is our ip so it's all done so now
we need to add a cookbook to the run
list of this node so come here click on
this arrow
edit run list
here sample this is the cookbook that we
want to run on our node put on the
current run list and here we have the
run button just click on that so this
should have transferred our cookbook
onto the node let's check that go to
your node machine
clear this
we need to be the root
let's run the chef client service
so we are running it once again because
after it was started we did add
something to our run list
the changes in the run list is updated
so in 1 minute 56 seconds
our cookbook has
run
on our node so the configuration changes
should have been made
let's check that it's pretty simple just
go to your browser
on the search engine just type localhost
and here's our html page that we created
on our workstation
congrats you configured your first note
and i really hope you did so that is the
end of our demo we have successfully
installed the httpd package on our node
and we have also executed a html file so
with that we come to an end to our video
now let's have a quick look at
everything you learned today first you
saw why you should probably use chef
then what exactly is this chef we looked
into the two most important terms often
used with chef configuration management
and infrastructure as code we also saw
the various components of chef and how
these components work together to
provide the capabilities that chef does
we looked into the four flavors of chef
and finally we wrapped it up with the
demo on installing http package on a
note and also writing a simple html file
hello this is matthew from simply learn
we're going to focus specifically on
puppet so in this session what we're
going to do is we're going to cover what
and why you would use puppets what are
the different elements and components of
puppet and how does it actually work and
then we'll look into the companies that
are adopting puppet and what are the
advantages that they have now received
by having puppet within their
organization and finally we'll wrap
things up by reviewing how you can
actually write a manifest in puppet so
let's get started so why puppet so here
is a scenario that as an administrator
you may already be familiar with you as
an administrator have multiple servers
that you have to work with and manage so
what happens when a server goes down
it's not a problem you can jump onto
that server and you can fix it but what
if the scenario changes and you have
multiple servers going down so here is
where puppet shows its strap with puppet
all you have to do is write a simple
script that can be written with ruby and
write out and deploy to the servers your
settings for each of those servers the
code gets pushed out now to the servers
that are having problems and then you
can choose to either roll back to those
servers to their previous working states
or set them to a new state and do all of
this in a matter of seconds and it
doesn't matter how large your server
environment is you can reach to all of
these servers your environment is secure
you're able to deploy your software and
you're able to do this all through
infrastructure as code which is the
advanced dev ops model for building out
solutions so let's dig deeper into what
puppet actually is so puppet is a
configuration management tool maybe
similar tools like chef that you may
already be familiar with it ensures that
all your systems are configured to a
desired and predictable state public can
also be used as a deployment tool for
software automatically you can deploy
your software to all of your systems or
to specific systems and this is all done
with code this means you can test the
environment and you can have a guarantee
that the environment you want is written
and deployed accurately so let's go
through those components of puppet so
here we have a breakdown of the puppet
environment and on the top we have the
main server environment and then below
that we have the client environment that
would be installed on each of the
servers that would be running within
your network so if we look at the top
part of the screen we have here our
puppet master store which has and
contains our main configuration files
and those are comprised of manifests
that are actual codes for configuring
the clients we have templates that
combine our codes together to render a
final document and you have files that
will be deployed as content that could
be potentially downloaded by the clients
wrapping this all together is a module
of manifest templates and files you
would apply a certificate authority to
sign the actual document so that the
clients actually know that they're
receiving the appropriate and authorized
modules outside of the master server
where you'd create your manifest
templates and files you would have
public client is a piece of software
that is used to configure a specific
machine there are two parts to the kind
one is the agent that constantly
interacts with the master server to
ensure that the certificates are being
updated appropriately and then you have
the fact of it the current state of the
client that is used and communicated
back to through the agent so now that we
know what puppet is let's look into the
puppet architecture so puppet has a
master slave architecture as you can see
here on the top we have the puppet
master and below we have the puppet
clients so the puppet master is the
system where your system administrator
sits the clients are those systems which
require configuration you can have n
number of clients connected to the
puppet master so don't worry we look
into each of these components in detail
firstly we have the puppet master so the
puppet master is where the system
administrator sits and he or she types
in the codes here so the codes are not
only written in the system but they are
also stored here and whenever the client
requires these codes for their
configuration they simply request it
so manifest is the first sub-component
of the puppet master these are the
actual files where the codes are written
so in case of puppet these are ruby
files
modules tie manifests templates and
files into a single unit
now these codes dictate the instructions
for performing various tasks on your
client the next component is templates
so if manifests are your code templates
are the data so let me explain this to
you with an example consider you want to
create a file called index.html on one
of your client machines so what you do
is you write the code for creating this
file in your manifest and the content of
this file is written in your templates
then you simply link them but here's the
thing when you divide your code and data
in this way it's a very clean structure
so it's preferred to do it in this
manner files are your static contents so
the files are basically sent to your
client and they are simply downloaded at
the client there is no execution or
compilation involved with your files now
this is where files and templates are
extremely different because with
templates they are never sent over to
your client the templates are simply
read by the parser at the master itself
modules ties the manifest templates and
files into a single unit so modules is
not a separate component as such it just
provides a very clean hierarchy this is
the most important component of the
puppet master ca which stands for
certificate authority
now as we will see later in this video
the puppet master and the puppet client
communicate through an exchange of ssl
certificates so when the client sends
over the certificate to the master ca
provides the master the authority to
sign these certificates the minute the
master signs a certificate the master is
basically saying that yes this client is
registered with me and i agree to
exchange data with this client our next
component puppet client of course these
are the systems that require to be
configured agent is a service installed
on the client the agent is solely
responsible for all the communication
between the master and the client and
finally we have factor so factor is
responsible for collecting all the data
about the present state of our client
and sending this data over to the puppet
master at the master this data is
compared against the manifest which are
your code files and then these manifests
are sent over to the client depending
upon the results of this comparison so
now that we had a look at the various
components of puppet let's see how these
work together
so we have a master and we have three
clients now before any information can
be transferred between the master and
the client it's important that these
components recognize each other also
there needs to be an encrypted channel
of communication between each pair of
master and client now all the data which
is transferred between the master and
the client it flows through this channel
so let's see how this entire procedure
of recognizing each other works the core
of this procedure are the ssl
certificates ssl stands for secure
socket layer secure socket layer is a
security protocol and it forms an
encrypted channel between two components
what this encrypted channel ensures is
that all the data that is passed through
this channel is not accessible by any
other system outside so it provides
complete security okay so we will
consider a very general scenario we have
a master and a client here this is not
the puppet master or the puppet client
they are just two systems and we're just
going forward with master slave
architecture so the client so far is not
a client it is just a system and we will
refer to the system as system a so
system a sends over a client certificate
to the master
associated with this client certificate
is the host name of system a now master
goes through the certificate it sees the
host name and then it decides whether it
wants to form a communication link with
the system a if it does it signs the
certificate and the signed certificate
is sent back to system a now the system
a is officially a client the minute the
master signed the client certificate it
said that yes i am willing to exchange
information with this system and i do
take the system as one of my clients so
now that the system is officially a
client it can request for data from the
master and the master will simply send
over the data now we are here to talk
about puppet so if this was a puppet
master and this was a puppet client then
the first three stages will be the same
so the puppet client sends over the
certificate to the master the master
signs a certificate sends it back and
the client requests for data now by data
here of course we mean the configuration
data those are the manifest or even
could be your files
so what happens after this request after
this request the factor service which is
present on your clients collects all the
information regarding the present state
of your client so this information could
include the operating system that's
installed on them the various number of
software present on them the versions of
these software now all this information
is collected it's called the fact and
it's sent over to the master at the
master this information that is the
facts is compared against the manifest
so why does the master do this the
master basically compares the facts
against manifest to know if what the
manifest is about to perform is already
performed on these systems so if the
manifest has some additional
functionality they are compiled into
catalogs and then these catalogs are
sent over to the client now remember
those agent services which existed in
your clients here's where they come in
the agents take the catalog and execute
them on the client once executed these
catalogs make the required changes on
the client and a report is generated
this report is then sent back to the
master so the master keeps record of all
the changes that's made in the system
and this comes very handy when one of
the systems fail and it's required to be
rolled back to its previous working
state so this entire procedure can be
repeated n number of times and can be
repeated at regular intervals so if you
have a scenario where a system needs to
be configured every 30 minutes what you
can do is you can set your interval and
automatically every 30 minutes your
systems will be configured so today i'll
be showing you how you can use puppet to
install apache on one of your client
machines so we'll be using two machines
here we'll have a server and we'll have
a node machine the server is essentially
your master the node is your client i'm
just using the term server and node
instead because i want to keep it very
close to as they are used in the
commands now both these machines are
going to be sent to seven machines and i
have oracle vm virtual box installed on
my machine so on that i have simply
created two virtual boxes both sent
centos 7 of course so before we move on
to the actual demo i'll just take you
through the various steps so first we'll
install the puppet server on our server
or master machine we'll then start the
server service we then shift over to our
node or the client machine and we'll
install the puppet agent service we will
then start the service too and the
minute you start the puppet agent
service an ssl certificate is created so
this certificate will have the host name
of your node attached to it and this is
how the master or the server will
recognize the certificate and then it'll
sign the certificate so once your master
or the server signs the certificate you
can write your manifest so the manifesto
is just the codes for configuration and
once that tool is done you shift back to
your client or the node system and you
run the asian service so once you run
the agent service your manifest or your
cat locks because as you know the
manifests are compiled into catalogs
these are executed on your note and this
will make the required changes so that's
how this entire process is going to work
now let's move on to the actual demo
this is my oracle vm virtualbox manager
the last two machines you see here are
the ones we'll be using for this demo
the puppet server is your puppet master
puppet client of course is the client so
let's just have a look at these two
machines
this is my puppet server so just so you
can differentiate guys the terminals
have been set accordingly puppet server
has a black background with white text
and puppet client here has a black
background with green text
so we'll move on to server machine or
the master machine because that's the
one we'll be working on first so before
we begin we need to set the hostname of
a master to puppet so this is a very
essential step in the configuration of
puppet if you miss this out there are
quite a lot of other changes you'll have
to make in certain files so let's do
this first
so that's the command to set the host
name the last word you see there that's
the new host name you want
okay so now we'll just check if our host
name is set so just type host name
and yeah it's puppet
so next we will check the ip of this
machine
so for that you just type if config
enter
so this is your ip guys
under enp0s3
in its value
that is
192.168.2.183 of course the ip will
differ for you guys
needless to say
so note that down somewhere because
we'll require it when we are configuring
our client
okay so now you want your puppet server
and your client
to communicate so for this we need to
remove certain firewalls so the command
for this is
sudo because we want the root permission
system
ctl
stop
firewall
d
and put in the password
okay so all your firewalls are removed
so the next step now we start on with a
puppet process so we download the puppet
labs at first now guys ensure that your
systems your virtual boxes in this case
are connected to the net
also you won't be getting an ip if it's
not for the first time
so here's the command to download the
puppet lag
enter the password again
okay so the puppet labs is downloaded
now you need to install this
so installation guys we will be
installing the puppet server on the
master machine or the puppet server
machine
so this may take a while
so that took a while so i just skipped
to the last part where it's completed
the installation process is over
now we need to make a small change
in our system config puppet server file
so let's just move to the file first
this file will open in vi editor
so this line here it basically allocates
memory for your puppet server now you do
not need 2gb
so we are going to reduce the size
512 mb should be enough
so guys notice here i did not type the b
okay so i just change this to xms
512
m
let's save that
always remember to open this file using
sudo otherwise saving the changes you
made could be quite troublesome
okay so now we can start a puppet server
service
we enable the service
okay so that's done so basically our
puppet server service
has started it's running presently
so for a while we are done with the
server machine
let's move on to our client machine
okay first things first we open our edc
host file
with sudo because you need to make a few
changes and save it
open this in the vi terminal
okay guys so here
you have to add this one line at the end
type in the ip
for your puppet server machine
puppet
puppet
dash
master
so let's save this file
now we'll move on to downloading puppet
labs on our puppet client so the command
is the same that we use for puppet
server
so puppet labs is downloaded now we need
to install the puppet agent service here
again this will also take some time
puppet servers installed
let me just clear this window
now that our puppet agent service is
installed we'll start this service so
i'll just type in the command for
starting the puppet agent service
as you can see here ensure changed
stopped to running
so basically the service was not running
before and now it's changed to the
running state
and while we executed this command not
only did the service starts running but
an ssl certificate was also created so
this certificate should have the host
name of this machine that's a puppet
client machine attached to it so let's
just check what the host name of our
machine is
that's
localhost.localdomain so a certificate
should have this attached to it so guys
the first time your client sends a
certificate
the name of the certificate itself is
usually the host name of the machine so
our certificate's name should be
localhost.localdomain
we'll check this on our master system
and that's where we'll sign the
certificate to
so first we list out all the
certificates in our case since we have
just one client
and we just started the client we should
have technically just one certificate
and it will be so
yeah so this is our certificate
localhost dot local domain
we'll now sign the certificate
okay sorry about that just
need to remove these
brackets
here as you can see your recipes
certificate is signed
sign certificate request
here
so once the certificate is signed the
request for signing the certificate is
removed that's this line
now that a certificate is signed we can
begin to write a manifest so let's move
into a manifest folder and we'll create
a placeholder file
so we'll create a file called sample.pp
this is a sample file we won't be
writing anything in this file as of now
so we're just checking here we're just
creating this file and then we'll go to
our client machine and just check there
if we can access this file from there
so now we will move to our client
machine
so let's test the connection
so as you can see here it says applied
catalog in 0.03 seconds so our catalog
is executed
on our client machine
now our catalog was just a placeholder
basically so the file that we created
which is sample.pp had no content and we
were just testing our client now let's
go back to our master server
put some content into this file and see
how the execution takes place
so we'll open our file sample.pp which
we created earlier in the vi editor
let's type our code here
so node and then within the brackets we
enter the host name of our client
machine
so this ensures that our manifest is
executed on this particular machine
now the apache service package on centos
is called the httpd
so this line that i just typed in is the
action it will ensure that the httpd
package is installed on your client
and that's it
so this is our code we'll save it
now let's go back to our client machine
and test it
so this is a client machine
and our catalogs applied on the client
so i just clear the screen now we'll
start the apache service
okay so how do we see if it's running we
just need to go to our browser
and at localhost you must have the
testing page for your apache
so we type localhost
enter
and yeah this is the testing page for
apache so as you can see we have
successfully used puppet to install the
apache service on our puppet client
and this is the end of
so let's have a look at companies that
are using puppet today there are a
number of companies that have adopted
puppet as a way to manage their
infrastructure so companies that are
using public today include spotify
google att so why are these companies
choosing to use puppet as their main
configuration management tool the answer
can be seen if we look at a specific
company staples so staples chose to take
and use puppet for their configuration
management tool and use it within their
own private cloud the results were
dramatic the amount of time that the it
organization was able to save in
deploying and managing their
infrastructure through using puppets
enabled them to open up time to allow to
experiment with other and new projects
and assignments a real tangible benefit
to a company so let's look at how you
write a manifest in pocket so so
manifests are designed for writing out
in code how you would configure a
specific node in your server environment
the manifests are compiled into catalogs
which are then executed on the client
each of the manifests are written in the
language of ruby with a dot pp extension
now if we step through the five key
steps for writing a manifest they are
one create your manifest and that is
written by the system administrator two
compile your manifest and it's compiled
into a catalog three deploy the catalog
is then deployed onto the clients four
execute the catalogs are run on the
client by the agent and then five and
clients are configured to a specific and
desired state if we actually look into
how manifest is written it's written
with a very common syntax if you've done
any work with ruby or really
configuration of systems in the past
this may look very familiar to you so we
break out the work that we have here you
start off with a package file or service
as your resource type and then you give
it a name and then you look at the
features that need to be said such as ip
address then you're actually looking to
have a command written such as present
or start the manifest can contain
multiple resource types if we continue
to write our manifest and puppet the
default keyword applies a manifest to
all clients so an example would be to
create a file path that creates a folder
called sample in a main folder called
etc the specified content is written
into a file that is then posted into
that folder and then we're going to say
we want to be able to trigger an apache
service and then ensure that that apache
service is installed on a node so we
write the manifest and we deploy it to a
client machine on that client machine a
new folder will be created with a file
in that folder and an apache server will
be installed you can do this to any
machine and you'll have exactly the same
results on those machines now let's have
a look at the puppet community
the puppet community is a rich community
of a lot of people officially there is
no count but counting the various
channels where people collaborate there
are a little over 2 900 committers to
github projects who are directly or
indirectly associated with puppet labs
there are thousand eight hundred and
ninety three modules on the official
puppet forge these include modules from
the puppet labs and also from open
source contributors to github
so that's nearly five thousand modules
of ready-made code available on the
puppet forge so before you write any
code for puppet you can check to see if
it's already been written by someone
now there's a mailing list which has
6588 participants apart from this on
slack overflow you have a big tag of
puppet labs and puppet which gives you a
list of only puppet questions
that's a good playground for you to
interact with people who are already
using puppet
and who are contributing and helping
others now let's have a look at puppet
forge
so puppet forge is a github client for a
repository which is hosted by puppet
labs it has almost five thousand modules
of puppet code so these are both puppet
labs and community contributed
the best thing about this is that
they're easy to customize so when you
have a requirement for anything you're
doing with your infrastructure you can
just grab one of those five thousand
modules and then you can customize it
according to your needs one of the other
benefits is they have built-in tests so
they follow all of the best practices
now if you write your own module you
also have to write your own tests and
you have to spend extra time writing
best practice code
all of that has been taken care of and
you can just download any one of those
and customize it according to your needs
and you're good to go
so that's the benefit you get from such
a large community where people
contribute to the modules and the code
and share with the community the puppet
dsl puppet dsl is a puppet domain
specific language
it's the puppet's primary programming
language it's just like plain english
and you don't really need to be a
programmer to write code in it it's kind
of a sub child of ruby because it
approaches and uses is equal to and
greater than marks to define things so
it's very easy to learn
you can specify packages that you want
to install you can specify services to
be managed you can do things based on
the operating system you have so we'll
be writing a small puppet module which
will be using this puppet dsl we will do
that after we install the puppet server
and the client and then we will write a
simple puppet module to show how to use
the puppet dsl
let's have a look at the demo we are
going to do so you will be setting up
the machines using sudo dns because we
want to have a resolvable dns because
only by having a resolvable dns can we
use puppet because puppet uses the ssl
certificates
now we'll be installing the puppet
server and the client will be signing
the certificates of the client on the
server side and then we'll proceed with
writing an ntp module which we'll be
using for installation of ntp on the
client and then we'll look at the puppet
programming language or dsl now we're
going to look at a demo here so we will
be setting up the machines we'll set up
a pseudo dns locally because puppet
requires a fully qualified domain name
in order to run since there is a
certificate communication taking place
here
we will be installing the puppet server
the puppet client will be signing the
certificate and finally we will write an
ntp module and make it run
so now we will be starting a puppet
master and a client i have two machines
here one is the puppet master and the
second is the puppet client the puppet
master has got almost four gig of ram
and four v cpus which i can show you
here
because it's a ruby on rails application
it requires a lot of cpu and ram
for the client i don't need that much
ram and cpu so i've allotted one
gigabyte of ram and one vcpu
i will start both of these machines and
find out the ip addresses right click
normal start
both of these machines are starting up
the puppet client has started up and the
first thing i'll do is log in using root
and red hat password and then i will
change the host name so i'll say vim etc
hostname this will open a hostname file
in a text editor which is vim
then we'll do a dd which will delete
that existing host name
then i press the i for insert mode and
finally i'll type
the puppet hyphen client
which will be the host name of this
machine i'll save this file by doing
escape semicolon wq exclamation mark
and i'll reboot the machine
similarly going to the puppet master
i'll say root red hat
i'll open the hostname file
say dd then i'll say puppet hyphen
master
i'll save this file and reboot the
machine for the host name change to take
effect the hostname change does not take
effect unless you reboot the machine
now both of these machines are ready
i'm going to find out the ips and use
the mac terminal to log into these
so this is 23 and 21 so 23 is my server
and 21 is my client
i'll ssh to 23 first
now in order for the puppet master to be
installed i need a fully qualified
domain name here and a fake dns which
means a fully resolvable dns name
so if i do hostname here you see my host
name is puppetmaster in order to set up
a fake dns i need to go to the etc hosts
file
go to the end
then i say i p address hostname local
then space hostname now this is one of
the techniques which makes the linux
server believe that there's a fully
qualified domain name on this machine
i'll save this
then i do a host name hyphen f
you see it has a fully qualified domain
name now
so now we will be downloading the puppet
labs repository for ubuntu 16.04 which
is zenial
so i'll say curl hyphen zero https
apps.puppetlabs.com
slash puppet labs hyphen release
hyphen pc1 hyphensenial.dap
you can see there is a debian file which
has been downloaded here i will import
this using the dpkg command so i'll say
dpkg hyphen i puppet labs hyphen release
hyphen pc1 hyphensenial.dab
and then i'll say apt get update which
will update my app package indexes on
this machine
and now i'll install the puppet server
so i'll say apt-get install
puppet hyphen
puppet server hyphen-y
so the puppet server is now installed
and we will be configuring the memory
allocation for the puppet server so i'll
say etc default puppet server so by
default
it has only
got two gigabyte allocated we'll give it
three gigabyte because it's jvm
i'll make this three and i'll change
this to three as well
and i'll save this file
i'll make sure the unconfigured firewall
allows port 8140 which is the puppet lab
puppet server port
the rules have been updated to allow
that i'll now start the puppet server so
i'll say a system ctl
start puppet server
it takes some time because it's jvm so
it takes a couple of minutes to start
the puppet server
so the puppet server is now running
i'll also enable it at boot time so i'll
say system ctl enable puppet to server
it will enable it boot time
now i also need to configure a fully
qualified domain name here so okay so
i'll do that by going into the hosts
file
i'll go to the end and i'll say
192.168.1.23 and then puppet
hyphen server.local and then puppet
hyphen server
if i do a hostname hyphen f
put hyphen master.local because the
current hostname is
puppet hyphen master
so the trick is to have the
hostname.local in front of the ip
address in the host file
having a fully qualified domain name now
now we will go to the client setup
the client setup is almost the same with
just a small difference
the package which we need to install on
the client is puppet agent so we will go
to the client
so you see this has got a hostname
now we also need to set up the fake dns
here so i'll copy this hostname
open the host line
go to the end
write the ip address
and then dot local and then host name
again
so this will give me a fully qualified
domain name
so when i do a host name
it says puppet hive and client when i do
a host name hyphen f it says puppet
client local to install the puppet agent
on this machine i will need to download
the zenio packages so i'll say wget
https
slash
apt.puppetlabs.com
labs
hyphen release hyphen pc1
hyphensenial.deb
i'll download this and then i'll say
dpkg hyphen i puppet labs iphone release
hyphen pc1 hyphensenial.dap
so this is the repository package which
i'll be downloading here and then i'll
say apt-get
update hyphen y this will update my apps
caches on this machine
and now i'll finally install the puppet
agent
so i'll say apt-get install puppet agent
hyphen agent hyphen y
now the puppet agent is here i'll start
the puppet agent and i'll enable it at
boot time so i'll say system control
start puppet
then system control
enable puppet
now puppet is enabled now we have set up
the fully qualified domain name on the
client and the server but each of them
should know each other so we'll have to
do a cross certificate host mapping so
we will be copying the host file entry
of the client and adding it to the
server so i'll go to the etc hosts on
the server side go to the end paste it
there
okay and i'll be adding the entry of the
master on the client side
okay now both of the servers will
recognize each other now because one of
them has the host entry of the other
so if if i do from the master ping
puppet iphone agent dot local
if i ping the agent from the server
hyphen client.local
it is able to ping it and if i ping the
master from the client
if i say ping puppet hyphenmaster.local
both of them will be able to ping each
other
now the next step would be to create a
certificate signing request so i'll go
to my to this directory which is opt
puppet labs puppet bin
and i'll say puppet agent hyphen t
hyphen knife and server
is equal to
and i'll give the fully qualified domain
name of the puppet master
then i'll say
hyphen f
when i do this it will create a
certificate signing request you see
now if i go to the server and i do an
opt
i'll check and see how many certificates
are pending to be signed
you'll see there is a puppet client
certificate which is pending to be
signed which is denoted by the absence
of a plus sign here
i'll be signing the certificate so i'll
say puppet search sign and then the name
so puppet hyphen client
dot local this will sign the
certificates and when i go to the server
on the client side if i run the puppet
agent again
you see it's actually pulling down the
catalog as of now it has an empty
catalog
that says there is nothing
now we have configured the puppet agent
and the master now we will be taking a
module from puppet forge
puppet forge is a big collection of open
source modules which are free to use as
a first step we will be using a
ready-made module
and that would be a demonstration for
how to actually get up and running with
a module so search for apache module
here
this is the puppet labs apache module
i'll be using the puppet command line
puppet module install this is the
command for that
but i will make sure i run this command
from the puppet home so i'll go to the
master i'll go to etc puppet labs
code environments production
in this i'll do modules
now i will run it from the binary which
is present at the opt puppet labs bin
puppet
and then module install
puppet labs hyphen apache and then this
version so we are specifying the latest
version
and i'll hit enter
when i press enter it starts downloading
from the forge api
so you see the module is downloaded in
addition to the dependencies so there is
concat stdlib and apache
so now i'll go to a folder here which is
one level up called manifest so this is
the file here etc puppet labs code
environments production manifest so in
this there's a file which i'll be
creating called site.pp the site.pp will
specify and this is the main controller
of how the infrastructure looks in the
site pp
i specify
that i want
puppethyphenclient.localnode to have the
apache module included
i'll save this file and the only thing i
need to do now is
since all is set on the server side i
need to go to the client side and run
puppet agent it will automatically
download the apache module and compile
it and may then make sure the server is
in a state so when i press enter we see
a lot of output it tries to configure
apache on this machine
and done now when i go to the front end
of this machine on this port i should be
able to see apache's default page so
this is apaches default page
so the module which we downloaded from
the forge was actually written in a way
that apache would be installed and run
at boot time so that is why it's running
here
and that is all we have from the
puppet module
and this concludes the demo today i'll
be showing you how you can install the
configuration management tool ansible so
let's have a brief about why one would
use ansible and what exactly is ansible
so if you consider the case of an
organization it has a very large
infrastructure which means it has more
than probably hundreds of systems and
giving one or even a small team of
people the responsibility to configure
all these systems makes their work
really tough repetitive and as you know
manual work is always prone to errors so
ansible is a tool which can automate the
configuration of all these systems with
ansible a small team of system
administrators can write simple code in
yaml and these codes are deployed onto
the hundreds and thousands of servers
which configures them to the desired
states so ansible automates
configuration management that is
configuring your systems it automates
orchestration which means it brings
together a number of applications and
decides an order in which these are
executed and it also automates
deployment of the applications now that
we know what ansible does let's move on
to the installation of ansible so here
is my oracle vm virtualbox manager i'll
be using two systems there's the node
system which is basically my client
system and there's a server system or
the master system so let's begin at our
server system
so this is my master system guys so the
first thing we do is we download our
ansible tool
so one thing we must remember with
ansible is that unlike
chef or puppet ansible is a push type of
configuration management tool so what
this means is that the entire control
here lies with your master or your
server system this is where you write
your configuration files and these are
also responsible for pushing these
configuration files onto your node or
client system as and when required
creates our ansible tool is installed
now we need to open an ansible host file
and there we'll specify the details of
our node or client machine
so this is a ansible host file as you
can see here the entire file is
commented but there's a certain syntax
that you'd observe for example here we
have a group name web servers under
which we have the ip addresses or
certain host name so this is about how
we'll be adding the details for our
client system first we need to give a
group
under this group basically we add all
the clients which require a certain type
of configuration since we are using just
one node we'll give only the details for
that particular node first we need to
add the ip address of our client machine
so let's just go back to our client
machine
and this here is the ip address
192.168.2.11
once you have typed in your ip address
give a space and then we'll specify the
user for our client machine
so all communications between the server
or the master system and the client or
the node system takes place through ssh
ssh basically provides a secure channel
for the transfer of information
follow this up with your password in my
case it's the root's password
and that's it we are done so now we save
this file and go back to our terminal
so now that our host file is written the
next thing we do is we write our
playbook the playbook is the technical
term used for all the configuration
files that we write in ansible now
playbooks are written in yaml yaml is
extremely simple to both write and
understand it's in fact very close to
english
so now we'll write our playbook the
playbook or any code in yaml first
starts with three dashes this indicates
the beginning of your file next thing we
need to give a name to our playbook
so name
and i'm going to name my playbook sample
book
we next need to specify our host systems
which is basically the systems at which
the configuration file or the playbook
in our case will be executed so we'll be
executing this at the client machines
mentioned under the group ansible
servers so we had just one client
machine under it we'll still mention the
group name
we next need to specify the username
with which we'll be logging into our
client machine which is root in my case
and become true specifies that you need
to become the root to execute this
playbook so becoming the roots called a
privilege escalation
next we need to specify our tasks so
these are basically the actions that the
playbook will be performing so you would
have noticed everything so far is
aligned that is name host remote user
become and task because these are at one
level now whatever comes under task will
be shifted slightly towards the right
although yaml is extremely simple to
understand and read both it's a little
tricky while writing because you need to
be very careful about the indentations
and the spacing
so my first task is install httpd which
is basically apache server
so now my commands yum and this will be
installing the httpd package
and the latest date of it will be
installed so that's our first task
now our second task would be running our
apache service
so name
run httpd
and the action which is service
will be performed on httpd hence the
name httpd
and state
must be started
now we come to our third task
so here we'll create a very simple web
page that will be hosted
so create content is the name of our
task
and the content that we are creating
here will basically be copied
to our note system at a particular file
location that we'll provide
our content will be congrats
and then we'll provide the destination
at which this file will be copied
so this is the default location for all
our html files
and that's it we are done writing our
playbook
just save this and go back to your
terminal
before we execute the playbook or push
the playbook onto our note system let's
check the syntax of our playbook so the
command for doing so is
and if everything is fine with your
playbook the output would be just your
playbook name so our syntax is perfectly
fine now we can push on the playbook to
our node or the client machine
and that's the syntax for doing so now
as your playbook is being sent over to
the client machine you can see that
first the facts are gathered that is the
current state of your client machine is
first fetched to check what all is to be
changed and what is already present so
the first thing is installing httpd so
our system already had httpd so it says
ok because this does not need to be
changed our next task was running httpd
now although our system had the apache
service it was not running so that is
one thing that was changed the next was
there was no content available so the
content was also added so two tasks were
changed and four things were okay now
everything seems fine and before you
move any forward it is very important
that you check this one line of
documentation provided by ansible you
have all kind of information available
here regarding which all tasks were
executed if your client machine was
reachable or unreachable and so on so
now that everything is fine here we can
move on to our node system
and we'll just go to our browser so if
our playbook has been executed here what
should happen is that the httpd service
must be in the running state and the
webpage that we created should be hosted
so let's just type localhost
and great everything's working fine so
our web page is displayed here so we
come to an end for our installation and
configuration video for the
configuration management tool ansible if
you have any doubts please post them in
the comment section below and we'll
definitely get back to you as soon as
possible ansible today as one of the key
tools that you would have within your
devops environment
so the things that we're going to go
through today is we're going to cover
why you would want to use a product like
ansible what ansible really is and how
it's of value to you and your
organization the differences between
ansible and other products that are
similar to it on the market and what
makes ansible a compelling product and
then we're going to dig into the
architecture for ansible we're going to
look at how you would create a playbook
how you'd manage your inventory of your
server environments and then what is the
actual workings of ansible as a little
extra we're going to also throw in
ansible tower one of the secret source
solutions that you can use for improving
the speed and performance of how you
create your ansible environments and
finally we're going to go through a use
case by looking at hootsuite social
media management company and how they
use ansible to really improve the
efficiency within their organizations so
let's jump into this so the big question
is why ansible so you have to think of
ansible as another tool that you have
within your devops environment for
helping manage the service and this
definitely falls on the operation side
of the dev ops equation so if we look
here we have a picture of sam and like
yourselves sam is a system administrator
and he is responsible for maintaining
the infrastructure for all the different
servers within his company so some of
the servers that he may have that he has
to maintain could be web servers running
apache they could be database servers
running uh mysql and if you only have a
few servers then that's fairly easy to
maintain i mean if you have three web
servers and two database servers and
let's face it would we all love just to
have one or two servers to manage it
would be really easy to maintain the
trick however is as we start increasing
the number of servers and this is a
reality of the environments that we live
and operate in it becomes increasingly
difficult to create consistent setup of
different infrastructures such as web
servers and databases for the simple
reason that we're all human as if we had
to update and maintain all of those
servers by hand there's a good chance
that we would not set up each server
identically now this is where anspo
really comes to the rescue and helps you
become an efficient operations team
ansible like other system solutions such
as chef and puppet uses code that you
can write and describe the installation
and setup of your servers so you can
actually repeat it and deploy those
servers consistently into multiple areas
so now you don't have to have one person
redoing and re-following setup
procedures you just write one script and
then each script can be executed and
have a consistent environment so we've
gone through why you'd want to use
ansible let's step through what ansible
really is
so you know this is all great but you
know how do we actually use these tools
in our environment so
ansible hat is a tool that really allows
you to create and control
three key areas that you'd have within
your operations environment first of all
there's it automation so you can
actually write instructions that
automate the it setup that you would
typically do manually in the past the
second is the configuration and having
consistent configuration imagine setting
up hundreds of apache servers and being
able to guarantee with precision that
each of those apache servers is set up
identically and then finally you want to
be able to automate the deployment so
that as you scale up your server
environment you can just push out
instructions that can deploy
automatically different servers the
bottom line is you want to be able to
speed up and make your operations team
more efficient so let's talk a little
bit about pull configuration and how it
works with ansible so there are two
different ways of being able to set up
uh different
environments for server farms
one is to have a key server that has all
the instructions on and then on each of
the servers that connect to that main
master server you would have a piece of
software known as a client installed on
each of those servers that would
communicate to the main master server
and then would periodically either
update or change the configuration of
the slave server this is known as a pull
configuration an alternative is a push
configuration and the push configuration
is slightly different the main
difference is as with a pull
configuration you have a master server
where you actually put up the
instructions but unlike the pull
configuration where you have a client
installed on each of the services with a
push configuration you actually have no
client installed on the remote servers
you simply are pushing out the
configuration to those servers and
forcing a restructure or a fresh clean
installation in that environment so
ansible is one of those second
environments where it's a push
configuration server and this contrasts
with other popular products like chef
and puppet which have a master slave
architecture with a master server
connecting with a client on a remote
slave environment where you would then
be pushing out the updates with ansible
you're pushing out the service and the
structure of the server to remote
hardware and you are just putting it
onto the hardware irrelevant of the
structure that's out there and there are
some significant advantages that you
have in that in that you're not having
to have the extra overhead weight of a
client installed on those remote servers
having to constantly communicate back to
the master environment so let's step
through the architecture that you would
have for an ansible environment
so when you're setting up an ansible
environment the first thing you want to
do is have a local machine and the local
machine is where you're going to have
all of your instruction and really the
power of the control that you'd be
pushing out to the remote server so the
local machine is where you're going to
be starting and doing all of your work
connected from the local machine are all
the different nodes pushing out the
different configurations that you would
set up on the local machine the
configurations that you would write and
you would write those in code within a
module so you do this on your local
machine for creating these modules and
each of these modules is actually
consistent playbooks the local machine
also has a second job and that job is to
manage the inventory of the nodes that
you have in your environment the local
machine is able to connect to each of
the different nodes that you would have
in your hardware network through ssh
clients so a secure client let's dig
into some of the different elements
within that architecture and we're going
to take a first look at playbooks that
you would write and create for the
ansible environments so the core of
ansible is the playbook this is where
you create the instructions that you
write to define the architecture of your
hardware so the playbook is really just
a set of instructions that configure the
different nodes that you have and each
of those set of instructions is written
in a language called yammer and this is
a standard language used for
configuration server environments did
you know that yaml actually stands for
yaml 8 markup language that's just a
little tidbit to hide behind your ear so
let's have a look on one of these
playbooks it looks like and here we have
a sample
yaml script that we've written so you
start off your jammer script with three
dashes and that indicates the start of a
script and then the script itself is
actually consistent of two distinct
plays at the top we have play one and
below that we have play two within each
of those plays we define which nodes are
we targeting so here we have a web
server in the top play and in the second
play we have a database server that
we're targeting and then within each of
those server environments we have the
specific tasks that we're looking to
execute so let's step through some of
these tasks we have an install apache
task we have a start apache task and we
have an install my sql task and when we
do that we're going to execute a
specific set of instructions and those
instructions can include installing
apache and then setting the state of the
apache environment or starting the
apache environment and setting up and
running the my sequel environment
so this really isn't too complicated and
that's the really good thing about
working with yaml is it's really
designed to make it easy for you as an
operations lead to be able to configure
the environments that you want to
consistently create so let's take a step
back though we have two hosts we have
web server and database server where do
these names come from well this takes us
into our next stage in the second part
of working with ansible which is the
inventory management part of ansible so
the inventory part of ansible is where
we maintain the structure of our network
environment so what we do here is part
of the structure in creating different
nodes is we've had to create two
different nodes here we have a web
server node and a database of server net
and under web server node we actually
have the names that were actually
pointing to specific machines within
that environment so now when we actually
write our scripts all we have to do is
refer to either web server or database
server and the different servers will
have the instructions from the yammer
script executed on them this makes it
really easy for you to be able to just
point to new services without having to
write out complex instructions so let's
have a look at how ansible actually
works in real world so the real world
environment with is that you'd have the
ansible software installed on a local
machine and then it connects to
different nodes within your network on
the local machine you'll have your first
your playbook which is the set of
instructions for how to set up the
remote nodes and then to identify how
you're going to connect to those nodes
you'll have an inventory we use secure
ssh connections to each of the servers
so we are encrypting the communication
to those servers we're able to grab some
basic facts on each server so we
understand how we can then push out the
playbook to each server and configure
that server remotely the end goal is to
have an environment that is consistent
so this asks you a simple question
what are the major opportunities that
ansible has over chef and puppet
really like to hear your answers in the
comments below pop them in there and
we'll get back to you and really want to
hear how you feel that ansible is a
stronger product or maybe you think it's
a weaker product as it compares to other
similar products in the market here's
the bonus we're going to talk a little
bit about ansible tower so ansible tower
is an extra product that red hat created
that really kind of puts the cherry on
the top of the ice cream or is the icing
on your cake ansible by itself is a
command line tool however as well tower
is a framework that was designed to
access ansible and through the ansible
tower framework we now have an easy to
use gui this really makes it easy for
non-developers to be able to create the
environment that they want to be able to
manage in their devops plan without
having to constantly work with the
command prompt window so instead of
opening up terminal window or command
window and writing out complex
instructions only in text you can now
use drag and drop and mouse click
actions to be able to create your
appropriate playbooks inventories and
pushes for your nodes alright so we
talked a lot about ansful let's take a
look at a specific company that's using
ansible today and in this example we're
going to look at hootsuite now hootsuite
if you not already use their products
and they have a great product hootsuite
is a social media management system they
are able to help with you managing your
pushes of social media content across
all of the popular social media
platforms they're able to provide the
analytics they're able to provide the
tools that marketing and sales teams can
use to be able to assess a sentiment
analysis of the messages that are being
pushed out really grateful and very
popular but part of their popularity
drove a specific problem straight to
hootsuite the challenge they had at
hootsuite is that they had to constantly
go back and rebuild their server
environment and they couldn't do this
continuously and be consistent there was
no standard documentation and they had
to rely on your memory to be able to do
this consistently imagine how complex
this could get as you're scaling up with
a popular product that now has tens of
thousands to hundreds of thousands of
users this is where ansible what came in
and really helped the folks over at
hootsuite today the devops team at
hootsuite write out playbooks that have
specific instructions that define the
architecture and structure of their
hardware nodes and environments and are
able to do that as a standard product
instead of it being a problem in scaling
up their environment they now are able
to rebuild and create new servers in a
matter of
seconds
the bottom line is ansible has been able
to provide hootsuite with it automation
consistent configuration and free up
time from the operations team so that
instead of managing servers they're able
to provide additional new value to the
company ansible is currently the most
trending and popular configuration
management tool and it's used mostly
under the devops approach
so what will you be learning today
you'll learn why you should use ansible
what exactly is ansible the ansible
architecture how ansible works the
various benefits of ansible and finally
we'll have a demo on the installation of
apache or the http package on our client
systems we'll also be hosting a very
simple web page and during this demo
i'll also show you how you can write a
very simple playbook in yemen and your
inventory file
so let's begin why should you use
ansible let's consider a scenario of an
organization where sam is a system
administrator sam is responsible for the
company's infrastructure a company's
infrastructure basically consists of all
its systems this could include your web
servers your database servers the
various repositories and so on so as a
system administrator sam needs to ensure
that all the systems are running the
updated versions of the software now
when you consider a handful of systems
this seems like a pretty simple task sam
can simply go from system to system and
perform the configurations required but
that is not the case with an
organization is it an organization has a
very large infrastructure it could have
hundreds and thousands of systems so
here is where sam's work gets really
difficult not only does it get tougher
sam has to move from system to system
performing the same task over and over
again this makes sam bored not just that
repeating the same task leaves no space
for innovation and without any ideas or
innovation how does the system grow and
the worst of it all is manual labor is
prone to errors so what does sam do well
here is where ansible comes in use with
ansible sam can write simple codes that
are deployed onto all the systems and
configure them to the correct states
so now that we know why we should use
ansible let's look at what exactly is
ansible ansible is an i.t engine that
automates the following tasks so first
we have orchestration orchestration
basically means bringing together of
multiple applications and ensuring an
order in which these are executed so for
example if you consider a web page that
you require to host this webpage stores
all its values that it takes from the
user into a database so the first thing
you must do is ensure that the system
has a database manager and only then do
you host your web page so this kind of
an order is very crucial to ensure that
things work right
next ansible automates configuration
management so configuration management
simply means that all the systems are
maintained at a consistent desired state
other tools that automate configuration
management include puppet and shelf
and finally ansible automates deployment
deployment simply means the deploying of
application onto your servers of
different environments so if you have to
deploy an application on 10 systems with
different environments you don't have to
manually do this anymore because ansible
automates it for you in fact ansible can
also ensure that these applications or
the code are deployed at a certain time
or after regular intervals
now that we know what exactly ansible is
let's look at ansible's architecture
ansible has two main components you have
the local machine and you have your node
or the client machine so the local
machine is where the system
administrator sits he or she installs
ansible here and on the other end you
have your node or the client systems so
in case of ansible there's no supporting
software installed here these are just
the systems that require to be
configured and they are completely
controlled by the local machine at your
local machine you also have a module a
module is a collection of your
configuration files and in case of
ansible these configuration files are
called playbooks
playbooks are written in yaml yaml
stands for yaml ain't a markup language
and it is honestly the easiest language
to understand and learn since it's so
close to english we also have the
inventory the inventory is a file where
you have all your nodes that require
configuration mentioned and based on the
kind of configuration they require they
are also grouped together so later in
the demo we'll have a look at how the
playbook and the inventory is written
and that will probably make it clearer
so of course a local machine needs to
communicate with the client and how is
this done this is done through ssh ssh
is your secure shell which basically
provides a protected communication in an
unprotected environment
okay so we saw the various components of
ansible now how does ansible exactly
work you have your local machine on one
end this is where you install ansible if
you have gone through any previous
material on ansible you would have come
across the term agentless often being
associated with the stool so this is
what agentless means you're installing
ansible only on your local machine and
there's no supporting software or plugin
being installed on your clients this
means that you have no agent on the
other end the local machine has complete
control and hence the term agentless
another term that you would come across
with ansible is push configuration so
since the local machine has complete
control here it pushes the playbooks on
to the notes and thus it's called a push
configuration tool now the playbooks and
the inventory are written at the local
machine and the local machine connects
with the nodes through the ssh client
this step here is optional but it's
always recommended to do so it's where
the facts are collected so facts are
basically the current state of the node
now all this is collected from the node
and sent to the local machine so when
the playbook is executed the task
mentioned in the playbook is compared
against the current status of the note
and only the changes that are required
to be made further are made and once the
playbooks are executed your notes are
configured to the desired states so as i
mentioned before ansible is currently
the most trending tool in the market
under the configuration management
umbrella so let's have a look at the
various benefits of ansible which gives
it this position well ansible is
agentless it's efficient it's flexible
simple important and provides automated
reporting how does it do all this let's
have a look at that agentless as i
already mentioned before you require no
supporting software or plugin installed
on your node or the client system so the
master has complete control and
automatically this means that ansible is
more efficient because now we have more
space in our client and node systems for
other resources and we can get ansible
up and running real quick ansible is
also flexible so an infrastructure is
prone to change very often and ansible
takes no amount of time to adjust to
these changes ansible cannot get any
simpler with your playbooks written in a
language such as yaml which is as close
to english as you can possibly get
air important basically means that if
you have a playbook which needs to be
run n number of systems it would have
the same effect on all of these systems
without any side effect and finally we
have automated reporting so in case of
ansible your playbook has a number of
tasks and all these stars are named so
whenever you run or execute your
playbook it gives a report on which
tasks ran successfully which failed
which clients were not reachable and so
on all this information is very crucial
when you're dealing with a very large
infrastructure and finally we reached
the most exciting part of our tutorial
the hands-on before we move on to the
actual hands-on let me just brief you
through what exactly we'll be doing so
i'll be hosting two virtual boxes both
centos 7 operating systems one would be
my local machine and other my node or
the client machine so on my local
machine first i'll install ansible we
then write the inventory and the
playbook and then simply deploy this
playbook on the client machine there's
just one thing that we need to do is
that we need to check if the
configurations that we mentioned in our
playbook are made right
so we'll now begin our demo this is my
oracle virtualbox here i have my master
system which is the local machine and
this is the client machine so let's have
a look at these two machines this is my
client machine the terminals open right
now so the client machine terminal has a
black background with white text and the
master machine terminal has a white
background with black text just so you
can differentiate between the two so
we'll start at the master machine the
first thing to do is we need to install
our ansible so yum install
ansible hyphen y is the command to do so
so this might take some time
yeah so ansible is installed the next
step we go to our hosts file so host
file here is basically the inventory
it's where you'll specify all your nodes
in our case we just have one node
that's the path to your host file
as you'll see everything here is
commented so just type in the group for
your client notes
so i'm going to name it ansible clients
[Music]
and here we need to type the ip address
of a client machine so my client
machine's ip address is 192.168.2.127
so before you come to this it's advised
that you check the ip address on your
client machine the simple command for
that is ifconfig now once you type the
ip address put a space and here we need
to mention the username and the password
for our client
so i'll be logging in as the root user
so this is the password
and then the user
which is root in my case
that's it now you can save this file
just clear the screen
next we move on to our playbook we need
to write the playbook
so the extension for our playbook is yml
which stands for yaman
and as you can see here i have already
written my playbook but i'll just
explain to you how this is done
so a yaml file always begins with three
dashes this indicates the start of your
yaml file
now the first thing is you need to give
a name to the entire playbook
so i have named it sample book
host is basically where this would be
executed
so as we saw earlier in our inventory i
mentioned clients group name as ansible
clients so we use the same name here
the remote user is the user you'll be
using at your client so in my case
that's root and become true is basically
to indicate that you need to set your
privileges at root so that's called a
privilege escalation
now a playbook consists of tasks
so we have here three tasks the first
task i've named it to install httpd so
what we're doing here is we are
installing our httpd package which is
basically the apache server and we're
installing the most latest version of it
hence the state value is latest the next
task is running httpd so for the service
the name is httpd because that's the
service we need to start running and the
state is started our next task is
creating content so this is the part
where we are creating our web page
so copy because this is the file that
will be created at the client
the content will be welcome
and the destination of the file will be
www.html index.html as you know this is
like a default path that we use to store
all our html files now as you can see
here there's quite a lot of indentation
and when it comes to yaml although it's
very simple to write and very easy to
read
the indentation is very crucial
so the first dash here represents the
highest stage that is the name of the
playbook and all the dashes under task
are slightly shifted towards the right
so if you have two dashes at the same
location they basically mean that they
are siblings so the priority would be
the same
so to ensure that all your tasks are
coming under the tasks label make sure
they are not directly under name
so yeah that's pretty much it so when
you write your yaml file the language is
pretty simple very readable indentation
is absolutely necessary make sure all
your spaces are correctly placed we can
now save this file
next thing we need to check if the
syntax of our yaml file is absolutely
right because that's very crucial
so the command to check the syntax of
the yaml file is ansible playbook
the name of your playbook
syntax check
so we have no syntax errors which is why
the only output you receive is
sample.yml which is the name of your
playbook
so our playbook is ready to be executed
the command to execute the playbook
is ansible playbook
and the name of your playbook
so our playbook is executed as you can
see here gathering facts that's where
all the facts of the note that the
present state of the note is collected
and sent to the local machine so it's
basically to check that if the
configuration changes that we are about
to make is already made
so it's not made we do not have the
httpd package installed on our node so
this is the first change that's made
also if it's not installed of course
it's not running that's the second
change that's made so it's put into the
running state
and a final task which is create content
is under the okay state this means that
the contents already present in the
client machine so i made it this way so
that you can actually see the different
states that's present
so over here we have okay four so four
things are all fine the facts are
gathered two things are changed and one
is already present two changes are made
zero clients are unreachable and zero
tasks have failed so this is the
documentation that i was referring to
previously that ansible provides
automatically
and is very useful as you can see
so our next step we need to just check
on our client machine if all the changes
that we desired are made so let's move
to our client
so this is my client machine so to check
this since we are installing the http
package and hosting a web page the best
way to do it
is open your browser
and type in
localhost
so there you go your apache server is
installed and your web page is hosted
hi guys in this video we have compiled
the most important interview questions
of configuration management tools chef
ansible and puppet that you might face
in a devops interview
so without further ado let's get started
so let's just get into the first section
which is configuration management so one
of the questions that you'll get asked
right away is why do you have ssl
certificates used for chef really
fundamentally your immediate answer
should be security ssl provides for a
very high level of private security and
private and public key pairing this
really is essential to ensure that you
have a secure environment throughout
your entire network the second part
should be that if you're using ssl and
you're using the private public key
model within ssl you're able to
guarantee the systems on your network
that the chef that you'll be able to
validate that the nodes within your
network that chef is validating against
actually are the real nodes themselves
not imposters so you will also be asked
um some questions such as the following
which is the following commands would
you use to stop or disable the http
service when the system boots and you'll
typically get four responses and
there'll be
system ctl disable
dot service or is it system disable http
dot service system disable httpd or the
final option which is system ctl disable
httpd.service
your answer should be the first one
which is hashtag system ctl disable http
dot service so chef comes with a series
of tools that allow it to function
effectively and one of the tools that
you're going to be asked about is what
is test kitchen and test kitchen is
essentially a command line tool that
allows you to be able to test out your
cookbook before you actually deploy it
to a real note so some of the commands
that you would use are for instance if
you want to create an instance of test
kitchen you would do kitchen create if
you want to destroy an instance after
you created it you do kitchen destroy
and if you want to be able to combine
multiple instances you would do kitchen
converge so a question you'll get is
around chef is how does chef apply
differ from chef client so fundamentally
the difference between them is that chef
apply will validate the recipe that
you're working on whereas chef client
looks to apply and validate the entire
cookbook that's run in your server
environment so one is focused on the
recipe and the other is focused on the
entire cookbook
so there are some differences when
you're working with different command
lines so for instance when you're
working with puppets and you're working
with one version of puppets and you want
to do what is the command to sign a
requested certificate the top example
here is for public version 2.7 whereas
the lower option here is for puppet
version
three now something to bear in mind when
you're going through your interview
process is that the tools that are used
within a continuous integration
continuous delivery devops model do vary
and so you want to be able to talk
knowledgeably about the different
versions of the tools so that when
you're talking to your interviewer
you're able to show the deep knowledge
that you have which open source or
community tools do you use to make
puppet more powerful and essentially
this question is going to be asking you
to look beyond the core foundation of
puppet itself and so the three options
you have is uh being able to track
configurations with jira which you
should be doing anyway but it's a great
way to be able to clearly communicate
the work that's being done with puppet
our version control can be extended with
get and then the changes should be
passed through jenkins so the three
tools you want to be looking at
integration with jira git and jenkins so
what are the resources in puppet well
fundamentally there are four the
resources are basic unit of any
configuration management tool they are
the features of the nodes they are the
written catalog and the execution of the
catalog on a node so as we dig deeper
into puppet one of the things that you
are likely to be asked regarding puppet
is what is a class and puppet and so a
class in puppet is really the name
blocks in your manifest that contain the
various configurations and this can
include services files and packages and
we have on the screen here an example of
what a class would look like when you
write it out and you may want to
memorize just one class don't memorize
just a whole set of classes just
memorize one the person that's
interviewing you is just really looking
for someone who has a working knowledge
they're not looking for you to have
memorized complete massive classes but
having one small class to be able to
illustrate the experience you have is
extremely valuable to the interviewer
particularly if it's a technical
interview so as we move into ansible one
of the things that you're going to be
asked around ansible is what is ansible
role so a role is an independent block
of tasks and variable files and
templates embedded with inside of the
playbook so example we have here on the
screen actually shows you one role
within a playbook and in this role it is
to install tomcat on a node again as
with previous question within puppet of
a class it's probably good to have
memorized just one or two roles so you
can talk knowledgeably about ansible
when you're having your interview so
when you're working with ansible when
should you be using the curly brackets
and so just as a frame of reference uh
there's often two different ways that
these kind of brackets are referred to
now they're either referred to as french
brackets or curly brackets either way
and what you'll be wanting to answer is
when would you use these specific types
of brackets within ansible and really
the answer comes down to two things one
is that it makes it easier to
distinguish strings and undefined
variables and the second is for putting
together conditional statements when you
are actually using variables and the
example we have here is this prints the
value of and we have foo and we have to
then put in the variable conditional
statement of foo is defined as something
so what is the best way to make content
reusable and redistributable with
ansible and there's really essentially
three the first is to include a sub
module or another file in your playbook
the second is to import an improvement
of an include which ensures that a file
is added only once and then the third is
roles to manage the tasks within the
playbook
so a question you will be asked is
provide a differences between ansible
and puppets so if we look at ansible
it's a very easy agentless installation
it's based on python you can configure
it with yaml and there are no support
for windows in contrast puppet is an
agent-based installation it's written in
ruby the configuration files are written
in dsl and it has support on all popular
operating systems so we dig deeper into
the actual architecture ansible it has a
much more simple architecture and it's
definitely a push only architecture in
contrast to puppet it's a more
complicated but more sophisticated
architecture where you're able to have a
complete environment managed by the
puppet architecture hello everyone today
we will be looking at the interview
questions which a typical devops
engineer faces in an interview this is
both for people who are new to the
devops world and people who are
experienced in other fields like linux
or production support and are willing or
wanting to move to devops so let's take
a look so pretty much it'll start with
questions about yourself they'll have a
resume in front of them as obviously you
would have sent your resume to them so
they'll look at that and they will ask
you to quickly walk them through your
resume and tell them what you've been
doing in your previous project so you'll
have to summarize this in a way in which
you know kind of walk through all three
layers and you have to tell them that
you worked on a team where you kind of
managed aw the aws part and the
automation part of it
so
that can also include telling them about
any infrastructure deployment scripts
which you have written it could also
include any configuration management
that you've done and deployment
automation you might have done
so it would also include things like
setting up a monitoring system setting
up the entire thing on the cloud
collaborating with teams uh everything
maybe what your code review process is
scrum methodology
whatever you do in your team
they will definitely ask you what uh
your team size was so you could say
you've been working on a team about five
to six people
which would include team leads
consultants managers scrum masters etc
what was your role in the team that's
the typical devops role in which you've
written code for automation of stuff on
the cloud
uh they'll ask how good are you at
programming now this is a typical
question that's asked of a devops
engineer to gauge whether he's fit for
the devops role or not
so you would answer that you've not
written full-fledged applications such
as java or ruby on rails but you're good
at ruby python shell and pearl from a
scripting language perspective
maybe i'm not a full-fledged programmer
but i know the ins and outs of scripts
one of the typical questions is are you
from the dev side or the op side and the
answer is you're from the op side but
you have a good hold on the programming
languages which are used for scripting
and configuration management and
whatever code is required you can write
that easily
they may ask how quickly can you learn
which is a gauge of the candidate's
ability to learn new things and
flexibility to adjust himself to a new
environment
given the chance can you architect an
application the answer is definitely yes
tell them you have been working with
architects recently and that you've been
contributing to the architecture from a
devops perspective and giving your input
so that the application could be
developed in a more easily deployable
manner
given the chance to lead a team can you
do that you'll say yes definitely i have
more than five years experience
typically this is true for people who
have at least five years experience
leaving a team because less than that
would really not be meaningful the next
level of questions that come up in a
devops interview are typically linux
questions these questions could be
anything from the linux world but
typically these are the most common
questions
what is the command to view the cron tab
the command is crontab hyphen l
what is an alias in linux an alias in
linux is something that tells you the
shortcuts on that system these are
defined in the etc rc file what does the
chmod command do the chmod command
basically allows you to change the
permission of a file in linux it can be
changed from read write in executable
mode so it could be changed from read to
read write or to read write execute
depending on the use case
what is ssh port forwarding it's a way
to actually forward your ports through
ssh protocols so it allows you to bypass
firewalls and also tunnel ports through
uh strictly guarded environments so this
is one of the ways which you can connect
to instances or services
in your private subnets in aws or your
data center
the next question is what is a zombie
process now this is about the most
common linux question asked in an
interview zombie process is a process
which is in a terminated state but which
has not yet released the resources so
basically it's most commonly a child
process where the parent has exited but
the child is still there basically its
it's entries in the process table
they'll ask how to check the top cpu
consuming processes and you can use the
top command to check that the top
command gives you a very nice view of
the entire linux process table
looking at the top deployment related
questions which is one of the most
important areas people use to gauge
their candidates one of the questions
which comes up is what is a blue green
deployment so a blue green deployment is
something that
in which you have x number of resources
running your application and say that
number is 10 so you have 10 servers in a
web farm now in a blue green deployment
what you do is take out half of those
from the actual production state you
deploy the new code on those now in the
meantime the other five or the other
half would be serving the production
traffic and these five would not be
hindered or hampered in any way
now the first five in which you complete
the deployment which you've taken out of
the actual production load you put those
back in and you wait for those to come
back into service and then you take the
other five out of the actual load and
you start deploying on those so in a
blue green deployment what happens is
you never let the end user see the
downtime it's an always up environment
how do you do a hot deployment
this is just a rephrasing of the
previous question really a hot
deployment can be done either by having
two environments of the same size and
then you redirect traffic through a load
balancer or a proxy service to one of
the environments deploy it on the other
and then redirect to the first one and
apply it to the second and just like a
blue green deployment you never showed
the end user the downtime
and what is your rollback strategy
this is something you need to be very
confident about because every deployment
should have a rollback associated with
it so let's say your deployment fails
how do you roll back the system it has
to be linked to a blue green or a hot
deployment so you have to say that you
have a jenkins job or a script
which basically does a blue green
deployment and in the middle of that
blue green deployment it checks to see
whether or not services are up and
running and at the least the sgtp
endpoints of your application are
running or not
have you used jenkins for deployment yes
i've used it and you've used it using a
couple of strategies you've used it with
plugins and i've used it with my script
so my plugins used to deploy code on the
environment using build or publish or
ssh and i have also had
my ansible or chef or puppet code which
used to do the deployment for me so we
used to use jenkins as an orchestrator
and puppet and chef and ansible for the
actual deployment of the target service
one of the other common questions from a
deployment perspective is what jenkins
plug-ins have you used
you would say jenkins plug-ins you've
used maven and gradle i've used kobetra
for testing pmd for programmatic mistake
detection aztec for ruby on rails
testing karma for angularjs testing and
integration with s3 i've also used git
plugin for checking out code svn plugin
for checking out svn repositories
upstream downstream plugin for
connecting the builds
in addition to this i've also used
archive artifacts plugin publish html
reports plugin to publish test reports
have you ever used user data for
deployment you answer yes i've used it
in aws so when you have instances behind
load balances we used to use it
it will actually define the deployment
script so that every time a new instance
comes up in the auto scaling group it
has got the latest code on it so that
latest code is checked out using the sh
command which is specified inside the
user data
looking at the aws questions
so what is a vpc a vpc is a slice of the
amazon cloud which they give you to run
your resources
what is the difference between a public
and private subnet a public subnet is a
subnet which is directly accessible from
the internet a private subnet is a
subnet that is not accessible from the
internet it's only accessible from
within the vpc
what is reserved instance a reserved
instance is an instance which is
reserved for you by amazon for a year
and they give you significant price
reductions on that you can buy that no
upfront partial upfront or full upfront
payments and you get discounts from 20
to 60 percent based on the payment type
and terms
what is the difference between spot
instance and reserved instance the spot
instance is like a bid instance where
you have a specific price which you have
bid and based on that you are assigned
instances now the moment your bid is
lower than the next highest bid your
instance is terminated and it's assigned
to the next highest bidder a reserved
instance on the other hand is not a
biddable instance you have to buy it for
specific terms
what is cloud formation cloud formation
is an orchestration or an infrastructure
or a server deployment tool a managed
server deployment tool or service which
amazon provides so it takes a gsun as an
input in that gsun you provide
everything that is required to build up
an environment from vps to servers to
buckets everything so it's an amazon
provided service that lets you build
entire application stacks from scratch
have you used route 53 yes i've used
route 53 i used it for managing dns i
use it to redirect our code id dns to
route 53 using amazon name servers and
then from there in route 53 we used to
create cnm entries a records mx records
txt records and we used to manage the
entire dns from there
what is the best feature of aws which
you like
i like the auto scaling group and the
elastic load balancer because it allows
you to infinitely scale your application
to any level
coming to configuration management
which configuration management tool have
you used
so you can say that you've used all
three chef ansible and puppet in one
project or another i have good hands-on
experience with each of them and i've
written chef cookbooks puppet modules
and ansible playbooks
what is the difference between chef and
ansible so chef is a ruby-based tool you
uses ruby as its main programming
language it's open source just like
ansible chef uses a client server and
client only architecture so the
difference is that ansible is simply an
agentless tool so there is no agent in
ansible whatsoever in chef there are two
methodologies one is agent based and the
other is agentless but if you talk about
the difference one of the differences is
that there is no agent in ansible and
the other difference is ansible uses
yaml uh for defining the state of the
systems and its playbooks whereas chef
uses ruby for defining the state of the
systems in its cookbooks and it's more
of a programming language when it comes
to chef and the yaml inansible is not
really a programming language it's more
of a statically typed code
have you written any cookbooks or
modules and
the playbooks
yes i've used both from
the repositories which each of these
configuration management tools provide
so for chef i've used the chef
supermarket cookbooks and i've also
written custom cookbooks for puffit i've
used modules from puppet forge and i've
written my own modules for custom
applications for ansible i've used the
community provided playbooks as well as
i've written my own custom playbooks for
provisioning of instances on the cloud
as well as managing
and now production support
what is the biggest issue you faced in a
production environment
so you can say that there's an
application we used to run on the cloud
and there was some application
deployment error it was a logical error
in the application which caused an error
behind the elastic load balancer so we
had an elastic load balancer which was
tied to the auto scaling group so it
kind of snowballed the application and
we were not able to control it so the
application scaled infinitely and it was
snowballing the instances so we had to
go in and manually freeze the size of
the auto scaling group once the size was
frozen we were able to go into the
instances check the logs fix the issue
rebuild the imi restart the auto scaling
process so that was one of the biggest
issues in production i faced recently
what is your dr strategy in a live
website
so a dr strategy is that you do a
failover check using route 53 dns so one
of them is a dns based failover in which
you've got an exact replica of your
environment your web servers your
database your cache
so your database may not be synced in
real time with the dr so it could be a
one day behind sync so the traffic is
switched to dr whenever there's a
downtime in production automatically
through a dns switch
the other dr strategy is that you can
have instances in two availability zones
and then you can have your load balancer
to switch traffic based on the
availability of those two zones but that
is a same region dnr so from a
multi-region dnr the best option is to
have a dns based switch and you can also
have an interface tool and interface
proxy which can route traffic based on
the health of your endpoints
how do you scale a production web
service so if you're on the cloud you
can use the auto scaling group which
will scale automatically based on demand
if you don't want to go into instances
and you don't want to manage instances
you can use the elastic bean stock for a
managed stack which takes care of the
load balancing itself
if you have an application which is
already containerized it's a better
practice to run them on ecs on the cloud
which would allow you to scale your
applications based on demand and you can
create an application load balancer
there
if you're in house you can scale your
application by having a container
management system in which you can have
some base hosts on which you run
multiple services so you can keep on
adding multiple hosts to that cluster
and you don't have to worry about the
scaling part because the host can be
added on the fly to that hardware so
your docker cluster like a swarm or a
kubernetes can take care of getting
those new machines into your cluster and
running the containers which are
existing on your cluster on those new
machines thanks a lot everyone this is
all from the interview question
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here
you